WE'RE WAITING FOR MORE MEMBERS
TO ARRIVE SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND STARTED MEETING --
SPECIALLY MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES SOONER YOU GET HERE
THE SOONER WE CAN BEGIN EVEN IN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
.
WILL NOW START DE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY --
WE CALL THE ROLL. ONE TWO THREE
FOUR JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY
THERE KALLIO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS ON THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDARS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. TEN NINETY
FOUR ANDERSON WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS.
ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT SKINNER FOOD
OPTIONS PLANT BASED MEALS AND
ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B. ELEVEN
NINETY ONE IT HUESO CRIMES ELDER
INDEPENDENT ADULT.
ABUSE INVESTIGATIONS MOVE THE
CONSENT CAL.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
IT'S AN CALLARD ADOPTED --
WE HAVE ONE ITEM THAT WAS PULLED
THIS ITEM NUMBER TWENTY S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY SIX STONE WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR THIS ONE
WAS VOTE ONLY.
ON ITEM.
AND THEN I HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
SENATORS.
BOB NAY IF YOU SKINNER OF THE
CHAIR OF UP PUB SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY WILL PRESENTING WILL BE
PRESENTING HER BILL AT
APPROXIMATELY TEN O'CLOCK WE
WILL BE TO COMMITTEE WILL BE
MAKING ALLOWANCES FOR HER TO
MAKE REPRESENTATION.
AT THAT TIME [inaudible]
THAT.
MR HILL YOUR FIRST.
YOUR TWO ITEMS ARE S. B..
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE AND S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR ITEMS IN
THE FOURTEEN AND NINETY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND A
COLLEAGUES SP THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE MAKES IT.
ILLEGAL TO KNOWINGLY AND
INTENTIONALLY OPERATED ON MANNED
AIRCRAFT SYSTEM ON OR ABOVE THE
GROUNDS OF A STATE PRISON OR
JAIL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL RECENT
INCIDENTS OF DRONES BEING USED
TO DROP CAO CONTRABAND INTO
PRISONS AND JAILS FOR EXAMPLE.
IN OCTOBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
SMALL DRONE CRASHED INSIDE THE
PERIMETER OF ELMWOOD
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY
.
MORE BAG CONTAINING DRIVE
ROLLING PAPER.
AMONG OTHER ITEMS WELL SMUGGLING
CONTRABAND INTO PRISON OR JAIL
THROUGH ANY METHOD IS ILLEGAL.
NO STATUTE CURRENTLY BARS DRONES
FROM FLYING NEAR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE UPDATES CURRENT LAW. TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT USING DRONES TO
SMUGGLE CONTRABAND INTO
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES IS ALSO
UNLAWFUL.
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE DOES
NOT PROHIBIT DRONE TECHNOLOGY
BUT INSTEAD CREATES A PENALTY.
SURE ANY UNAUTHORIZED PERSON FOR
OPERATING A DRONE NEAR A PRISON
OR JAIL FACILITY I RESPECTFULLY
EFFORT I'VE OF MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS TORSOS
ALONE WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
I THINK THIS GIVES ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX --
AND PREDICTED.
AUTHOR SAID ALL WELL SO TO SAY
WE ASK YOUR OF OF THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER TO
CALIFORNIA FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY MY FRIEND FROM THE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS REAL QUICKLY
[inaudible]
GO.
I THINK THIS IS A A PRETTY GOOD
BILL BUT I I I NEED TO JUST
LITTLE COURT CLARIFICATION ON
POWER DEFINING.
FLYING OVER PRISON THAT THE TERM
GROUNDS DOESN'T INCLUDE PARKING
LOT THERE ARE WE TALKING.
THE ACTUAL HOUSING AREA DO WE
HAVE ANY CLARIFICATION ON THAT --
MY SENSE IS THIS ANY PROPERTY OF
THE PRISON.
AND I DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER.
IT IS NOT SPECIFIC IN THE BILL
LANGUAGE TALKS ABOUT THE GROUNDS
OF THE THE PRISON BUT WE'RE
HAPPY. TO TO LOOK IT.
FINDING THAT A LITTLE MORE
CLEARLY YEAH I'D GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT OF COURSE I'M
GONNA SUPPORTED TODAY BUT IF YOU
GUYS WOULD OF ACTUALLY CLARIFY
THAT A LITTLE BIT I THINK BE
HELPFUL WILL LOOK AT IT.
WE MAKE IT.
YES IN WITH THAT.
REALLY CLOSE EXPECT WE HAVE
TRIBAL MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK
YOU DUH.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE --
AND I I THINK YOU NEED TO
CLARIFY NOT ONLY.
FOR I GUESS TO THE INDIVIDUAL
WORKER WITHIN THE PRESIDENT BUT
PEOPLE MIGHT YAK BE FLYING A
DRONE ACCIDENTALLY.
NEAR THOSE GROUNDS THEY COULD BE
PROSECUTED AND THAT I'M NOT SURE
OF THAT BUT THAT MAY BE WHERE
AND I AGREE THAT THE THE TO
DISDAIN.
ASSEMBLYMAN IS GETTING TOWARD
ENDED IT IN LOOKING AT THE
GROUNDS OF A PRISON THAT COULD
EXPAND BLOCKS IN HALF A MILE IN
TERMS OF LAND THAT THEY OWN SO I
THINK THE CLARIFICATION SUPPORT
BY APPRECIATED WHO WILL WORK ON
IT GET IT DONE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
NUMBER THAT.
WE NEED A MOTION.
ON S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
THE BILL PASSES.
HERE NEXT BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
THE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR AND YOU KNOW I WANT TO
BEGIN FIRST BY THANKING THE
CHAIR FOR HIS WORK OVER THE
WEEKEND.
AND STAFF --
FOR THEIR OUTSTANDING AN
EXHAUSTIVE WORK ON THIS MEASURE
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE TIME
THAT WAS SPENT THE ENERGY THAT
WAS USED IN THE CREATIVE
THINKING THAT WENT INTO THIS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
PREVIOUSLY S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR ALLOWED THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO IMPOUND
VEHICLES UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION.
AND AUTHORITY RECOMMENDED IN TWO
AUDITS OF P. UC'S TRANSPORTATION
ENFORCEMENT BRANCH HOWEVER IS
CLEARLY POINTED OUT IN THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS SUCH AS THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT CONCERNS.
EXISTING STATUTE ALLOWS THE CPUC
TO SEEK IMPOUND ORDERS TO RECORD.
THE CPUC HAS REPEATEDLY STATED
Y. THESE CURRENT STATUTES
STATUTES ARE INSUFFICIENT TO
PROPERLY ENFORCED CARRIERS.
THESE REASONS INCLUDED DESIRE TO
CONDUCT ON THE SPOT IMPOUNDMENTS
GIVEN THE NATURE OF THE VEHICLES
THAT CP YOU SEE RICK REGULATES.
AND AN INABILITY TO PAY FOR
OVERTIME FOR PEACE OFFICERS TO
ENFORCE VIOLATIONS OF CPUC RULES.
THE CURRENT AMENDMENTS TO SP
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR ADDRESSES
THIS LAST CONCERNED BY ALLOWING
THE COMMISSION.
CONTRACT WITH C. U. CH P. OR
SHERIFF'S TO ENFORCE IMPOUNDMENT
OTHER STATE AGENCIES LIKE THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ALSO HAVE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO CONTRACT
WITH C. H. P. OR SHARES FOR
IMPOUNDMENTS WHICH SEEMS
APPROPRIATE. TO ALLOW THE CPUC
TO DO SIMILARLY THE CPUC
TRANSPORTATION BRANCH ASSESSES A
FEE ON ALL THE ENTITIES THEY
REGULATE.
THIS FEE IS CURRENTLY OPERATING
AT A SURPLUS COVER THE COST OF
SUCH CONTRACTING COLLEAGUES THE
S. TO SEEP UC'S TRANSPORTATION
BRANCH HAS UNDERTAKEN A NUMBER
OF CHANGES OVER THE YEARS.
ALL IN AN EFFORT TO STREAMLINE
THE PROGRAM AND ALLOW FOR THEM
TO DO THEIR JOBS BETTER.
ALLOWING THE CPUC TO CONTRACT
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO UPHOLD
THE VIOLATIONS OF THE CPUC RULES.
IS ONE FINAL PIECE TO ENSURING
ILLEGAL CARRIERS NO LONGER FLOUT
THE LAW I APPRECIATE AND I BOTH
MEMBERS THANK YOU HAVE A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT.
YES YES SIR TO CHAIR MEMBERS
GREG COOK REPRESENT A GREATER
CALIFORNIA LIVERY ASSOCIATION
THIS IS A MAJOR STEP IN
ATTEMPTING TO IMPROVE THE SAFETY
OF PEOPLE TRAVELING IN
CALIFORNIA THE GREATER
CALIFORNIA LIVERY ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER.
BUT THERE ANY OTHER.
CHECK IN NOW.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
MEMBERS OF ANY OTHER INTERVIEWS
WHO LIKE --
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THAT TO
GO SLOW WORK BECAUSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE HERE ESPECIALLY
OUTSIDE.
SO WE MAKE SURE WE GET ANYONE I
WANT TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
WILL BE HEARD NON EDITOR.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I GO RIGHT BACK OUT AGAIN
[inaudible]
NNOVA [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MORE AND I MEMBERS MIGHT ADOPT
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAD PREVIOUSLY
OPPOSED THE BILL AND WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION I'M MORE
GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR AND ON
HIS STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
I AM WORKING ON THE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I'M SEEING NO.
OPPOSITION OF ANY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
I THINK THIS IS VERY MUCH COMMON
SENSE.
THERE IS NO WAY TO KNOW WHETHER
DROWNED FLYING OVERHEAD IS JUST
SOMEBODY TAKING PICTURES.
OVER ON A DIFFERENT BILL SORRY.
SO I LIKE THIS.
ONE TOO SO YOU KNOW HOW IT'S
GOING TO VOTE ON THE OTHER BILLS
IS THE FUND COULD.
COME I WOULD STAY HERE ON THIS
IS A FUN COMMITTEE.
LIKE THIS.
ARE YOU YOU YOU STILL GOODNESS
TO ALL QUIRK OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ARE YOU MAKE CLOTHES REALLY FAST
AND I VOTE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU ALSO WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR FOR WORKING WITH STEFANO
WAS.
BACK AND FORTH AND WE WANT --
WE HAD AFTER YOU WORK.
THROUGH IT ALL IT TO YESTERDAY
AND I'M GLAD WE GOT MORNING SO
THAT'S IT THAT'S REALLY HELPFUL
TO THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MANY BILLS SO I ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU AS THE AUTHOR --
FOR FOR FOR MAKING A COMBINATION
WE GET THIS DONE --
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE BEGAN.
THANK YOU.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY KILEY AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SOME PACO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RICHARD THANK YOU
COLLEGE MACHINE.
SO WE'RE WAITING FOR MR BRADFORD.
CENTER BRADFORD SENATOR PAN
PATTERN.
SENATOR LEYVA --
CENTER PORTANTINO HAS TWO BILLS
A SENATOR GLAZIER
[inaudible]
BUT BUT THAT.
GET FIVE ITS OUR OWN --
SENATOR LARA S. B..
ONE EIGHT THREE SO YOU HAVE
[inaudible]
THREE YES.
A S. B. ONE EIGHT THREE STATE
BUILDING FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AGENTS S. B. TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT
NUMBER ITEM NUMBER.
TEN SUBHUMANS DISORDER LICENSE
CERTIFY TREATMENT SP.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE EITHER A
FIFTEEN JUVENILES FITNESS FOR
JUVENILE COURT.
WHICHEVER ONE YOU WANT TO BEGIN
WITH WHEN WE BEGIN WITH SP ONE A
THREE OF THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERGE
SB ONE EIGHT THE WILL PROHIBIT --
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT ARISE FROM ENTERING
STATE BUILDINGS REFORM
SURVEILLANCE EFFECTUATE AN
ARREST WILL QUESTION INDIVIDUAL
UNLESS THEY POSSESS ABOUT IT
FEDERAL WARRANT TO DO SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR VOTES.
THANK YOU ORDER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
ON RUNNING ON AFTER WAY LOOK
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
HALLWAY STRIVE.
TO DO A PAUSE.
GOOD MORNING MARGO GEORGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS ONE EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS LAW PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR
[inaudible]
YOU.
MIKE ADOPT OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VERY MORE OIL WITH THE CS YOU WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE UP BILL.
WE RESPECTFULLY WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS ON SOME ISSUES REGARDING.
THE INCLUSION OF HIGHER HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THIS IN THIS BILL
IN LIGHT OF THE PASSAGE OF AB
TWENTY ONE FROM FROM LAST YEAR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FRIENDS.
WHEN THE CHIME IN?
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
TWICE AND EIGHT WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
WITH THAT BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A MOTION NO QUESTIONS
YOU MAKE.
YES WHERE MOTION A SECOND YOU
MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
OUR VOTES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING IS
LEGISLATION RIGHT CHAIR
RECOMMENDING I MAY CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. ONE EIGHTY THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOCARDIA CDVA I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU MISTER --
SP.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT YEAH PERFECT.
THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
FOR A SIX MONTH DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION ON THE PATIENT
REFERRALS. FOR ALTERNATIVE
CUSTODY PROGRAMS IT IS OPEN AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUG PRICES HAS
RECEIVED A LOT OF ATTENTION IN
THE LEGISLATURE WHILE FIGHTING
THE OPIOIDS.
PRESCRIPTION CRISIS WE CANNOT
IGNORE THE TREATMENT CENTERS
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES ARE
DESPERATE FOR HELP AND MANY ARE
ARE BEING.
SCAMMED BY UNSCRUPULOUS
TREATMENT BUSINESSES WHO TRADE
PATIENT REFERRALS FOR CASH THE
CALL THIS PATIENT BROKERING.
A AND IT'S LEAVING CALIFORNIA
DOWN THE PATH TO MISERY S. B.
TALL TWENTY EIGHT DEFINES THE
BAND ON PATIENT BROKERING.
DEFINES AND BANDS THE PATIENT
BROKERING WHICH MEANS REFERRING
THE PATIENT FOR EXCHANGE FOR A
KICKBACK COMMISSION OR ANY KIND
OF ECONOMIC BENEFIT.
S. B. TALK TONY ALSO RAISE THE
STANDARDS FOR RECOVERY HOUSING
TO INCLUDE TRANSIT OPTIONS PRINT
FINANCIAL RULES REPORTING OF
PATIENT DEATHS AND THE LOCKS ON
WHICH IS THE OVER DEBT --
WHICH IS THE OVERDOSE PROTECT
TOP PREVENTION DRUG AVAILABLE
WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION AS WE
TALK TO ME ALSO REQUIRES LICENSE
RECOVERY PROGRAMS. TO REFER
PATIENTS ONLY TWO RESIDENCES
THAT PROTECT PATIENTS FROM
PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL ABUSE
THESE REFERRALS ALSO APPLY TO
ALTERNATIVE CUSTODY PROGRAMS.
ADD TO THIS AYE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES WILL
SELECT THE CERTIFICATION.
THE CERTIFYING ORGANIZATION AND
I WILL RESULT IN HIGHER
STANDARDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ADULTS MOVE THE BILL.
RDA WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudibl]
A SELECT COMING UP [inaudible]
SUPPORT.
YEAH.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT OKAY ANY
WOODS IS NOT [inaudible]
BUT CUT EVERYBODY BY SURPRISE.
IT'S VERY POSSIBLE [inaudible]
OF TWENTY BUT KNOW QUICK
CORRECTION ON SB ONE EIGHTY
THREE IT GOES TO JUDICIARY
OFFICE [inaudible]
RIGHT THERE [inaudible]
THURMOND AND YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON AN AD.
SEE IS ME FOR BEING LATE I WAS
VERY PREGNANT IN THE HALL THEY
WOULD LET ME AND BUT I'M HERE
NOW.
I AM DOCTOR WE UNDER CLARK
HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES WE
REPRESENT OVER SEVENTY FIVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE SOME OF WHICH
PROVIDE.
SUBSTANCE USED TO DISORDER
TREATMENT AND OF COURSE WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB.
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT OUR AGENCIES
ARE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACROSS THE LIFE SPAN INCLUDING
ASSISTING INDIVIDUALS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS MANAGE
THEIR CAN DISH AND WITH
APPROPRIATE IN AN INTENSIVE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
INTERVENTION STRATEGIES AND THIS
CAN INCLUDE PARTICIPATION
RESIDENCYPROGRAMS RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT PATIENT IN RECOVERY
FROM SUBSTANCE USE RIGHT THERE
MOST VULNERABLE PERIOD OF
RELAPSE IN THE FIRST FOUR YEARS
AFTER TREATMENT.
IT THAT'S EXACTLY WHEN PATIENTS
ARE MEDICINE LESS PRACTICES THIS
WOULD INCLUDE PATIENT BROKERING
AN INSURANCE FRAUD COMMITTED BY
TREATMENT PROVIDERS.
THIS VULNERABILITY TO RELAPSE
AND ABUSES HEIGHTENS WHEN WE
LOOK AT PEOPLE BEING RELEASED
FROM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ESTIMATES CITED IN THE US
SURGEON GENERAL'S REPORT
RECENTLY INDICATE THAT HALF OF
THE NATIONAL PRETTY PRISON
POPULATION HAS AN ACTIVE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SO HAVING
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY CARE --
RESIDENCIES --
AND HAVING PATIENT PROTECTIONS
IS CRITICAL UPON RELEASE WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE I AM AS MUCH OR
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OF SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN BEHALF OF RECOVERY
FROM NOW IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
A POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS KIRK CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
REGRETFULLY WE DO HAVE TO OPPOSE --
THIS BILL WEEK WE'D.
I APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW FOR
PATIENTS' BROKERING WE THINK
THAT IS A PRACTICE THAT HAS A
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE --
SEEKING AND RECEIVING TREATMENT
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE PROVISIONS
THAT CREATE A CERTIFICATION
PROGRAM --
WITH IN --
SOBER LIVING RESIDENCES AND AND
INDEED DOES NOT ARE RESIDENCES --
PROTECTED UNDER BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL FAIR HOUSING LAW FOR ANY
RESIDENTS UNDER SIX AND UNDER
THERE CANNOT BE RESTRICTIONS ON
THOSE --
HOMES THOSE RESIDENCES THAT
IMPACT INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND INDIVIDUALS IN
TREATMENT PROGRAMS ARE INDEED
PERSONS WITH A DISABILITIES.
SO FOR THAT REASON EVEN THOUGH
THAT IS A PROVISION THAT IS
VOLUNTARY WE STILL BELIEVE THAT
IT --
CROSSES THE LINE ON FAIR HOUSING
LAW BY RESTRICTING THOSE --
HOUSING --
OPTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS.
SO WE OPPOSE LIKE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
K. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE COURT --
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK IT'S VERY MUCH
NEEDED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I I WANTED TO ASK QUESTIONS OF
THE WITNESS SO WE'RE GONNA.
SEE IF WE CAN BRING IT BACK.
I YEAH I JUST HAD A QUESTION FOR
THE I'LL OPPOSITION WITNESS SIDE
COULD YOU JUST ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT YOU THINK THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT IS GOING TO BE
ON THESE FACILITIES --
UNDER SIX PEOPLE AND YOU SAID
IT'S VOLUNTARY BUT YOU STILL
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE HARMFUL
SO YOU JUST EXPLAIN A LITTLE
MORE YES --
SO IT'S A IT'S OUR VIEW
CERTAINLY WHEN THERE ARE
CERTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS THAT
THEN PLACES A LABEL UPON THOSE
THAT ARE CERTIFIED AND THOSE
THAT AREN'T CERTIFIED.
THOSE THAT ARE NOT CERTIFIED GET
LABELED AS THE NOT CERTIFIED AND
THEREFORE --
CARRY THE DETAINED WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY AND ARE SUBJECT.
TO BOTH WE THINK COMMUNITY --
DIRECTION AT THOSE --
AT THOSE HOMES SO IT IMPOSES THE
A OPPORTUNITY.
THIS BILL IMPOSES DENIES THE
OPPORTUNITY --
FOR REFERRALS TO THOSE THAT
CHOOSE NOT TO HAVE THE
CERTIFICATION.
OKAY SO IN THAT SENSE YOU CAN
STILL OPERATE WERE YOU CAN
ACCEPT REFERRALS IF YOU DON'T
HAVE VOLUNTARILY GET THAT THE
CERTIFICATION THAT'S RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS [inaudible]
WE GO.
WERE IN OPPOSITION.
THEY OPPOSITION THOUGH THEIR
SUPPORT THIS KIND OF LONELY VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET INTO THE ROOM.
OTHERS MADNESS OUTSIDE --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD [inaudible] TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS BARBARA LODGE AND I
LIVE IN WEST LOS ANGELES I'M
HERE BECAUSE OF MY TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD SON WHO OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS HAS LIVE NOW COULD
SPEAK LITTLE POTION MICROPHONES
HARD TO AREA.
THAT OVER. TO THANK YOU MY NAME
IS BARBARA LODGE AND I LIVE IN
WEST LOS ANGELES.
I'M HERE BECAUSE MY TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD SON WHO OVER THE PAST
FOUR YEARS HAS LIVED IN THREE
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIA RECOVERY
RESIDENCES.
WHEN HE DEVELOP SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER I COMMITTED ALL OF MY
TIME AND ENERGY TO FINDING HIM
HELP IN A SAFE PLACE TO LIVE?
THE RECOVERY RESIDENTS WE CHOSE
ASSURED US IT WOULD BE A STABLE
AND SUPPORTIVE PLACE FOR HIM.
BUT NOTHING COULD HAVE BEEN
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
WITHIN IS FIRST MONTH MY SON'S
TWO ROOMMATES RELAPSED ON HEROIN
IN THEIR SHARED BATHROOM.
THERE WAS SO MUCH CHAOS AND
YELLING AND POLICE ACTIVITY IN
HOUSE THAT MY SON FILLED
TRIGGERED AN UNPROTECTED.
HOUSE MANAGER CALLED AND ASKED
ME TO PICK HIM UP IN ORDER TO
KEEP HIM SAFE.
IN ANOTHER INCIDENT IN ANOTHER
RESIDENTS MY SONS CLOSE FRIEND
AND ROOMMATE CRAIG.
OVERDOSED ON HEROIN SMUGGLED IN
BY A RESIDENT.
AS THERE WAS NO NALOXONE ON SITE
HE WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL AND
RESUSCITATED.
HE IS NOW BRAIN DEAD FOR LACK OF
OXYGEN.
YET ANOTHER HOME SAID MY SON
WOULD BENEFIT FROM DALY ONE ON
ONE SESSIONS WITH A MENTOR.
IN ADDITION TO THE THOUSANDS I
WAS ALREADY PAIN PER MONTH THE
MENTOR WOULD COST ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER HOUR.
DESPERATE TO TRY EVERYTHING I
AGREED.
WHEN I LEARNED THAT MENTORING
EQUAL PLAYING TENNIS?
AND CLOTHES SHOPPING RATHER THAN
RESUME WRITING I CONTACTED THE
FACILITY TO CANCEL.
THE OFFICE OF PATIENT RETENTION
INSTEAD RECOMMENDED AN INCREASE
IN WEEKLY MENTORING HOURS.
AND THERE WAS THIS WHILE I WAS
PAYING HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS FROM
MONTHLY DRUG TESTING.
THE RESIDENTS WAS SIMULTANEOUSLY
FILING TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLAR CLAIMS WITH MY INSURANCE
FOR THE SAME DRUG TESTS.
OUR STATES LACK OF OVERSIGHT FOR
PEOPLE IN RECOVERY IS ASTOUNDING.
WHEN A DEAR FRIEND'S DAUGHTER
CHRISTIE RELAPSED IN HER
RECOVERY RESIDENT SHE WAS
SUMMARILY THROWN OUT?
THE HOUSE MANAGER DIDN'T EVEN
CALL HER PARENTS.
AND THAT VERY NIGHT HOPELESS AND
WITHOUT OPTIONS SHE STEPPED IN
FRONT OF A MOVING TRAIN AND DIED.
TRISTEN ANOTHER FRIEND'S TWENTY
YEAR OLD SON OVERDOSED AND DIED
ALONE IN HIS APARTMENT WITHIN
HOURS OF GRADUATING FROM HIS
RECOVERY RESIDENTS.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT OVERLOOKS
THE VERY REAL POSSIBILITY OF
SUCH PREVENTABLE DEATHS.
WELL I'M NO EXPERT I KNOW WE CAN
DO BETTER.
IT WASN'T UNTIL MY SON ADMITTED
HIMSELF INTO A RESIDENTS RUN BY
AN ETHICAL PROVIDER THAT HE
FINALLY GOT THE SUPPORT HE
NEEDED.
THIS WAS NOT A FANCY PLACE THERE
ARE NO EXPENSE OF MENTORS HE WAS
THERE WITH PEOPLE WHO HAD LOST
YEARS OF THEIR LIVES TO
SUBSTANCE USE WHO HAD SPENT TIME
IN PRISON AND LIVED ON THE
STREETS.
THESE INDIVIDUALS DID NOT TREAT
HIM LIKE A GUY WITH A DOLLAR
SIGN ON HIS BACK.
THEY OFFERED HIM SUPPORT IN THE
FORM OF RESPECT AND DECENCY AND
THAT'S WHERE HIS RECOVERY REALLY
BEGAN.
WE NEED TO ENACT STRATEGIES AND
SERVICES THAT SUPPORT RECOVERY.
SO THAT WHEN PEOPLE LEAVE THEIR
HEALTHIER THAN WHEN THEY ARRIVE.
I SUPPORT SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE WE NEED
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE THOUSANDS OF PARENTS AND
PATIENTS WHO ARE DESPERATE FOR
YOUR PROTECTION.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
COMMENTS.
GENERAL ELECTROLESS THANK YOU I
MEAN YOU'VE HEARD THE STORIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
IT HAS BEEN.
OKAY IT HAS BEEN PROPERLY --
MOVED AND SECONDED LET'S GOING
TO CALL FOR THE VOTE.
SP TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO BY KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY KILEY AYE
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURE PASSES CENTER THANK YOU
MISTER. ONE MORE ITEM.
YES S. B..
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE YOU MAKE IT
WAS CHAIR MEMBERS S. B. THIRTEEN
ANYONE PROHIBITS CHILDREN AGES
OF FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN FROM
BEING TRIED AS ADULTS IN
CRIMINAL COURT.
AND SUBSEQUENTLY SENT TO THE
ADULT PRISON CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA YOUTH AGES FOURTEEN
AND FIFTEEN WHO COMMIT CRIMES
CAN BE TRIED AS A CAN BE TRIED
AS ADULTS AND SENTENCED TO ADULT
PRISON.
WE DIDN'T ALWAYS DO THIS HOWEVER
THIS PRACTICE WAS STARTED IN THE
NINETIES WHEN THE STATE WAS
TRYING TO A SO CALLED BE.
TOUGH ON CRIME --
BACK BACK THEN SOCIETY BELIEVE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WERE FULLY
DEVELOPED AROUND THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN NOW RESEARCH HAS THE
PUNK THAT MYTH.
COGNITIVE SCIENCE HAS PROVEN
THAT CHILDREN AND ARE VERY
CAPABLE OF CHANGE HOWEVER DUE TO
THE YOUNG AGE FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO MAKE POOR
DECISIONS.
SENDING YOU TO ADULT PRISON DOES
NOT HOW ARE YOU AND IT DOES NOT
MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES ANY SAFER
IN FACT THE PRACTICE HAS
DISPROPORTIONATE AFFECTED BLACK
AND LATINO YOUTH.
JUST OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS 50%
OF LATINO YOUTH 60% OF BLACK YOU
WERE SENT TO ADULT COURT AFTER
TRANSFERRING I TRANSFER HEARING.
COMPARED TO ONLY 10% OF WHITE
YOUTH FOR SIMILAR CRIMES SOME
YOUTH SENTENCED TO ADULT PRISON
MAY HAVE COMMITTED.
VERY SERIOUS CRIME BUT NOT THE
MAJORITY OF THESE CASES IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN ABOUT 72% OF YOU.
UNDER THE AGE OF SIXTEEN WERE
SENT TO ADULT COURT FOR NON
HOMICIDE RELATED CRIMES SUCH AS
BURGLARY ROBBERY AND ASSAULT.
THE YOUNG IF TEENS IN OUR SYSTEM
NEED TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS BUT THEY'RE ALSO
REQUIRE AGE APPROPRIATE SERVICES
AND PROGRAMS TO REHABILITATE AND
GROW INTO HEALTHY MATURE ADULTS.
KEEPING YOU UP IN THE JUVENILE
SYSTEM DOES NOT MEAN THEY GET A
SLAP ON THE WRIST SOME OF THESE
YOUTH MAY HAVE COMMITTED VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES.
AND THEY WILL BE PUNISHED
THROUGH INCARCERATION AT
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
THIS IS STILL PRESENT MEMBERS
JUST WITH AGE APPROPRIATE
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES FOR
YOUTH OFFENDERS.
KEEPING YOUTH IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM MEAN THEY WILL BE
REQUIRED TO BE IN TREATMENT
COUNSELING AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING AND EDUCATION.
PEOPLE IN THE ADULT SYSTEM ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO BE IN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE SENTENCED TO ADULT
PRISON DON'T EVEN HAVE ACCESS TO
ANY TYPE.
OF SERVICES WITH THE BENEFIT OF
THE SERVICES YOUTH FAITH FROM
USE WAY MUCH BETTER IN JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND I'D LEFT LIKELY TO
COMMIT CRIMES --
INTO IN THE FUTURE --
THIS BILL PRIORITIZE.
PUBLIC SAFETY BY PROVIDING AGE
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES AND
EDUCATION TO VULNERABLE YOUTH
EVEN WITH THE SERVICES OF A
YOUNG PERSON IS STILL DEEMED A
DANGER TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
WHEN IT THAT WHEN IT IS TIME FOR
THEM.
TO AGE OUT OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM THERE IS ALREADY
A LAW THAT ALLOWS THEM TO REMAIN
IN THE SYSTEM UNTIL DJJ
DETERMINES THEY ARE NO LONGER A
DANGER TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO SEND OUR
YOUTH TO ADULT PRISONS WHERE
THEY WILL NOT RECEIVE THE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES. TO HELP
THEM GROW TO HEALTHY MATURE
ADULTS WE MUST REJECT THE LAWS
OF THE NINETIES AND THAT HELPED
PERPETUATE NEGATIVE RACIAL
BIASES TOWARDS BLACK AND BROWN
YOU.
THIS LAW SAYS THAT CHILDREN ARE
REDEEMABLE AND SHOULD NOT BE
JUDGED BY THE WORST ACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU --
GIVE WITNESS IN SUPPORT. FIVE
MINUTES ALTOGETHER.
THINK EACH I'M CHAIRPERSON JONES
SAWYER HAND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IS MY HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY.
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE HI MY NAME IS MEGAN LA HAS
GARCIA ARM A LITTLE OVER A WEEK
AGO I JUST GRADUATED WITH MY
BACHELORS DEGREE IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE FROM UC RIVERSIDE.
PRIOR TO THAT IRAN THREE
ASSOCIATE DEGREES WELL WORKING
THREE PART TIME JOBS.
I VOLUNTEER MY COMMUNITY.
AT WITH AT RISK YOUTH I INTERNED
WITH AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
I AM A BOARD MEMBER ON THE
NATIONAL COALITION OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
AND THE YOUNGEST PERSON EVER
APPOINTED AS COMMISSIONER OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY JUVENILE
JUSTICE DELINQUENCY PREVENTION
COMMITTEE.
THIS SUMMER I WAS AWARDED A
FELLOWSHIP TO WORK ON PUBLIC
POLICY ISSUES AND I PLAN TO
ATTEND LAW SCHOOL.
WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN THOUGH?
NOW FOR A SINGLE SECOND WOULD
ANYONE HAVE GUESSED THAT I WOULD
BE HERE WHERE I AM TODAY.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN EASY TO GIVE
UP ON AT FIFTEEN I SOLD DRUGS
AYE VICTIMIZE PEOPLE.
I LOOK TO THE STREET FOR
RECOGNITION.
AND I CARRIED A KNIFE READY TO
USE IT. ONE DAY I MADE THE
DECISION TO USE THAT KNIFE.
AND SOMEONE ALMOST DIED.
I WAS ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
AND FACE BEING TRIED AS AN ADULT.
WHY WOULD HAVE LIKELY RECEIVED A
LIFETIME SENTENCE IN PRISON?
HOWEVER I WAS LUCKY.
INSTEAD OF BEING TRIED AS AN
ADULT WITH CAPTAINS JUVENILE
SYSTEM HAS COMMITTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE.
BEING INCARCERATED IN BJJ WITH.
WAS VERY DIFFICULT AS IT AS IT
IS FOR ALL YOUTH.
BECAUSE IT'S STILL PRESENT
HOWEVER WHILE THERE I GOT HELP.
THROUGHOUT MY CHILDHOOD MY
FATHER WAS EXTREMELY A VERY
ABUSIVE.
I DJJ I RECEIVE COUNSELING I
UNPACKED MY OWN PAIN ANGER AND
SADNESS.
I WAS MENTOR I CAME TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE IMPACT I HOW MY VICTIM AND
MY COMMUNITY.
I WAS REQUIRED TO BE IN SCHOOL
AND I FOUND LOVE FOR IT.
I WAS TREATED LIKE A CHILD I WAS
SOMEONE WHO NEEDED A CHANCE TO
GROW AND LEARN.
AS BE THIRTEEN NINETY ONE WOULD
MEAN THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT
TURN THEIR BACK ON FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS WHO MAKE A
TERRIBLE DECISION BUT INSTEAD
GIVEN THE CHANCE.
I WASN'T IT WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
THAT CALIFORNIA KEPT EVERY
SINGLE FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
NOW WE HAVE HORRIBLE RACIAL AND
GEOGRAPHICAL DISPARITY AND HOW
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS.
ARE TREATED.
AND IT'S JUST NOT ABOUT IT THE
INDIVIDUAL YOUTH RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT TRYING.
YOUTH AS ADULTS IS BAD FOR
PUBLIC SAFETY BECAUSE BEING
TRIED AS AN ADULT.
ARE BEING TRIED AS ADULTS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO COMMIT NEW CRIMES.
THE CHANCE I GOT ALLOWED ME TO
GROW INTO THE MAN I AM.
THE THING I'M ARM PROUDEST OF
LIFE IS BEING A FATHER TO MY ONE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER I THINK
SOMEDAY.
SHE'LL BE GRATEFUL TO THAT HER
FATHER HAD A CHANCE TO BECOME
THE MAN HE IS.
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MAX THANK YOU
CHAIRPERSON JONES SAWYER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
VALERIE THOMPSON I'M THE
ASSISTANT CHIEF PROBATION SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY.
PRIOR TO THAT I WAS WITH THE
VIRGINIA DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I HAVE THIRTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN CONTRIBUTING TO
BUILDING SUCCESSFUL YOU
PROBATION SYSTEMS AND
STABILIZING YOU AND COMMUNITIES.
I'M HERE TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
BECAUSE THE PRACTICE OF
SENTENCING YOUTH AGED FIFTEEN
AND YOUNGER AS ADULTS MUST THE
SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE WILL
ENSURE THAT WE BOTH HOLD YOUTH
ACCOUNTABLE AND SUPPORT THEM.
CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF YOU TO MAKE
MISTAKES EVEN BIG MISTAKES. FOR
YOU TO COMMIT SERIOUS CRIMES THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
PROVIDES EVIDENCE BASED
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES.
THAT SUPPORT YOUTH [inaudible]
ACCESS.
YOU CAN BE HELD THAT DJJ UNTIL
TWENTY FIVE FOR FOURTEEN OR
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD THAT MEANS TEN
OR ELEVEN YEARS OF THE BENEFIT
FROM AGE APPROPRIATE THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES AND INTERVENTIONS.
AND EDUCATION AFFECT THE LAW
REQUIRES THAT YOUTH PARTICIPATE
IN PROGRAMS EDUCATION WHILE IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IN CONTRAST YOU SENATE'S TO
ADULT PRISON ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE IN ANY
REHABILITATION.
THE ADULT SYSTEMS REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES PALE IN COMPARISON TO
THOSE OF THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT SYSTEM OF ALL OF YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCE NIFTY CAN'T TRAUMA.
F. 5275% HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS THESE YOU'VE DESERVED
TO GET THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
WE ALSO CAN'T IGNORE THE
PERVASIVE RACIAL AND ETHNIC
DISPARITIES IN THE DECISION TO
PROSECUTE FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
YEAR OLDS AS ADULTS.
AND CALIFORNIA FOR EVERY TEN
WHITE YOUTH WITH THE TRANSFER
HEARING ONE WAS TRANSFERRED TO
ADULT COURT. FOR EVERY BLACK
YOUTH SIX WERE TRANSFERRED AND
FOR LATINO YOUTH. FIVE WERE
TRANSFERRED TO ADULT COURT.
PERHAPS POLICYMAKERS SHOULD USE
WHAT WE CALL THE MACHO WORLD
WOULD YOU WANT YOUR FOURTEEN OR
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD SENATE SEVEN
ADULT.
I THINK NOT.
I CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY THAT THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
EQUIPPED TO HELP USE TRANSITION
INTO ADULTHOOD WITH LOWER
RECIDIVISM RATES THAN THOSE OF
ADULTS.
MY COUNTY HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
REHABILITATED YOU'VE CHARGED
WITH VERY SERIOUS OFFENSES. ONE
EXAMPLE OF THE BOY WHO WAS
ARRESTED FOR MURDER AT FOURTEEN
FAITH FLIGHT FACED LIFE IN ADULT
PRISON INSTEAD WE RETAINED HIM
IN THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
NOW HE IS OUT WILL GRADUATE FROM
UC DAVIS IN THE FALL.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA HOWEVER THERE
ARE MANY OTHER FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS WHO DID NOT
GET THAT CHANCE OVER ONE
THOUSAND AND TEN YEARS WERE
SENTENCED TO ADULT COURT.
SUPREME COURT DECISIONS EMBRACE
THE DOCTRINE OF DEVELOPMENTAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN CHILDREN AND
ADULTS ACKNOWLEDGING THAT YOU
HAVE A GREATER CAPACITY FOR
CHANGE.
NEUROSCIENCE HAS CONFIRMED WHAT
EVERYONE KNOWS FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS HAVE A LOT OF
GROWING UP TO DO.
IT IS TIME FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LAW TO REFLECT THESE FACTS AND
RESTORE SENSIBLE BALANCE TO OUR
LAWS.
RECOGNIZING THAT YOUNGER
CHILDREN SIMPLY SHOULD NOT BE
OBJECTED TO THE SUBJECT TO THE
ADULT SYSTEM.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BOB DEFINE MINISTER UP
IT DID YOU HAVE ONE MORE WITNESS
OR ITS GOOD OKAY.
EVERYONE THAT'S BEEN SUPPORT
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
M. LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE OF LEARNING OF ELIZABETH
CALVIN WITH HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
AND WE'RE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR
OF THIS.
RIGHT STATES YEAH BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER
PROUD CO SPONSOR ALSO ON BEHALF
OF THE LA COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER
THREATENED TO BE TREATING
CHILDREN LIKE CHILDREN.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK AS FOR
ELEVATOR CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT.
I CAN MORNING ALTAMONT IT THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AND ALSO
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC ON BE HERE.
KIM MIGUEL FROM YOU JUSTICE
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT ALSO
HERE FOR SEMI PADILLA AND STEVEN
AND IS SERVING LIFE SENTENCES AT
FOURTEEN MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HELLO LESTER MASAMI YOU --
APART WE USUALLY USE JUSTICE
COALITION I'M ANOTHER --
MEN OF COLOR WHO HAS HAVE LIKE
EIGHT YEARS OF ANGER MANAGEMENT
THAT IT REALLY HELPED ME OUT IN
LIFE AND I I REALLY SUPPORT HIS
BILL.
AND I HOPE YOU.
TO HELLO MY NAME'S NEXT YEAR I'M
THE REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE SAKE
OF COLLISION FROM WHITTIER
COLLEGE I THINK I HIGHLY
ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO PASS NEW BUDGET NEW LAWS ARE
BEING USED TO OPPRESS PEOPLE
COLOR YOU COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ANA BILLINGSLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE PERRANCE INSTITUTE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I'M CHILLIN SHEER FOUNDER OF
FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT IN NICE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU MA'AM.
LEE WESTERLY A WEST CONSULTING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHERRY STEMMING GONE
WITH SILICON VALLEY DEBUG OVER
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU --
WILLIAM CRAN BURNS INSTITUTE NAM
THE STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
IT'S ABOUT DEATH THROUGH JOE GOT
UP MONA COLLEGE I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE
IN SPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DARCY COVERT STUDENT AT YALE LAW
SCHOOL INTERNET TERENCE'S CHO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE BORN
AND RAISED IN TURN CISCO
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALEX MALIK FROM RESTORE JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
EDU.
KATE CHATFIELD IN FROM RESTORE
JUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
SAMANTHA PRATT AS A PRE LAW
STUDENT AT SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
GOOD MORNING JULIE MY WITH
RESTORED JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MACK
WILSON.
I SUPPORT IS BEYOND ON THE
PRESIDENT.
I ADVOCATE FOR YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I MISS MY NAME ASSERTION DAMN
WITH RESTORE JUSTICE DIAMOND
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS VERONICA.
SHOULD THE MIKE TO MY NAME IS
VERONICA.
GET UP GET UP TO THE MICROPHONE
MY SON MISSING CLOSER THEN WHEN
SHE HOW ABOUT FOURTEEN YEARS OLD --
THANK YOU MA'AM.
EVEN ORGANIZATION [inaudible]
BOOKIT.
MERRY GARVEY LOS ANGELES NINE
ZERO ZERO FOUR NINE AM A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE WITH HUMAN
RIGHTS WATCH AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THIRTEEN NINETY ONE HI MY
NAME IS LOVELL BAYLOR I AM A
MEMBER OF ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND ALSO THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR FREEDOM FOR YOUTH.
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. TWENTY MANY LISTENERS WITH
THE SOME A MEMBER OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN US OF
WHAT IS A RECOVERING I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NICER HAVEN I SUPPORT
THIS AND I'M WHICH ARE THINK YOU
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROBERT GARCIA AND THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
JUST A RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
THOMAS SUPPORT THIRTEEN NINETY
THANK YOU.
HI I'M SHEILA DAWKINS THE
VOLUNTEER OF PAC PEOPLE ACTING
COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL.
HI MY NAME IS YUMMY GRANDMA FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA WITH PACKED
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M ANTHONY ROEBLING THAT YOU
JUST COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
I'M DATA BROWN WHAT DO YOU
JUSTICE COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS TONY UP WHY DO YOU
SAY I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JOSH PINE USE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION PROUD SO.
CO SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
STEVE ROGERS DIGGING IN POWER
NOW TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DENNIS FLYNN WITH CARES FOR YOU
FINISHED STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING ONE OF THE S. WHEN
ISRAEL VIA WOULD MEET BOTTOM
MOTIVATED INDIVIDUAL LEADERSHIP
REPUBLIC ADVANCEMENT AND STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SD THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PRIMENEWS HAD DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS FROM SUPPORT.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME IS AMAR DAS ON
BEHALF OF HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE GOOD MORNING
JENNIFER READING DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEN
MENDOZA I AM THE POLICY
COORDINATOR FOR ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I'M HERE STROKES
BROUGH S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
TELL US AGAIN TEARS WOULD
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS YOLANDA
LEDEZMA AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF SILICON VALLEY DEBUG ADLAI
NAM IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IT [inaudible]
ANY [inaudible]
BOTH GUYS.
THE
NINETY ONE NAME.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION MY NAME IS
CHIP DOES THE EASY I'M WITH THE
WHITE [inaudible]
WHY DO?
THEY WERE ORGANIZATION.
KERRY RAN ON THEY USED JUST AS
COALITION AND I'M.
PORT OF THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
THANK YOU.
MY THE VENICE WITH COMMUNITIES
UNITED FIRST ARGUED JUSTICE IN
OAKLAND AND IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NOT A MATTER EAST --
A FROM SAP IS CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALICE LYNCH PEOPLE ACTING IN
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER SAN JOSE
PART OF PICO I SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
MY NAME IS PRESENT THEIR VALLEY
I'M A FORMERLY INCARCERATED FOUR
POINT A STUDENT AND I SUPPORT
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DESTINY VIA COME FROM SALINAS
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE THINK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S KATRINA REYES
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN ANYWAY.
HELLO MY NAME IS BEN RACKED FROM
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE HI I'M FRANK
IT WAS MINE WITH THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW AND WE
SUPPORT.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE HI MY NAME
IS LAURA RIDOLFI FROM THE W.
HAYWOOD BURNS INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THEIR TO
NINETY ONE MY NAME IS CASSIDY
CROFTON WITH THE ANTI POLICE
TEAR PROJECT AND I SUPPORT THIS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MANY
OTHER RODRIGUEZ I'M FROM SALINAS
CALIFORNIA AND I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF OF THE BILL AS THREE
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE HI MY NAME
IS LYNN WITHIN THE PRISON LAW
OFFICE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE HI MY NAME
IS CATALINA AND I'M.
SILICON VALLEY THE BUT I SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS G. SUN SIGN
FROM THE PACIFIC JUVENILE
DEFENDER CENTER I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
VIDEO.
HOW MANY MISS DOZEN RODRIGUEZ
FROM FROM SALINAS CALIFORNIA AND
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
NINETY ONE THING?
MY NAME'S EUGENE DAY HOW WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE THANK.
MY NAME IS ALL THE ROMERO WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS BOBBY JOE
GARCIA I'M A STUDENT FROM THE
CENTRAL COAST AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THERE TWO MENU.
HELLO MY NAME IS CECILIA CHáVEZ
SAN FRAN SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA IN
A STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS MARILYN NOW PAY
THAT AND NOT I AM FROM LOS
ALAMOS A CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE.
THE SUPPORT IS THE THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE MY NAME'S ANDREW WHEN
ANTI RACISM COALITION POTTERY
BOUNCE EGGMAN STATEMENTS FROM
EXPERT IT'S BILL.
STEPHANIE THOUGHT AND NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH FLY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FREEMAN DOT AND THAT IS WHAT GOT
US COMMITTEE ISSUED A RESOURCE
ADVOCACY IN SERVICES FIRST
REPRESENTING SOUTH SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND WE SUPPORT.
ON HE PREDOMINANT FEATURE IN
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MORNING I MEANDER PUBLIC YOU
KNOW WITH THE YOLO COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS GONNA BE A
FLORIDA SUNBURN SALINAS
CALIFORNIA I'M A STUDENT AND I
AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THERE.
MY NAME IS PUMPING IRON DEL I'M
SIXTEEN AND I'M A STUDENT IN
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MICHAEL WHEN OF A CO FIFTY
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M SALINAS SHAPE
ENOUGH ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR TIGHTLY FROM
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS PHILIP LES JUMPER
Y. JC AN ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION OUT LA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS OSCAR CANNOT LISTEN
I'M FROM THE ANSWER WAS IN
COLLISION I STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS
BILL.
NAME IS REBECCA I CRAMMED WITH
RESTORE JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT
THE SPELL THANK YOU.
MONIES BELINDA'S WITH RESTORE
JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
AS WELL.
ANGELINA ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
SOUTH PARK.
COLBY LANDS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS WE
WORK WITH WOMEN WHO WERE STE
SENT TO STATE PRISON AT THIS
YOUNG AGE WERE HIGHLY
TRAUMATIZED WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER A THING
FROM HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AND I
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
JEROME DIXON BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE ENTIRE CITIZENS COALITION
AND I SUPPORT.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE S. BONUS
WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DARIA LEARY'S A DAY WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SPELL
[inaudible]
WILL.
JASMINE NAMENS NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
NINETY ONE OVERHEAD.
MY NAME IS SERGEANT CON I'M A
DEPUTY PUBLIC DEFENDER WITH
SANTA CLARA COUNTY I STRONGLY
SUPPORT S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHN RODRIGUEZ SOMEWHAT ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS AND YOU BIGELOW I'M
AN ORGANIZER SILICON VALLEY
DEBUG NOW SUPPORT [inaudible]
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE YOU.
ANNA JOHNSON RICHMOND CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA PARA WITH
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVED INJUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LUIS M. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT.
TONY SOKOL WHO YOU JUST THE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
LISTENERS BONE OAKLAND OF FROM
COMMUTER STAR ARE UNITED FOR
SORT OF JUST OUR STRONG SUPPORT
THIRTEEN AND ONE GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DANIEL HERRON WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS FERNANDO FERRER WHAT
THE ENTIRE CITY WITH COALITION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING WHEN THOSE THE AS
DENIM AND THOSE --
POLICY FELLOW FOLLOWS AND
FAMILIES ARE HOOKING A STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY.
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION.
COULD YOU MAKE SOME ROOM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
IT'S STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY TOMAR TALCOTT
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
IN THE LA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
JUVENILES WHO COMMIT CRIMES
INCLUDING SERIOUS CRIMES SHOULD
BE HANDLED WITHIN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND IN THAT REGARD WERE
ABSOLUTELY IN AGREEMENT WITH
SENATOR LARA.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT FITNESS
HEARINGS TO TRANSFER --
A JUVENILE TOOK CRIMINAL COURT
SHOULD BE A RARE OCCURRENCE AND
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IT IS
ABSOLUTELY A VERY RARE
OCCURRENCE.
HOWEVER THERE ARE CASES WERE ALL
PREVIOUS ATTEMPTS AT
REHABILITATING THE MINOR HAVE
FAILED AND A FITNESS HEARING IN
JUVENILE COURT BECOMES NECESSARY
TO GIVE THE JUVENILE COURT JUDGE
THE DISCRETION TO DECIDE --
TO TRANSFER THE MINOR TO
CRIMINAL COURT OR TO NOT
TRANSFER THE MINOR TO CRIMINAL
COURT IT WOULD BE UP TO THE
JUVENILE COURT JUDGE AND IT
WOULD BE OUGHT TO KEEP THE
PUBLIC SAFE. FOR EXAMPLE A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WE HANDLED THE
CASE OF A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
JUVENILE WHO HAD BEEN ON
PROBATION TO THE JUVENILE COURT.
AND WHILE HE WAS ON PROBATION TO
THE JUVENILE COURT HE WAS LIVING
NEXT DOOR TO AN EIGHTY SIX YEAR
OLD DISABLED LADY.
THOUGHT HE KNEW SHE LIVED ALONE.
ONE NIGHT HE BROKE INTO HER HOME
HE STOLE SOME ITEMS HE LEFT AND
THEN CAME BACK THROUGH THE
WINDOW AGAIN.
AND THIS TIME SHE WOKE UP SO HE
GRABBED A KNIFE AND STABBED HER
TO DEATH.
HE THEN LEFT.
AND WITHIN THE SAME NIGHT CAME
BACK BECAUSE HE HAD SEEN A
LAPTOP IN HER KITCHEN.
THAT HE WANTED TO TAKE AND HE
TOOK IT AND HE LEFT.
AND HE ALSO LATER ADMITTED THAT
HE KNEW SHE'D LIVED ALONE AND
THAT'S WHY HE TARGETED HER.
WE ALSO HANDLED THE CASE OF A
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD FEMALE MINOR.
SHE WAS LIVING WITH HER DAD AND
SHE WAS LIVING WITH HER
GRANDPARENTS.
AND SHE AND HER BOYFRIEND HAD
BEEN A STEALING MONEY FROM THE
GRANDPARENTS IN FACT THEY'VE
BEEN USING OF THEIR CHECKS AND
THEY'D BEEN WRITING CHECKS ó
ON THE GRANDPARENTS ACCOUNT
WITHOUT PERMISSION.
AND WHEN THEY WERE DISCOVERED
THE SHE DECIDED SHE WANTED TO
KILL THE GRANDPARENTS.
AND THE FIRST NIGHT THEY WENT
INTO THE GRANDPARENTS BEDROOM
BUT THE DOG STARTED BARKING.
SO THEY LEFT THE NEXT NIGHT THEY
TRIED AGAIN.
THIS TIME THEY CAME BACK BOTH OF
THEM ARMED WITH KNIVES A THE
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD FEMALE MINOR
STABBED HER GRANDMOTHER ONE
HUNDRED AND TWELVE TIMES.
AND SHE KILLED HER GRANDMOTHER.
HER BOYFRIEND STABBED THE
GRANDFATHER FORTY SEVEN TIMES
KILLING HIM.
BOTH OF THE ELDERLY VICTIMS FELL
OUT OF BED [inaudible]
AND THE TWO INDIVIDUALS THEN
PICKED UP THE GRANDPARENTS AND
PUT THEM BACK INTO BED WITH THE
INTENTION OF MAKING IT SEEM AS
THOUGH THEY WERE STILL ASLEEP.
THEY THEN RAN AWAY AND THEY WERE
SEEN DESTROYING EVIDENCE ON A
STORAGE FACILITY.
WE ALSO HANDLE THE CASE OF A
FIFTEEN YEAR OLD MINOR WHO WAS
AN ACTIVE GANG MEMBER.
IN THE JUVENILE COURT HE HAD
BEEN PLACED HOME ON PROBATION HE
HAD BEEN PLACED IN SUITABLE
PLACEMENT.
INFECTED BEEN GIVEN TWO SEPARATE
COMMITMENTS OF CAMP COMMUNITY
PLACEMENT.
AND HE HAD BEEN RELEASED LESS
THAN THREE WEEKS FROM CAMP ABOUT
WHEN HE CAME OUT AND MURDERED A
RIVAL GANG MEMBER.
INDIA'S RARE SITUATIONS WHERE
THE JUVENILE COURT MAY THINK IT
IS APPROPRIATE TO TRANSFER THIS
CASE TO CRIMINAL COURT.
THE JUVENILE COURT WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO DO SO IF THEY'RE NOT
ABLE TO PASS A FITNESS HEARINGS
IN THEIR COURT THEY WOULD NOT
HAVE THAT DISCRETION EVEN IF
THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS MINOR
SHOULD NOT BE RELEASED. OH BY
THE AGE OF TWENTY FIVE THE
JUVENILE COURT WE BELIEVE IS IN
THE BEST POSITION TO KNOW WHO IS
AND WHO WAS NOT FIT FOR BEING
HANDLED WITHIN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE JUVENILE COURT DOES
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO MAKE THESE
IMPORTANT DECISIONS BOTH IN THE
INTEREST OF REHABILITATING THE
MINOR BUT ALSO IN THE INTEREST
OF PROTECTING THE COMMUNITY.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY WERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN PER
SHAUN OFTEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
WERE ALSO IN RESPECT WHAT
POSITION SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
FOR THE REASONS.
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES AND ALSO JUST POINT OUT
THAT THE THE GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE
IN.
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE I THINK
HIS [inaudible]
STORY.
IS IS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW THE
CURRENT SYSTEM WORKS PROPERLY.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH ATTEMPTED
MURDER PRESUMABLY PRIOR TO THE
PASSAGE OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN WHEN
IT COULD HAVE BEEN DIRECTLY
FILED.
INSTEAD THEY WENT TO A FITNESS
HEARING THE JUVENILE COURT
DECIDED THIS PERSON IS SOMEONE
THAT'S BETTER SERVED IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM AND THEY KEPT IN
THERE.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT.
ILLUSTRATES ANY SORT OF A OF A
PROBLEM WITH THE CURRENT SYSTEM
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED --
DIDN'T SO WE WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO TO REJECT THE BILL
AND LEAVE THESE DECISIONS IN THE
HANDS OF THE JUDGES THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN --
IN A VERY STRONG.
SUPPORTERS OF JUDICIAL
DISCRETION IN THE PAST WE WOULD --
SUGGEST THAT THEY THEY CONTINUE
THAT TRACK RECORD TODAY AND
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL ARE JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
OF COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION.
OF THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE THE
ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS.
AND THE LA COUNTY PROFESSIONAL
PEACE OFFICERS ASSOCIATION FOR
THE REASONS ARTICULATED BY MY
TWO COLLEAGUES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RYAN CHAIRMAN
WITH THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHAN FELT OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS COURCELLES
ALONG WE HAVE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION OPPOSITE
THANK YOU.
NOW BRING YOU BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS.
HEARING NONE.
OF YOU MAY CLOSE.
MEMBERS I AGAIN.
YOU KNOW WE WE GOTTA REVERSES
POLICIES FROM THE NINETIES
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN HOLES ARE
DIFFERENT WE GOTTA MAKE SURE WE
GIVE ABILITY TO REHABILITATE.
THAT CAN ONLY HAPPEN IN DJJ
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE THANK YOU BOMB AT AN
IRISH RESPECT THAT BUT ONLY DID
A LOS ANGELES DJ [inaudible]
AND THEIR CONCERNS AND I THINK
WHAT THE SENATE IS TRYING TO DO.
ISLAM.
LOOK AT WHY THESE INDIVIDUALS
DID WHAT THEY DID THEM.
BUT IT WAS A RED WITHOUT A DOUBT
AND NOT EVEN.
WE'RE NOT EVEN HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
BUT ALSO USED THE THE EXAMPLE.
OF A OF A PERSON OFFICE SERVED
IN BEEN.
SERVE TIME IN THE PENITENTIARY.
BECAUSE THEY HAD A POLICE
OFFICER IT WAS BECAUSE HE WAS
HUNGRY HAD NEAT IN A WEEK.
TRYING TO GRAB.
A BURRITO ARM CAME OVER HE CAME
BACK AND HIT SOMEONE IN THE FACE
HAPPENED WEEK LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER BROKE HIS NOSE WAS
CONSIDERED REALLY EGREGIOUS
THROUGH THAT SYSTEM.
HE ULTIMATELY ENDED UP AND AND
THE PRISON SYSTEM.
NO ONE EVER SAT WITH THEM.
AND ASK HIM WHAT WAS A PROBLEM
INSTEAD THEY JUST ASSUMED.
THE THREAT.
BECAUSE HE WAS HUNGRY.
AND I THINK WHAT TO SENATORS TRY
TO GET TO LET'S GET TO THE ROOT
OF THE PROBLEM WHICH IS WHAT.
WE'RE ALL TRYING TO GET TO IT
WHICH FOR THREE ABILITY ACTION
THAT'S WHY [inaudible]
HI I'M.
MOVING FORWARD AND HOPEFULLY
COMMITTEE MOVE FORWARD WITH THEM.
WITH AN AYE RECOMMENDATION THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
VOTE [inaudible]
COLUMBO.
ON SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
BILL DON'T CALL LEGUMES TERM
EVER SPANK YOU.
I BELIEVE MISTER BRADFORD
SENATOR SKINNER.
BOB HAS GRACIOUSLY.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT
[inaudible]
THE LONGER.
THAT WE HAD ANTICIPATED.
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT OUR
KNIGHTS OF NI A WHICH IS SIMPLY
REQUIRE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES A POSTER POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES ONLINE.
THE BILL APPLIES TO ONLY PUBLIC
RECORDS UNDER CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT --
I AUTHORED A SIMILAR BILL LAST
YEAR A. B. THREE FOUR FIVE WHICH
THE GOVERNOR VETOED ANY SAID --
WE NEED TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
PRECISE AND OUT APPROACH THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL EXACTLY GUYS.
MANY AGENCIES ARE READY LISTS --
THEIR TESTING IN --
TRAINING.
ONLINE BECAUSE HE'S TOO SMART
AND RIGHT THING TO DO --
IT HELPS --
BILL TRUSTS IN THE COMMUNITY AND
HELP SAVE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
AND I RESPECT LAST FREE THE AYE
VOTE TODAY I HAVE SUSAN LEFT --
EYES WHO'S A MEMBER THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION HEARING TESTIMONIES
[inaudible]
THANK THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
SEC.
ETCETERA BRADFORD JUST SAID IN
OVER TWENTY COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND ANOTHER TWENTY OR
MORE IN THE WHOLE UNITED STATES
THERE ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THAT ARE CHOOSING ON
THEIR OWN TO PROVIDE ONLINE
PUBLIC RECORDS. TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS AND THAT ALLOWS US
SENATOR BRADFORD SAID BETTER
ACCESS TO INFORMATION MORE
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT SUPPORT.
BETWEEN THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT I WANT TO FOCUS ON JUST FOR
A MOMENT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE THIS IN EFFECT?
IN COMMUNITIES THAT DO NOT YET
HAVE ONLINE PLEASE REGULATIONS
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT PROVIDES
BIG CHALLENGES.
THERE OVER SIX HUNDRED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN
CALIFORNIA.
NONE OF THEM USE STANDARDIZED
LANGUAGE AND LABELS IN THEIR
DESIGNATIONS OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
A PUBLIC RECORD AND IN WITHIN
THE PUBLIC RECORDS.
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PROBLEM IS THIS MAY SOUND REALLY
TRIVIAL BUT IN REALITY IT
CREATES OBSTACLES TO
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THE PUBLIC?
INDIVIDUALS WHO SEEM THESE WHO
SEEK THESE REGULATIONS HAVE NO
WAY TO IDENTIFY WHAT DOCUMENT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR AND
SUBSTANTIVELY.
WHAT THE INFORMATION LOOKS LIKE?
JUST THIS PAST FRIDAY I HAD TO
GO TO COURT TO TRY TO GET A
PUBLIC RECORD THAT THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AGREED WAS A
PUBLIC RECORD.
THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN CPR
<c.green> SAYS THAT WE SHOULD GET</c>
THIS WITHIN TEN DAYS WITHOUT ANY
ARGUMENT.
BUT I HAD TO GET A COURT ORDER
TO GET A PUBLIC RECORD.
IF THIS BILL IS ALREADY IN PLACE
I COULD HAVE JUST GONE ONLINE
AND DOWNLOAD IT MYSELF BUT
INSTEAD I HAD TO HAVE A JUDICIAL
OFFICER ORDER LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
TURN IT OVER TO ME --
S. B. SIX NINE SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD SAY LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THE COST OF COMING TO
COURT IN DEFENDING THEMSELVES.
AND WOULD.
CREATE BETTER ACCESSIBILITY
ASSIST IN EDUCATING THE PUBLIC
HELP PUBLIC AGENCIES TO PROMOTE
THEIR OWN BEST PRACTICES AND
PROVIDE GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY.
ALL OF THOSE GOALS WILL MEET THE
PRESIDENT OBAMA TAX TASK FORCE
ON TWENTY FIRST CENTURY POLICING.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU OR ANY
OTHER WITNESSES TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
Q..
SO BLACK AMERICAN POLITICAL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL WE
THINK THAT IT THAT HE'LL NAME OR
I'M SORRY NAME AND ORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MARGO GEORGE OF FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND PROUD SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ISABELLA DOT THEIR AGE ON BEHALF
OF ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
HELLO LESTER MASSA'S CITIZEN I
SUPPORTIVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO NICK CIGAR --
AND RUBS ENTER FROM THE SOCIAL
COALITION FROM WHITTIER COLLEGE
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
THANK YOU.
LIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON ME HALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DARCY COVERT YA LAW SCHOOL SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE --
BORN REYES INSURANCE IS GOING TO
PUT A SPELL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF MY NAME IS MACK
WILSON ON THE PRESIDENT AVIC
AGAINST OF A STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SIR.
MAKING MORE WITH A CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT MAKE YOU.
A JURY OF HARRY WHILE WE DON'T
HAVE --
OFFICIAL SUPPORT ON THE BILL WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
NOT THAT WE KNOW.
THAT BAY PACKERS BACK UNDER ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WHICH OF MOURNERS CORSO'S ALONG
THE OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION.
OUT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THAT IT IS THE WITNESS
POINTED OUT.
OSTENSIBLY THE DOCUMENTS AND
POLICIES AND STATEMENTS AND
PROCEDURES AS THE BILL ATTEMPTS
TO DEFINE THEM ARE ALREADY
PUBLIC RECORDS.
BUT AGAIN BY THE OPERATION OF
THE BILL AND IT IT HELPED IT.
REFERS ONLY TO DOCUMENTS THAT
ARE ALREADY DISCLOSED BOWL UNDER
THE P. R. A SO THE NET RESULT IS.
A CHANGE IN PROCESS ON HOW THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE PROCESSED.
AND MADE AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW IF
SOMEBODY REQUESTS TO DOCUMENT.
THE RECORDS --
SUPERVISOR THE CLERK WHO
OVERSEES THESE RECORDS --
FINDS A RECORD SOMEBODY IN THE
OPERATION MAKES A DETERMINATION
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT IT'S PUBLIC
DOCUMENT.
AND THEN IT'S RELEASED OR IT'S
NOT BASED ON SECTION SIX TWO
FIFTY FOUR IS THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE EXEMPTION IS THERE
SOME REASON NOT TO DISCLOSE IT.
THAT DECISIONS MADE AND THAT'S
TURNED OVER IT'S NOT UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE PR A THIS BILL
EFFECTIVELY SAYS.
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH ALL YOUR
RECORDS LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
AND DETERMINE IN ADVANCE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE INDEED DISCLOSE
A BOWL UNDER THE PR A AND THEN
AFFIRMATIVELY POST THEM.
AND SO YOU CREATING THIS
UNFUNDED MANDATE TO PUT THESE
RECORDS TO MAKE THEM AVAILABLE.
IN CIRCUMSTANCES PRESUMABLY
WHERE NO ONE HAS ASKED TO SEE
THEM -- SO
FOR THOSE REASONS FOR THE
REASONS WE OPPOSE THE BILL LAST
YEAR WERE STILL OPPOSE THIS YEAR
THANK YOU.
YES CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
DEVELOPMENT CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW WE
HAVE DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE FIVE
SWORN OFFICERS SIX ONE OFFICERS
TEN SWORN OFFICERS IS OUR SMALL
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE USUALLY
UNDERSTAFFED DUE TO INJURIES OR
OTHER REASONS TRAINING ISSUES.
AND TO REQUIRE THEM TO PULL
SOMEONE OFF THE BE. TO GO
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE DOCUMENT
THAT THEY HAVE.
THAT WOULD BE DISCLOSED UNDER
THIS ACT --
SCANNED THROUGH FIND OUT WHAT'S
RELEASABLE WHAT'S NOT AND THEN
POSTED ONLINE FOR SOMEONE WHO
MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT WANT TO COME
AND TAKE A LOOK AT SOME POINT
DOWN THE FUTURE.
AS AN INCREDIBLE BURDEN TO US.
IT ALSO JEOPARDIZE PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE YOUR POINT OFFICERS OFF
THE BEAT. TO GO IN AND SPEND
TIME DOING THAT AND FOR THAT
REASON WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
LIEUTENANT SHIRLEY SO WILLIAM
SALMON AND IN ALL SHARE SOME
BEHALF OF SHERIFF MCMAHON
RESPECTFULLY AND OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MARLON MARSHALL ON BEHALF OF
SHERIFF BILL GORE IN THE SAN
DIEGO SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NEWMAN YOU MAY CLOSE MISTER
BRADFORD AND IF YOU.
WANT TO KIND OF ADDRESS.
THINK I MISSED YOUR MEMBERS ARM
AND I'M.
THANK YOU FOR THE WITNESSES WHO
OF SPOKEN SUPPORT AND EVEN THOSE
IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE I'M ALWAYS
AMAZED THAT THE DIFFICULTY THAT
THEY CREATE.
IT'S SIMPLY A MAKING WHAT IS
ALREADY AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
AVAILABLE ONLINE --
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO PRETTY
MUCH NOW IN SOCIETY AT ITS VIA
THE INTERNET AND TO POST
INFORMATION ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF
NO ONE IS ASKING TO TAKE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
OFF ARE OUT OF THE FIELD BECAUSE
LAW ENFORCEMENT IF SOMEONE
WALKED INTO THE DEPARTMENT.
AND HAD PHYSICALLY REQUIRE ARE
REQUEST TO THE DOCUMENT IT
WOULDN'T BE POLICE OFFICERS
PULLING THAT FILE WOULD BE
ADMINISTRATIVE.
CLERK SO THE USE EXAMPLE THAT
YOU'D BE FORBES FORSMAN OFFICERS
THE LITERALLY KEYSTROKE THIS AND
AS I IT IN THE POLLS MEANT WHEN
I DO.
RESPECT THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
SMALLER DEPARTMENTS BOAT I END
WITH THOSE SMALLER DEPARTMENTS
THERE ARE --
MANOWAR CHALLENGES AND NOW
PERSONNEL CHALLENGES BUT AGAIN --
WITH COMPUTERS YOU CAN SCAN A
DOCUMENT IN A MATTER OF SECONDS
AND IT'S ONLINE WE DOWNLOAD TONS
OF INFORMATION IN THIS BUILDING
EVERYDAY AND IT AND IT WILL WE
MAKE IT AVAILABLE SO WE'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT.
THOSE RECORDS THAT INFORMATION
THOSE TRAINING PROCEDURES THAT
AS WE STATED PLENTY DEPARTMENTS
ARE ALREADY VOLUNTARY DON'T.
AND IN THE GOVERNOR'S WHAT IT
WAS IN THE AGREEMENT TO SEE IF
THEY PASSED ME NARROWED AND THIS
IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES WE REALLY
ARE ELIMINATED STATE AGENCIES.
AND REDUCE IT DOWN THE LOCAL
AGENCIES AND POST --
TRAINING SO ARE BASED ON THOSE
ARE REASONS AND I THINK IT'S A
COMMONSENSE MANAGER IT SAVES
PUBLIC TIME IT SAVES PUBLIC
MONEY AND I THINK WE ALL ARE IN
AGREEMENT THAT TRANSPARENCY
MAKES EVERYTHING BETTER.
AND THIS IS A STRAIGHT FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY
ARE MEASURE THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU --
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. NINE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARDIO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
THAT BUILT ON CALL THANK YOU
MISSED YOUR MEMBERS TO MORE.
BEFORE IT SENATORS SKINNER
PRESENTS I WANT TO ANNOUNCE
ABOUT SENATOR HUESO.
ABA HAS PULLED SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY ARMED AUTHOR
POULTICES ALSO ON VOTE WAS A
VOTE ONLY.
SENATOR WE'RE HERE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS.
I WILL START WITH SB
[inaudible]
ELEVEN NINETY OKAY.
SB ELEVEN NINETY ESTABLISHES THE
EUGENICS STERILIZATION
COMPENSATION PROGRAM TO
COMPENSATE.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS STILL ALIVE
TODAY WHO WERE FORCIBLY
STERILIZED.
DO YOU WHILE THEY WERE BEING
HELD IN A STATE MENTAL HOSPITAL
OUR STATE MENTAL FACILITY --
I MEAN I JUST JUMPED TO MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO ALLOW
THEM -- TO
SPEAK AS I DESCRIBED WHAT IT
DOES [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
MADE A WHO DONE WITH CALIFORNIA
LET THE NUNS FOR REPORT JUSTICE
ALSO KNOWN AS TAYLOR J..
SEALER J. WORK STATEWIDE TO
EMPOWER LATINOS LET THE NEXUS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES
THROUGH COMMUNICATION POLICY
ADVOCACY.
AND COMMUNITY INFORMED RESEARCH
MUCH OF OUR TIME IS SPENT
WORKING WITH COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO
IDENTIFY ISSUES CRITICAL TO THE
IMPROVEMENT OF LATINOS AND
ENSURING REPORT JUSTICE.
CEELO JAY'S MISSION IS TO
ACHIEVE THE TENETS OF REPLY
JUSTICE INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO
PARENT. TO THAT AND SB ELEVEN
NINETY UPHOLDS OUR CONVICTION
THAT EVERY PERSON'S REPRODUCTIVE
CAPACITY.
AND DECISION SHOULD BE
CONTROLLED BY THEMSELVES.
PART OF OUR WORK ALSO INCLUDES
CONNECTING THE DOTS BETWEEN
PEOPLE'S LIVES IN ADVOCACY
THROUGH THE USE OF STORY TELLING.
AND EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE NO
STERILIZATION SURVIVORS HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY.
I CARRY THEIR STORIES WITH ME.
IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD IRISH LOPEZ A MEXICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN STARTED WORKING
AT THE CAL SHIPYARDS IN LOS
ANGELES TO HELP SUPPORT HER
FAMILY.
HOWEVER BEFORE JOINING THE
SHIPYARDS AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN
IRIS WAS COMMITTED TO A
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION AND
STERILIZE.
SIMILARLY IN MARCH OF NINETEEN
THIRTY FOUR FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
MEXICAN AMERICAN MARY FLUNG GO
WAS COMMITTED TO PACIFIC COLONY
ASYLUM A FACILITY SET UP BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO HOUSE THE
INSANE.
SPECIALIST THERE SOON DIAGNOSED
HER WITH PEOPLE MY IT IS TIED TO
SOCIAL DEVIANTS AND TWO MONTHS
LATER HER FOR LOW PAY AND TUBES
WERE REMOVED. EIGHT TAKE ITS ON
FRANCO'S STORY CONTINUES TO
HAUNT HER FAMILY. FOR SEALER DAY
IT IS URGENT AND NECESSARY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PROVIDE REDRESS TO
THE ESTIMATED SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SURVIVORS ALIVE AS OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF THESE
SURVIVORS 62% ARE WOMEN AND 18%
ARE LATINOS LATINOS.
DEMONSTRATING THAT THEIR WORD
GENDER AND RACIAL BIAS SEES IN
THE DETERMINATION OF
STERILIZATION.
LATINO PATIENTS WERE 59% MORE
LIKELY TO BE STERILIZED THEN LOT
NON LATINO PATIENTS AND LATINO
PATIENTS WERE 23% MORE LIKELY TO
BE STERILIZED THE NON LATINO
PATIENTS.
WHILE ALARM MEAN IT IS NOT
SURPRISING TO FIND THAT LATINOS
LATINOS WERE DISPROPORTIONATE
TARGETED AND DEEMED UNFIT TO
PARENT.
RACE AND ETHNICITY IN THE U. S.
HAS ALWAYS BEEN INTERTWINED WITH
EUGENICS EFFORTS AND OTHER
POLICIES OF REPRODUCTIVE
OPPRESSION PAST AND PRESENT.
YOU CHEN EXPLOSIVE TO THE ONE AS
SB ELEVEN NINETY AIMS TO REDRESS
ARE ROOTED IN RACES CLASSES A
REALIST AND SEXES BELIEVES THAT
WOMEN AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE IRRESPONSIBLE
REPRODUCE THERE'S BAD PARENTS
AND DRAINS ON SOCIETY AT
STEREOTYPICAL.
DRIVEN LOGIC.
OTHER MONETARY COMPENSATION
MIGHT NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
HARM SUFFERED BY STERILIZATION
SURVIVORS IT CAN BE A FIRST STEP
IN CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE IN THIS
VIOLENT PAST.
I AM ASKING COMMITTEE REFER
MEMBERS TO REFLECT ON OUR
DICHOTOMOUS HISTORY.
WHILE WE AS A STATE PRIDE
OURSELVES IN PUSHING FORWARD
PROACTIVE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
POLICIES.
ON THE SAME POINT IN OUR STATE
OFFICIALLY ACCOUNTED FOR ONE
THIRD OF ALL STERILIZATIONS THAT
OCCURRED IN THIRTY TWO U. S.
STATES IN THE TWENTIETH CENTURY.
SO HOW DO WE VALUE PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE WHEN THE HISTORY DIPAK
DEPICTS A DIFFERENT STORY.
AND WHY HAS IT TAKEN OUR STATE
SO LONG FOR SURVIVOR SUCH AS
IRIS AND MARY TO BE GIVEN SOME
FORM OF JUSTICE.
TODAY'S VOTE CAN BE A TURNING OF
TIDES IN REGARDS TO THIS HISTORY
EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE BEST REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
IT IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
TRULY EMBODY THE VALUES WE
ALREADY WHO CLAIM TO HOLD DEAR
IT IS TIME TO REMEDY OUR PAST
VIOLATIONS TO THE SURVIVORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES.
IT IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
STAND AGAINST ABUSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE PRACTICES AND
TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF THE LAST
WEEK SB ELEVEN NINETY THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KARLY
MYERS AND I'M AN ATTORNEY FELLOW
WITH THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
EDUCATION AND DEFENSE FUNDS AND
NATIONAL DISABILITY LAW AND
POLICY CENTER THAT PROTECTS IT
ADVANCES THE CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
AS AN ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
PROMOTING EQUALITY AND ALL
ASPECTS OF LIFE WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN NINETY IN
BELIEVE IT WILL PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN ADVANCING DISABILITY
JUSTICE.
BETWEEN NINETEEN OH NINE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AT LEAST
TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
CLASSIFIED AS HAVING
DISABILITIES WERE INVOLUNTARILY
STERILIZED AT THE HANDS OF THE
STATE.
BASED ON INACCURATE IN MISGUIDED
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT DISABILITY
PEOPLE WERE LABELLED QUOTES
MORON IN MISSILE OR MENTALLY
DEFECTIVE.
IN THEY WERE SUMMARILY
STERILIZED.
CALIFORNIA'S EUGENICS
STERILIZATION LAW WAS ONE OF
SEVERAL LAWS IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT ON THEIR FACE
TARGETED PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND IN PRACTICE HAD
A DISPARATE IMPACT ON PEOPLE OF
COLOR WOMEN IN POOR PEOPLE.
THE U. S. SUPREME COURT'S
INFIRMITIES DECISION IN BUCK V.
BELL PERHAPS BEST SUMMARIZES THE
HORRIFIC REASONING BEHIND THE
STERILIZATION LAWS.
IN THE SHAMEFUL WORDS OF JUSTICE
HOLMES IT IS BETTER FOR ALL THE
WORLD IF INSTEAD OF WAITING TO
EXECUTE TO GENERATE OFFSPRING
FOR CRIME OR LET THEM STARVE
BEFORE THEY'RE IMBECILITY.
SOCIETY CAN PREVENT TO THOSE WHO
ARE MANIFESTLY UNFIT FROM
BREEDING THE KINDS. THREE
GENERATIONS OF EMBASSY AISLES
ARE ENOUGH.
AS THE MOST AGGRESSIVE
STERILIZER IN THE COUNTRY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NOW HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DENOUNCE EUGENICS
STERILIZATION LAWS FOR WHAT THEY
WERE.
A FLAGRANT HUMAN RIGHTS ABUSE.
IN RECOGNITION OF THE LASTING
HARM IS THAT THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS INJURED SB ELEVEN
NINETY WILL PROVIDE SURVIVING
INDIVIDUALS WITH MONETARY
COMPENSATION AND IT WILL RAISE.
PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT THE
INJUSTICES THAT THEY FACED.
THROUGH THESE MATERIAL
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS SB ELEVEN NINETY
RECOGNIZE THE HUMAN RIGHT OF
EVERY INDIVIDUAL TO CONTROL THE
REPRODUCTIVE CAPACITY.
IT ACKNOWLEDGES THAT STEREOTYPES
IN ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE QUALITY
OF LIFE OF PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ARE NEVER
LEGITIMATE FACTORS IN EVALUATING
WHAT IS MEDICALLY.
MEDICALLY APPROPRIATE TREATMENTS.
ALL PEOPLE SHOULD BE TREATED
WITH RESPECT AND DIGNITY
REGARDING THEIR LIVES IN
REPRODUCTION. FOR THESE REASONS
THE DISABILITY RIGHTS EDUCATION
AND DEFENSE FUND RESPECTFULLY
ASKS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB
ELEVEN NINETY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SEC.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES A
SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
I SAMANTHA CROSS YELLOW WITH THE
FEMINIST MAJORITY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I SHERMAN GO BOOM WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ISABELLA DOT THEIR AGE WITH
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
COURTESY COVERT YALE LAW SCHOOL
SARIN CISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
YOU'RE ON THE SEMESTER AMASIS
AMBIENCE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NEXTERA ARMOR PRESENTER FOR THE
SAKE OF CUSHION WOULD COLLEGE
AND THE U. SO HE JUST COALITION
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THIS BILL.
CAN MIGUEL FROM THE JUSTICE
COALITION ONE STRONG SUPPORT.
ANTHONY WROTE LIVE AT YOU JUST
COALITION STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS
BILL.
SHE ALEXANDER REPRESENTS SCHOOLS
OUR PRISONS CAMPAIGN AND IT AN
ENTIRE SET OF HIS COALITION.
GOOD MORNING THEM BACK AGAIN --
UNDER PRESIDENT A ADVOCATE FOR
YASSER NOW STRONGLY SUPPORT IT'S
BEYOND NOT THANK YOU FOR LET ME
GET UP AND SPEAK [inaudible]
ACCU.
MY NAME IS YET MEAGER MONTHLY
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA WITH PACKED
AND PICKLES THEY'D WIFE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT OF NINETY AQ.
HI I'M SHEILA FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA WITH PACKED AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THINK.
SUSAN WOLF SENT US A CALIFORNIA
WITH PACKED STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
ALICE LYNCH ALSO FROM SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA WITH PACKED AND ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TONY STARK OR WERE YOU JUST THE
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
CARY REYNOLDS WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
SHE DOES THE EASY BY JCS
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY OTHER.
AFTER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE IN NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MISTER LACKEY [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS IS CLEARLY A WORTHWHILE
ISSUE AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL OBVIOUSLY BUT I DID
HAVE JUST A COUPLE QUICK
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS AS AS IT.
RELATES TO FUNDING.
WHAT WILL BE THE FUNDING SOURCE
AYE AND I NOTICED AT ONE POINT
GENERAL FUND WAS REFERRED BUT IT
WAS CROSSED OUT?
AND AT WHAT LEVEL WE WILL WE BE
COMPENSATED VICTIMS.
DOES MILEY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION BOARD
WOULD OVERSEE THE PROGRAM THE WE
DO NOT SPECIFY THE DOLLAR AMOUNT
PARTLY DUE TO AND IT.
NEEDING AN APPROPRIATION ORDER
FIGURE THAT OUT THE OTHER STATES
THAT WE'VE PATTERN THE BILL
AFTER.
HAVE -- DID
THE USUAL SOME IT'S BEEN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER --
PER VICTIM SO THAT IS THE AMOUNT
WE'RE THINKING WOULD BE PER HOUR
IT WOULD BE --
APPROPRIATE AND IT THAT AMOUNT
IF THERE WERE FOR EXAMPLE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT CLAIMS
THE TOTAL COST FOR COMPENSATION
BE SLIGHTLY LESS THAN FOUR
MILLION WHILE OUR ESTIMATE IS
THAT THERE'S BETWEEN SIX AND
SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE.
WHO WERE ALIVE TODAY THAT?
GROUP BIG EXPERIENCE THIS --
STERILIZATION AND IT WOULD BE
VERY DIFFICULT. TO TO IF THE
BILL SUCCEEDS GIVEN THE ADVANCED
STAGE OF MOST OF THEM.
WHILE EUGENICS STERILIZATIONS
DID CONTINUE INTO SIXTIES AND
SUCH.
THE THE MAJORITY OF THEM WERE
MUCH FROM THE MORE IN THE
THIRTIES AND FORTIES.
SO GIVEN THE ADVANCED AGE AND
THE WE DID NOT PUT.
AND OVER AMOUNT OF ONUS ON IT
WOULD BE MORE APT TO ADVOCACY
GROUPS -- TO
TO TRIED IT TO ASSIST THE
VICTIMS TO COME FORWARD SO
THAT'S WHY WE ESTIMATE THAT
WOULD BE A RELATIVELY LOW NUMBER
THAT DID COME FORWARD.
SO OUR COST ESTIMATE IS BETWEEN
FOUR AND FIVE MILLION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITHOUT.
DO YOU HAVE A IF YOU'RE MICHAEL.
I WANT TO SAY THAT I THINK THIS
IS A VERY GOOD BILL THAT BEGINS
TO WRITE SOME SYSTEMIC
REPRODUCTIVE WRONGS.
WHILE THAT MAY NOT HAVE STARTED
WITH BUT CERTAINLY --
INTENSIFIED EVEN FROM THE
BEGINNING WITH FOLKS LIKE
MARGARET SANGER SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
SPEAKING UP FOR WOMEN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A NEW MAKE CLOTHES I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
RIGHT IN CHAIRS RECOMMENDING AN
AYE VOTE I TO ONE OF THE THANK
YOU. FOR BRINGING THIS THERE.
TO THERE ARE LOT OF WRONG SAID
HAVE HAPPENED IN THE PAST.
A MEASURE AFTER AMERICAN THE
NOSE APPROACH TO SKI EXPERIMENT
AND FOR DECADES --
DOCTORS WERE EXPERIMENTING.
WITH SYPHILIS INJECTED IT INTO
AFTER AMERICANS EVEN AFTER THEY
DISCOVERED A CURE THEY STILL
WERE.
DOING EXPERIMENTS ON AFTER UP
UNTIL NINETEEN SEVENTY WITH ASSN
RECORDS UP UNTIL THEN SO.
IT IS WE NEED TO TO ADDRESS WHAT
WE DO.
AND AS A COUNTRY WHEN WE DO MAKE
MISTAKES.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HOLD UP TO DOES NOT OWN UP TO IT
AND ALSO --
MAKE REPARATIONS SELECT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
CALLED CALDERON SB ELEVEN NINETY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO [inaudible]
BILLS OUT.
THANKS SO MUCH YOU SO NOW I'LL
GO TO S. B. [inaudible]
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AND MOVE.
SO.
WHAT S. B.?
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN DOES.
IS ADDRESSED THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S MURDER STATUTE.
HAS NOT BEEN MODIFIED. FOR
DECADES AND WHEN IT WAS ADOPTED.
IT SWEPT UP.
THE ENGLISH COMMON LAW CONCEPT
OF FELONY MURDER WHICH IS.
AS I INDICATED IN A A COMMON LAW
CONCEPT THAT IS MORE THAN A
CENTURY OLD.
WHICH BASICALLY --
IT IS NOT SO MUCH.
HOLDS.
A BE A CULPABILITY.
IS OF A OF THE PERSON THAT
QUESTION IS LESS A FACTOR.
IN THE CHARGE FOR THE CRIME AND
INSTEAD WHAT IT IS ANYTIME A
CRIME THAT WAS COMMITTED WHERE
DEATH OCCURS.
THE FELONY MURDER RULE SWEEPS
ACT.
THAT THE ANY PARTICIPANT IN THAT
CRIME.
NOW WHAT THAT IN ITS PRACTICAL
EFFECT HAS RESULTED IN IS THAT
WE HAVE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE SERVING LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE
SENTENCES WHO WERE CONVICTED
UNDER THE FELONY MURDER RULE.
WHO WERE NEITHER AWARE THAT A
MURDER OCCURRED?
PLANTS THE MURDER OR COMMITTED
THE MURDER.
AND WHILE WE STILL HAVE ON THE
BOOKS SUCH LAWS AS ACCESSORY TO
MURDER AN ACCOMPLICE TO MURDER
WE HAVE THE ABILITY THROUGH
EXISTING STATUTES. TO CAPTURE
THOSE A WHAT WE MIGHT CALL
PARTICIPANTS IN A CRIME.
AND DEAL WITH THEIR LESS
CULPABILITY THAT DOES NOT HAVE.
TO A APPLY FILL ANY MURDER RULE
TO THOSE WHO HAD A VERY MINIMAL
IF ALMOST A NONEXISTENT ROLE IN
THE CRIME --
SO -- THAT
IS WHAT THIS BILL IS TEMPTED TO
DO IS NARROW THAT STATUTE.
AND NARROW IT IN A WAY THAT
PATTERNS AFTER THE STATE OF OHIO
THE STATE OF KENTUCKY AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATES.
WHO SIMILARLY DID THIS AFTER
COURT CASES WITHIN THEIR STATE
AND WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR OWN --
SUPREME COURT OR SUPERIOR COURT
HAS DESCRIBED THE APPLICATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S FELONY MURDER RULE
AS BARBARIC.
BUT HAS NO I CHANGE THE
SENTENCES AND IS INDICATED THAT
IT IS THE DOMAIN OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM.
SO THAT IS WHY BRING THE BILL TO
IT BEFORE YOU TODAY IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM.
AND I WOULD LIKE ME WITNESSES
NOW -- TO
SPEAK IN.
WITNESSES AND SPORTS TESTIFY
THANK YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES
APIECE.
NOT EACH BUT FIVE MINUTES IN
TOTAL UPS ARE [inaudible]
THE THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS JOCK WHO WILL SEND.
AND THIS IS MY FATHER MAC WILSON.
I HE'S A RETIRED AIRFORCE
SERGEANT SERVED TWO TOURS OF
DUTY IN VIETNAM WITH DISTINCTION.
HE IS MY HERO HE IS MY
INSPIRATION.
THE REASON THAT WE ARE HERE IS
BECAUSE MY YOUNGER BROTHER.
IS CHARGED WITH FELONY MURDER.
IN THIS IS TRUE EVEN THOUGH HE
DID NOT KILL ANYONE.
ATTEMPT TO KILL ANYONE OR INTEND
TO KILL ANYONE.
HE WASN'T EVEN PRESENT AT THE
SCENE.
HOWEVER UNDER THE FELONY MURDER
RULE.
NONE OF THAT MATTERS.
AND TO BE CLEAR.
S. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN DOES NOT
ABOLISH THE FELONY MURDER RULE.
IT MERELY LIMITS ITS APPLICATION.
MY FAMILY IS NOT THE ONLY FAMILY
WHICH HAS BEEN DEVASTATED BY
THIS ANTIQUATED PRACTICE.
THE FELONY MURDER RULE.
HAS TAKEN THE HEAVIEST TOLL ON
YOUNG PEOPLE.
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THIS TOLL CAN ONLY BE MEASURED
AND HEARTBREAK.
MY EIGHTY THREE YEAR OLD FATHERS
[inaudible]
LAST WISH.
THIS TO BE ABLE TO HUG YOUR SON
AGAIN.
MY TWELVE YEAR OLD NIECE.
I ONLY WISH IS TO BE REUNITED
WITH HER FATHER.
IT COST OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO INCARCERATED
PERSON.
THIS BILL WOULD SAVE TAXPAYERS
MILLIONS [inaudible]
FURTHER.
EFFECTIVE LAWYERS LEAVE NO STONE
UNTURNED.
WHEN LITIGATING ACCOMPLICE
LIABILITY FELONY MURDER CASES?
THAT MEANS THAT CASES ARE IN THE
TRIAL COURT FOR YEARS PRIOR TO
TRIAL.
THIS CAN COST THE COURT AND
COUNTIES.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
PER DEFENDANT.
THE PEOPLE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
ARE NOT MURDERERS DESPITE THEIR
LABEL.
THEY ARE OUR SONS AND DAUGHTERS
BROTHERS SISTERS.
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
OVER THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT CALLED
THE FELONY MURDER RULE BARBARIC.
IN ASK THIS LEGISLATURE. TO FIX
IT.
YOU ALL HAVE THE POWER TO MAKE
THAT CHANGE.
WE ASK THAT YOU.
MAKE THAT CHANGE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THE MORNING MY NAME
IS KATE CHATFIELD AND I'M THE
POLICY DIRECTOR OF RESTORE
JUSTICE.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS A
RULE OF INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
IF IS A BEDROCK PRINCIPLE OF THE
LAW AND A FAIRNESS.
THAT A PERSON SHOULD BE PUNISHED
FOR HIS OR HER ACTIONS.
ACCORDING TO HIS OR HER OWN
LEVEL OF INDIVIDUAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND NOT FOR THE ACTIONS OF
ANOTHER.
LIFE SENTENCES FOR NON
PERPETRATORS OF THE FATAL ACT
NOT ONLY FAILS TO PLACE BLAME
WHERE IT BELONGS.
BUT IT ALSO APPROACHES CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
ALLOWS FOR AN INDIVIDUALIZED
ASSESSMENT.
OF THE PARTICIPANTS CULPABILITY.
SOMETHING THAT IS DONE THROUGH
OUT OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WITH THE FELONY MURDER RULE
BEING ONE GLARING EXCEPTION.
THE AVERAGE AGE OF A PERSON
CONVICTED.
UNDER THE FELONY MURDER RULE AS
A NON PERPETRATOR IS TWENTY
YEARS OLD.
PSYCHOLOGICAL RESEARCH CITED BY
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
DEMONSTRATES THAT PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO COGNITIVELY DEVELOP
INTO THEIR MID TWENTIES.
BEFORE THAT TIME YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE NOT FULLY DEVELOPED THE
DECISION MAKING SKILLS TO REMOVE
THEMSELVES FROM DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS PARTICULARLY WHEN
OLDER PEERS ARE INVOLVED
[inaudible]
MOREOVER.
STUDIES REVEALED THAT 72% OF
WOMEN INCARCERATED IN CALIFORNIA
WITH A LIFE SENTENCE UNDER THE
FELONY MURDER RULE WERE NOT THE
PERPETRATORS OF THE HOMICIDE.
THEY WERE ACCOMPLICES IN THE
UNDERLYING CRIME ONLY.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
WOULD ALSO ALLOW RE SENTENCING
FOR PEOPLE WHO DID NOT KILL OR
INTENT TO KILL.
INSTEAD.
THESE INCARCERATED CALIFORNIANS
WOULD BE SENTENCED FOR THE
CRIMES THEY DID COMMIT.
AND WOULD NO LONGER SERVE LIFE
SENTENCES FOR CRIMES THEY DID
NOT COMMIT.
AS OUTLINED IN THIS COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS RESEARCH REVEALS
THERE'S NO DETERRENT EFFECT THE
FELONY MURDER RULE.
S..
IN THE ANALYSIS.
IF THE PRIMARY RATIONALE FOR A
STATE TO RETAIN THE FELONY
MURDER RULE IS TO REDUCE CRIME.
THE STATE SHOULD RECONSIDER THIS
RULE.
PUBLIC SAFETY AND JUST CRIMINAL
LAWS ARE NOT A ZERO SUM GAME.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
STILL PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND HAVE A JUST AND EQUITABLE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SP
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY OF THE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY LIST.
HELLO MY NAME IS DENNIS FLAN AND
CARES FOR YOUTH IS AN
ORGANIZATION I REPRESENT WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
I'M ALSO HERE AS A PARENT OF A
DAUGHTER WHO HAS SERVED TWENTY
TWO YEARS UNDER THE FELONY
MURDER RULE SHE WAS NOT THERE
AND DID NOT PLACES TO PAY.
THANK YOU.
SHERRI STEMMING THOUGH IT
SILICON VALLEY DEBUG IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT THIS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JOANNE SHEER FOUNDER FELONY
MURDER ELIMINATION PROJECT.
MY ONLY CHILD IS SERVING LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE UNDER THIS LAW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
REBEKAH WEICKER OF WITH RESTORE
JUSTICE AND ALSOI AM A SURVIVOR
FAMILY MEMBER MY SISTER WAS A
VICTIM OF HOMICIDE AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
PHILIP LENDERS WOULD RESTORE
JUSTICE AND I SUPPORT HIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MARGOT GEORGE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU.
CAN MIGUEL FROM YOU JUSTICE
COALITION ARE PROUD BECAUSE
SPONSORS OF THIS.
SANDRA WORKED ON BEHALF ONLY A
WAS CONSULTING I SUPPORT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THE WEST FORMER STATE PRISON
NUMBER K. THREE SIX SIX FIVE TO
OUR CURRENT OPERATE OF LIAM WEST
CONSULTING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
SAMANTHA PRESS RESTORE JUSTICE
AND STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT OF
SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY AND I
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
ALEX MALIC UP FROM RESTORED.
PRIDE CO SPONSORS.
AND CARY MOJICA RESIDENT A
BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF ANDREW JAMES OLIVER I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY KINDNESS ELK GROVE CALIFORNIA
AND BEHALF OF OUR SON WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
PETRA HIMES I'M A PARENT OF A
SON THE PRISON AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
JULIE MY WITH RESTORED JUSTICE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SPELL THANK
YOU.
ISABELLA DOT THEIR AGE SOON UP
MONA COLLEGE ON BEHALF OF
ADVOCATES FOR JUSTICE I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY DOCTOR OFF ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS PART.
JANET DAVIS MY SON IS.
NINETEEN AND SERVING LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE.
I'VE HEARD.
BASED ON THE FELONY MURDER RULE
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL MAKE YOU
MA'AM.
CHRIS MORE PRIVATE CITIZEN IS
PART OF THIS BILL.
MANY SOME LARSON ON BEHALF OF MY
FATHER WHO'S BEEN IN JAIL FOR
TWENTY PLUS YEARS THEM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS COURTNEY HILL AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS GREG PHOTO WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU [inaudible]
LET'S.
DARCY COVERED STUDENT YALE LAW
SCHOOL INTERNET TERENCE'S CHO
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SARAH SHOULD BE YEAH
WITH RESTORE JUSTICE WERE PROUD
CO SPONSORED THE SPELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AGAIN A LESSER MISSILE PARA USES
COALITION I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TO THANK YOU LET'S KEEP REMOVED
NICOLAS ERA FROM AND WHAT IT
COLLEGE SO JUST COALITION STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I TRY PARA WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUST AS WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JIM WEINBERGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MEG NOT SURE HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
BURKE STATES YET BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC JUVENILE DEFENDER CENTER
PRATT CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
MARY GARVEY HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
AND HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH SUPPORTS
THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CECILIA CHAVEZ FROM
SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA AND SILICON
VALLEY DEBUG AND WE'RE HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS WELL.
ISRAEL VIA WITH MEAT BY SALINAS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HECK DOESN'T WANT THIS FROM
ANAHEIM CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING THEN MENDOZA WITH
FARMS AND FAMILY WAS SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THE MORNING DESTINY VIA FROM
SALINAS CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
THE FONT STRONG AND THAT US
SUPPORT IN THIS BILL THINK THANK
YOU THING ABOUT THIRTY MORE
PLANES BUDGETS ARE RALLY AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S KATRINA
REASSIGNMENTS FROM SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
WHEN IT IS LOVELL BAYLOR AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL?
HI MY NAME SALINAS CHAPMAN FROM
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I'M ANTHONY ROEBLING TO DO
JUSTICE COALITION WE'RE BROKE A
CO SPONSOR THE BILL THANK.
MY NAME IS TONY AMATO IDC I'M A
CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS JERRY BROWN WOULD YOU
JUSTICE COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
BECAUSE UNDER SEPARATE TINA
WITHOUT HE GETS JUSTICE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY DOCTOR ARE SPEAKING FOR THE
ELEVATOR FIRST CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT.
THROUGH WYNN'S LA CAN YOU
JUSTICE COALITION ALICE AFFECTED
BODIES ARE CONNECTED WHO WE HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE.
THANK YOU NAME IT ORGANIZATION.
I NAMES CARRY AROUND OUTSIDE
WITH THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CHIU DOZY EASY WHY JC
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS RICK I LOVE IT NAY
YES I MAKE INTERN WITH
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND I
SUPPORT HIS BILL BECAUSE WE
CAN'T EVEN HOMELESS ACCOUNTING
HUMAN ONE WILL PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE THANK YOU.
DARIA THERE IS TODAY NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE SPELL.
FRANKIE WAS MY NATIONAL CENTER
FOR UTILIZED ON SUPPORT OF BILL --
ESPANA IS ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
FERNANDO FERRER ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND US PUT THE BILL.
MICHELMAN THOSE WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IS
TRANSPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER READING DEPUTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN A MASSAGE ALEXANDER MUSICALS
LA PRISONS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CUT MENDOZA WITH ANTI RECIDIVISM
CLINICIAN AND STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHEN UTILITIES AND WITH THE
INTENT WAS TO HIS A COALITION
ITSELF WHEN IT'S A RECOVERY AND
THAT'S FUN TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THINKING?
IT TEARS AWAY SILICON VALLEY DO
RECOGNIZED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KNOW I KNOW IT DOES
MOST SILICON VALLEY DEBUG I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
NICE SAVE WHICH SAURON I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBERT GARCIA DOES A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE INITIATIVE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
DANIEL HERRON ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL --
EVEN I'M A TEACHER IN OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
JOSH PINE USE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION PROUD SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHN RODRIGUEZ ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
PHILIP LESSER Y. JC IN A RC FROM
A STRONG SUPPORT HIS BILL.
IS AUTHOR GONZALEZ.
WHO WOMAN A SUBSTANCE MEN OF
HONOR AND ANTI RECEIVING
COLLISION I STRONGLY SUPPORT HIS
BILL?
MY NAME IS CATENA APPEARANCES
KAYLA FOLLOWING FROM AL GROW BY
MY MOM MY HEART MY SON IS
HARMLESS DAVIS AND THAT IS
JAMES BIRCH POLICY DIRECTOR ANTI
PLEASE TEAR PROJECT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ANDREW BIGELOW AND
ORGANIZE A SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ANDREW NGUYEN POTTERY ABOUT
SEXUAL STATE INTEREST IS IN
COALITION STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
EUGENE DAY ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
SUSAN WELL VOLUNTARY PACKED I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SHE WOULD NOT GO SO THEY
CALIFORNIA WITH PAC STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU BECOME A SAN JOSE AGE WITH
PACKED BECAUSE STATE WIDE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALICE LYNCH PACKED SAN JOSE I
MY NAME IS LAKE I SUPPORT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BEATRICE LOVE NO BLOOD CAMPAIGN
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
COLBY LANDS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR WOMEN PRISONERS
AND SURVIVED AND PUNISHED
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TEDDY SO COR WILL YOU JUST OF
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THINK.
ANA BILLINGSLEY PRIVATE CITIZENS
EVINCES CON STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL.
MY VENDORS WITH COMMUNITIES
UNITED FOR STUDY JUST ISN'T
STRONG SUPPORT.
BUT ON OUR MERRY WAY SEVEN
SERVICES CALIFORNIAN AYE STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
STEVE ROGERS TECHNIUM POWER NOW
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SAUDI BEEN VERY WITH THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION I'M STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
HELLO MY NAME IS KAYLA MCGRAW
ENOUGH SUPPORT HIS BILL.
MONEY WAS AMONG NOT AND THAT IS
REPRESENTING GOT US FROM SOUTH
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
EITHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. FIVE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT [inaudible]
ONE OKAY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ONE MORE ONE MORE
SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION.
CITY WHATEVER --
PIECE OF IMPORTED CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE CHAIR IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING.
CRACK MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SHAUNA HOFFMAN.
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION OF IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO S. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN CDA IS.
OPEN TO THE IDEA OF REVISITING
THE APPLICATION OF THE FELONY
MURDER RULE --
TO AND WE'VE SUPPORTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER'S BILL EARLIER
THIS YEAR WE'VE ALSO HAD VERY --
I WOULD CHARACTERIZE IT AS VERY
POSITIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH.
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS --
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
HOWEVER AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED SP
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WE BELIEVE
IS FLAWED IN INTO VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAYS.
FIRST.
THE BILL ELIMINATES ANY
ADDITIONAL LIABILITY THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT SOMEBODY LOST
THEIR LIFE.
IN THE COMMISSION OF THE
UNDERLYING FELONY --
THESE ARE CRIMES THAT HAVE
VICTIMS WHO DESERVE SOME MEASURE
OF FINALITY AT SENTENCING.
AND SO TO TWO RECENT SOMEONE TO
SIMPLY THE SENTENCE FOR THE
UNDERLYING FELONY.
WE BELIEVE --
DOES NOT APPROPRIATELY KNOWLEDGE
LEVEL OF CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT
THAT.
OCCURRED I IN THAT INCIDENT.
SECOND AND IN THIS GETS A LITTLE
MORE TECHNICAL ON THE RE
SENTENCING ASPECT OF IT BUT THE
BILL'S FULLY RETROACTIVE AND
APPLIES CURRENTLY TWO
CONVICTIONS OBTAINED BY PLEA.
PLACING A BURDEN ON THE
PROSECUTION TO PROVE
INELIGIBILITY FOR RELIEF BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT.
IN CERTAIN CASES THIS WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE --
WHEN THERE'S A PLEA THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT?
WE DON'T DO IT WHEN THE
INVESTIGATION AT THAT POINT. FOR
FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES IT
STOPS [inaudible]
AND SO.
IT FOR NOW IN EFFECT ASKING US
TO GO BACK AND RE TRY THE CASE
ON THE ISSUE OF ELIGIBILITY.
I YEARS OR DECADES LATER PERHAPS
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF WITNESSES
AND WITHOUT EVEN COMPLETE
INVESTIGATIVE FILE AND HAVING TO
PROVE.
INELIGIBILITY BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
THAT'S A BURDEN THAT WE WILL BE
UNABLE TO MEET WHICH WILL RESULT
IN PEOPLE WHO.
MAY NOT BE --
THE THE INTENDED TARGET OF THIS
RELIEF.
HAVING THAT RELIEF EXTEND TO
THEM WHICH WE BELIEVE MAKES THE
COMMUNITY UNSAFE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THE AUTHOR --
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE WHERE --
EVERYBODY'S COMFORTABLE BUT I AS
THE BILL'S DRAFTED TODAY WE ARE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
ON KEPT KEY WAS MCCUE CAPTAIN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF I WOULD ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE HON OF THE
DA'S.
ARE REGARDING THE CONCERNS IT'S
JUST FROM A VICTIM'S PERSPECTIVE
I WOULD JUST TO KNOW CONCERNS
RELATIVE.
TO AYE THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE A
VICTIM --
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT THE CASE
HAD BEEN RESOLVED BEHIND THAT ON
JUSTICE ARE FOR THE VICTIM HAD
BEEN SERVED BUT WOULD ULTIMATELY
BE PULLED BACK.
ON INTO A SITUATION WHERE THERE
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS JUST
ABOUT PROCESS ABOUT VICTIM
INVOLVEMENT IN ENGAGEMENT --
AND HOW THAT WOULD PLAY OUT IN
TERMS OF THOSE ON RIGHTS
AFFORDED TO VICTIMS UNDER
MARCY'S LAW ON STATE LAWSUIT
WITHOUT WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR WE'VE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
HER SPONSORS.
ABOUT US SOME POTENTIAL BUT ON
DISCUSSIONS AND AMENDMENTS AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE OF THE
DIALOGUE THAT'S FAR AND FORWARD
BONTA THE CONTINUE CONVERSATION
HOPEFULLY REMOVE IN OPPOSITION
AT SOME POINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION YES SIDE JOHN LEVEL
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
OF THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WE CALIFORNIA
NARCOTICS OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
OF THE ASSOCIATION FOR LOS
ANGELES DEPUTY SHERIFF'S THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE.
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PROFESSIONAL POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE PRIOR WITNESSES
ARE OPPOSITION.
IS ROOTED IN THE BILL AS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED.
BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUING DISCUSSION.
AMONG THE PARTIES --
AS OF THE PREVIOUS WITNESSES
HAVE SAID WE ARE NOT OPPOSED PER
SE TO REFORM OF THE FELONY
MURDER RULE.
BUT WE DO HAVE ISSUES --
WITH THE WAY THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY CRAFTED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
CORSO'S ALONG THE HAVE A
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION FOR THE REASONS
STATED IN OPPOSITION.
TOMAR TOKAT DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENT FORM
FORM OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
MAKE.
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN THE FILMING
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND NOW TURNED OVER TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS A BILL.
MOVE THE BELL SECOND
[inaudible]
SO.
OKAY SO I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
[inaudible]
IF PHAM.
THE GENTLEMAN HERE MADE SOME --
OFFERED SOME VERY LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS IF YOU WOULD CARE TO
RESPOND I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS HE SAID WAS --
TO RECENT ON THE UNDERLYING
FELONY DOESN'T REALLY
ACKNOWLEDGE OTHER VICTIMS SO
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO KIND OF
RESPOND TO THAT.
THANK YOU I WILL I WILL I AM DO
SO APPRECIATE THE QUESTION THAT.
I WANT TO PREFACE IT WITH THE
FACT THAT [inaudible]
WHAT -- I
WILL DESCRIBE THE AMENDMENTS WE
HAVE TAKEN TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS BUT I WANNA PREFACE IT
WITH [inaudible]
THAT WHILE.
REGARDLESS OF HOW WE AMEND THIS
BILL.
THE FACT REMAINS THAT THERE ARE.
PEOPLE WHO.
HAD THE SAME ROLE.
IN THE COMMISSION OF A FELONY
WERE A DEATH OCCURRED WHO ARE
NOT SENTENCED UNDER FELONY
MURDER.
AND THEN THERE A GREAT DEAL WHO
ARE.
SO WE HAVE ALREADY IN EXTREMELY
UNEQUAL CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE THE
LIVE LAW WAS NOT APPLIED TO ALL.
SO IN OTHER WORDS EVERYONE.
WHO IF WE IF WE HAD OUR WITNESS
AT THE TABLE WHO DESCRIBES HIS
SON CIRCUMSTANCE?
WE COULD EVERY SIMILAR PERSON.
WHO DID NOT GET CHARGED THAT WAY
AS HIS SON DID?
AND WE HAVE --
THERE'S BEEN A GREAT DATA TO
THAT EFFECT --
SO OF COURSE IN WHAT
UNFORTUNATELY OCCUR SO OFTEN.
IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM IS YOUR IN
ADEQUACY OF REPRESENTATION.
BECAUSE EITHER DUE TO POVERTY OR
OTHER REASONS.
AND THEN YOU MIGHT DO A PLEA
BARGAIN.
IN A CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE ANOTHER
PERSON WITH BETTER
REPRESENTATION DID NOT AND YET
YOUR ROLE IN THE PARTICULAR
CRIME WAS EQUAL.
SO I JUST WANTED TO FIRST PUT
THAT IN THE RECORD NOW WE HAVE
BEEN MEETING.
FROM THE DAY I INTRODUCED EVEN
PRIOR TO THE INTRODUCTION OF
THIS BILL WITH THE DA'S AND WITH
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN ORDER TO TRY TO GET TO A
POINT WHERE WE HAVE.
A REFORM TO CALIFORNIA'S FELONY
MURDER RULE THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE.
AND WE'VE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS.
THAT OH ON THE SUGGESTION OF THE
DA'S INCLUDING WE CLARIFIED THAT
CERTAIN PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
CONSIDERED THE MASTERMIND BEHIND
A CRIME SO JUST AS AGAIN --
CLARIFICATION [inaudible]
IF.
ALREADY UNDER THE WAY THE LAWS
THE BILL AS WRITTEN IF YOU --
PLANNED THE MURDER IF YOU --
PAID SOMEONE FOR THAT MURDER IF
IT DIDN'T VARIETY OF OTHER VERY
SPECIFIC ROLES IN IT THAT ART
CHEST THE ACTUAL MURDERER.
YOU WOULD NOT BENEFIT FROM THIS
CHANGE BUT WE ALSO CLARIFIED
THAT PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
CONSIDERED THE MASTERMIND.
MASTERMIND WOULD NOT BE COVERED
BY THIS BILL AND COULD STILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE UNDER THE
FELONY MURDER RULE.
WE ALSO --
CLARIFIED THAT PEOPLE WHO EIGHT
COVERED IN THIS BILL AND THEY
ARE IN ELIGIBLE FOR RE
SENTENCING.
AND FINALLY WE FLIPPED THE
BURDEN OF PROOF SO THE
PROSECUTION NO LONGER HAS TO
PROVE.
IN THE RECENT SING PROCESS BUT
RATHER THE PETITIONER MUST PROVE
THAT THEY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
RELIEF AND THAT SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSED CONCERNS.
OF THE DA'S ASSOCIATION BECAUSE
THE ORIGINAL BILL PLACE THEBURDEN ON THE DA'S SHOW THAT THE
PETITIONER WAS INELIGIBLE BEYOND
REASONABLE DOUBT.
SO WE ARE STILL IN CONVERSATION.
TO SEE WHAT MIGHT A ADDITIONALLY
ADDRESS CONCERNS BUT I THINK THE
DA'S OF REP WOULD DESCRIBE THAT
WE HAVE BEEN.
IN CONSTANT COMMUNICATION AND
HAVE TAKEN AND I'D NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO DATE.
AND FOR THE RECORD YOU IT'S NOT
GIVING FOLKS A FREE PASS YOU
STILL HAVE NOT ADDITION S.
RECENT IN THING RIGHT CORRECT.
CORRECT IMPROVE THE YES AND YOU
STILL MAINTAIN A STRIKE CORRECT.
ON YOUR REFERENCE YES.
SO IT'S NOT WERE BEING
INTENTIONAL.
WITH IRAQ TALK ABOUT BEING TOUGH
ON CRIME ARE SOFT ON CRIME YOU
COULD SAY THIS IS ABOUT BEING
INTENTIONAL.
RIGHT THIS IS THIS IS ALIGNING.
THE CHARGE AND THE SENTENCE WITH
YOUR ROLE IN THE CRIME SO YOU AS
YOU OF ACCURATELY POINTED OUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YOU WOULD STILL BE A THAT WOULD
BE.
YOUR UNDERLYING CRIME WOULD
STILL BE A STRIKE UNDER THE
THREE STRIKES LAW.
BUT YOU WOULD NOT BE IF YOU IF
YOU MET THE CONDITIONS OUTLINED
IN THE BILL.
YOU WOULD JUST HAVE THE ABILITY
TO BE RE SENTENCED FOR YOUR ROLE
IN THAT CRIME [inaudible]
YOU.
OKAY MCKINNEY ANY OF KILEY.
A QUESTION FOR THE OPPOSITION
THE AND WHAT DO YOU BELIEVE IS
THAT DETERRENCE VALUE OF THE
FELONY MURDER RULE EITHER ITS
CURRENT VERSION OR WHATEVER
REFORM VERSION YOU'D BE.
COMFORTABLE WITH.
WE THINK THE VALUE OF WHAT IS
THE VALUE HAVING ANY FELONY
MURDER.
RULE ON THE BOOKS PLATED
DETERRENCE VALUE IS THAT PEOPLE
ARE DISSUADED FROM PARTICIPATING
AND SERIOUS [inaudible]
DANGERUS FELONIES.
BECAUSE IF SOMEONE.
DIES IN THE COMMISSION OF THAT
FELONY AS THE LAW IS TODAY.
ANYBODY INVOLVED IN THAT.
COULD CONCEIVABLY --
RECEIVE FIRSTLY MURDER CHARGE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MR QUIRK --
THIS ISABEL THAT'S A LONG TIME
COMING AND IT'S VERY FAIR.
ARE WE ACTUALLY HAVE CASES WHERE
THE SHOOTER IS OUT ON THE STREET
BECAUSE HE OUR WAS WILLING --
TO GIVE EVIDENCE.
WHEREAS THE PERSON IN THE CAR
WHO HAD NO IDEA THAT --
MURDER WAS BEING COMMITTED IS
STILL IN JAIL --
I'M GONNA VOTE FOR THIS BILL
WHICH RESTORES FAIRNESS TO OUR
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
BUT MISS COME LABOR DOVE.
TARRANT THAT IT --
YOU PEOPLE THINK TWICE.
AND I WAS JUST WONDERING.
IF ANYONE AT THE DAY AT THE
TABLE CAN SHARE YOU KNOW IF
YOU'VE HEARD OF CRIMINALS WHO
HAVE SAID.
YOU KNOW.
I WAS GONNA DO THIS BUT THEN I
THOUGHT I IS GOING TO BE A SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN ALL THIS IS GOING
TO BE A ONE EIGHTY SEVEN I MEAN
HAVE I HAD BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE
SAID THIS BEFORE MY HUSBAND AS A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY IN.
IT SEEMS VERY UNLIKELY IN RARE.
THAT IN HEARING STORIES PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY THINKING ABOUT THE
PENAL CODE THAT COULD BE APPLIED
TO THEM IF THEY'RE DOING AN ACT
SO BUT MAYBE I DON'T HAVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION.
CAN YOU SHARE IF THAT HAPPENS I
GILLOOLY WELL I CAN GIVE YOU ONE
FIRST HAND EXAMPLE.
SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW THIS BUT TO
MEMBERS OF OUR FAMILY WERE
MURDERED IN WHAT IS STILL TODAY
THE WORST MASS MURDER.
IN THE HISTORY OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES LITTLE BAR ON
NORMANDY JUST SOUTH OF SLAWSON
WAS FIRE BOMBED --
THE GUY WHO DROVE THE GETAWAY
CAR MANUEL HERNANDEZ --
AT THE TRIAL LOW IN HIS DEFENSE
LAWYER ARGUED AT THE TRIAL --
THAT -- GEE
ALL HE DID WAS BUY THE BUCKET A
GASOLINE THAT WAS THROWN INTO
THE BAR TO BURN SIX PEOPLE TO
DEATH -- BUT
HE DIDN'T KNOW THAT THAT WAS THE
INTENT THAT THEY WOULD LIKE THEY
WERE JUST TRYING TO SCARE PEOPLE.
AND HAD HE KNOWN HE WOULD HAVE
BEEN LIABLE HE WOULDN'T OF BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS AT ALL HE MADE
THAT SAME ARGUMENT WHEN HE WAS
ULTIMATELY PAROLED --
AND THAT WAS --
THAT THAT WAS A CONSTANT --
REFRAIN --
FROM HIM --
BUT NOT WITHSTANDING THE FACT
THAT INCLUDING GILBERT COULD
SALAS AND JOSE MY DOOR AND I IN
OUR FAMILY WERE MURDERED.
JUST TO CLARIFY THIS BILL WOULD
NOT HAVE --
WOULD NOT ALLOW RE SENTENCING
FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT AND GIVE ANY RELIEF TO
THOSE WHO AIDED AND ABETTED.
THE KILLING WHICH OCCURRED IN
THIS CASE SO.
IT'S NOT BE APPROPRIATE AS I AM
SURE THERE ARE --
EXAMPLES THAT COULD BE PROVIDED
THAT WOULD --
MAKE US SOME OF US UNCOMFORTABLE
BUT THAT ONE DOES NOT FIT FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL --
I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO SPEAK TO
THE DETERRENCE IF I MAY.
CHAIR --
REGARDING THE DETERRENCE ISSUE.
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT FEWER
THAN HALF A PERCENT.
OF INDIVIDUALS INCARCERATED FOR
FIRST OR SECOND DEGREE MURDER.
WERE EVEN AWARE THAT THE FELONY
MURDER RULE AS SUPPLIED EXISTED
BEFORE THEY COMMITTED THEIR
CRIMES.
SO IF ONE IS NOT AWARE OF SUCH A
RULE.
AND ITS EXTREME CONSEQUENCES.
THEN HOW CAN IT SERVE AS A
DETERRENCE.
AND I THINK IF WE WERE TO DO A
SURVEY.
OF THOSE MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE
WHO ARE NOT LAWYERS MOST OF THEM
WOULD NOT EVEN OCCURRED THAT.
IT BECAUSE WE HAVE ON THIS ON
THE BOOKS --
THINKS LIKE ACCESSORY ACCOMPLISH
VARIOUS OTHER STATUTES I THINK
MOST OF US ASSUME THAT.
IF YOU YOU KNOW HAD THIS MORE --
PERIPHERAL ROLE IN A MURDER THAT
YOU WOULD BE CHARGED WITH THAT
THAT YOU WOULD NOT BE CHARGED
WITH FELONY MURDER AND FOR
EXAMPLE I AM NOT A LAWYER AND
UNTIL.
I STARTED BE --
WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION AS
CHAIR OF PUBLIC SAFETY THE
EXISTENCE OF THE WAY
CALIFORNIA'S MURDER STATUTE IS
APPLIED I WAS NOT EVEN AWARE.
THAT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT
WE HAVE.
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES IN
CALIFORNIA DIRT DUE TO THIS ROLE.
ASK A FOLLOW UP QUESTION I TOO
WANTED TO SAY THAT I THINK THIS
IS A A GOOD BILL AND AS WE RE
CALIBRATE.
HOW WIDE AN INCONSISTENT NET
THAT WE HAVE CAST AS IT RELATES
TO OUTLAW ENFORCEMENT AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THIS IS
A SOLID STEP?
YES DID YOU.
SO I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS TO OUR ATTENTION
AND MUCH NEEDED CONVERSATION AND
I ALSO JUST WANT TO THANK ALL
THE WITNESSES THE CAME FORWARD I
KNOW THAT IT IS NOT EASY. TO
COME TO THIS BUILDING --
IT IS A LITTLE INTIMIDATING AND
THERE'S NEVER ENOUGH TIME TO
HEAR FROM ANY BUT FROM EVERYBODY.
ESPECIALLY THE PERSONAL STORIES
THAT ARE SO DEEP.
AND ENTRENCHED IN FAMILY WHO AND
CLEARLY IN THE HISTORY OF THE
STATE AND SO I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. FOR COMING TO THIS
BUILDING FOR SHARING WHAT YOU
CAN HARE AND KNOW THAT THERE
ARE MANY OF US THAT ONE OF OVER
STATE FORWARD THINKING.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU --
I THINK WE'VE HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION IN THE JUST TO
CLARIFY FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
DOES NOT ABOLISH THE FELONY
MURDER RULE.
IT RETAINS THE LIABILITY OF
FELONY MURDER FOR ANYONE WHO.
COMMITTED THE MURDER PLANNED
AIDED THE KILLING ACTED WITH
RECKLESSNESS DURING THE CRIME
MASTERMINDED THE CRIME IN A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER --
CONDITIONS BUT WHAT IT DOES DO
IS NARROW THE APPLICATION SO
THAT IT MORE REFLECTS THE
PERSON'S ROLE IN THE CRIME.
AND AS I INDICATED IN --
SPONSORING OUR DISCUSSIONI HAVE
TAKEN THE NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
THAT WE WORKED OUT WITH THE DA'S.
I WILL CONTINUE.
TO OUR IT CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE DA'S BECAUSE
IT IS MY HOPE.
THAT THIS BILL COULD BE IN A
FINAL PLACE WHERE THEY COULD BE
AT LEAST NEUTRAL --
AGAIN THESE THINGS --
ART BUT NOTHING IS EVER
GUARANTEED IN LIFE BUT THAT IS I
THINK THAT THE THE ASSOCIATION
WOULD --
TESTIFY TWO OUR GOOD
CONVERSATIONS IN MY INTENT TO
TRY TO MEET THOSE NEEDS --
BUT WITH THAT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIGHT
VOTE.
THANK YOU IN THE CHURCH
RECOMMEND YA REALLY BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT YOU'VE
HAD RESPECTFUL.
HONEST OPEN --
DISCUSSIONS ON THIS MATTER IF
TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS AND YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS SO TO
INSURE THAT WE DON'T LET.
PEOPLE OUT WHO REALLY ARE
CULPABLE LIABLE.
AND GUILTY THAT WE'RE NOT GIVING
THEM A FREE PASS.
SO WITH THAT I'M RECOMMENDING
THAT THE COMMITTEE THAT DO AN
AYE VOTE.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
DANCER AYE LACKEY [inaudible]
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND YOUR LAST ITEM [inaudible]
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE THANK YOU
I'M CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SP --
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE CALIFORNIA
IS RELATIVELY UNIQUE AMONG
STATES.
IN THAT WE HAVE --
BASICALLY.
THE NEITHER THE PUBLIC NOR EVEN
SOMETIMES HIRING AGENCIES HAVE
ACCESS [inaudible] TWO RECORDS.
AROUND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS --
IT WHEN I SAY WE ARE RELATIVELY
UNIQUE THERE'S A NUMBER OF
CIRCUMSTANCES --
THEIR STATUTES THAT WE PUT INTO
EFFECT BUT ALSO THERE WAS A
COURT CASE.
THAT INTERPRET ARE STATUTES IN A
CERTAIN WAY OR AT LEAST SAID
UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE CLARIFIES
THOSE STATUTES THAT BASICALLY.
THERE WOULD BE A FREEZE ON THE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO ANY RECORDS
RELATED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CONDUCT.
NOW WHAT FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
DOES IS THIS NOT OPEN UP.
ALL RECORDS RELATED LAW
ENFORCEMENT INEQUIVALENT WAY
THAT WE HAVE OUR PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT TOWARDS OTHER PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RATHER IT'S A NARROW.
IT NARROWLY ADDRESSES ONLY.
GIVING ACCESS TO THOSE RECORDS
RELATED INVESTIGATION RECORDS
RELATED [inaudible]
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT'S USE OF
DEADLY FORCE.
BONTA JOB SEXUAL ASSAULT OR ON
THE JOB RELATED DISHONESTY.
NOW I AM TAKING AMENDMENTS
AUTHOR AMENDMENTS WILL FIX LEDGE
COUNCIL ERRORS --
BUT ALSO ADDRESS LANGUAGE REALLY --
TOO TIGHT KNIT REGARDING THE ON
THE JOB RELATED DISHONESTLY AND
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE ARE -- IN
APPROPRIATIONS GOING TO CLARIFY
THAT THE RECORDS ON FRIVOLOUS
ALLEGATIONS OF USE OF FORCE
WOULD NOT BE DISCLOSED --
THERE'S ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
I'LL PROVIDE YOU ON THE
SPECIFICS OF THE BILL BUT I WANT
ALLOW MY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
TO SPEAK FIRST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NIKKI
MARTHA CALIFORNIA NEWS
PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
INTERACTIONS BETWEEN POLICE AND
THE PUBLIC ARE SOME OF THE MOST
CRITICAL AND CAN MEAN A LOSS OF
LIFE FOR LIBERTY.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE HERE
TODAY WHO WANT TO TELL THEIR
STORIES ABOUT THESE INCIDENTS
AND THERE ARE JOURNALISTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WHO WANT TO STE TELL
THE STORIES THAT AFFECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WE CAN'T THE STORIES HAVE
GAPING HOLES BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
HAS FOR TOO LONG KEPT
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
INCIDENTS SECRET.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS SAID
PEOPLE IN AN OPEN SOCIETY DO NOT
DEMAND INFALLIBILITY FROM THEIR
INSTITUTIONS BUT IT IS DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO ACCEPT WHAT THEY ARE
PROHIBITED FROM OBSERVING.
SAYING TRUST US DOES NOT CREATE
PUBLIC TRUST INSTEAD OF
PROACTIVELY DISCLOSING
INFORMATION ABOUT THE MOST
CRITICAL INCIDENTS CALIFORNIA SH
LAW SHROUDS THIS INFORMATION IN
SECRECY.
AND FORCES MOTHERS AND FATHERS
TO BECOME JOURNALISTS TO FIGHT
JUNK COVER SCRAPS OF INFORMATION
TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
AND WHEN CALIFORNIA JOURNALISTS
TRY TO FIND THE SAME INFORMATION
THEY ARE STYMIED.
CALIFORNIA IS AMONG THE MOST
SECRET OF STATES REGARDING
POLICE RECORDS IT HAS ONLY
WORSENED IN THE LAST TWELVE
YEARS SINCE THE COPLEY DECISION.
SHUT DOWN WHAT LITTLE ACCESS WE
DID HAVE TO INFORMATION.
TIME IS COME TO CHANGE THIS AND
COURTS HAVE SAID IT IS ONLY THIS
LEGISLATURE'S POWER TO DO SO
[inaudible]
THE SYSTEMIC.
SECRECY HURTS EVERY INTEREST
EVEN THOSE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
WE WILL BETTER UNDERSTAND
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE ARBITRATION
SYSTEM IF THERE WAS TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT OFFICER DISCIPLINE.
WE CAN GET RID OF BAD ACTORS BY
ENSURING THAT THEY ARE NOT
SHUFFLE TO A NEW DEPARTMENT THAT
DOESN'T KNOW THEIR HISTORY.
AND WHEN POLICE ACT PROPERLY IN
USING FORCE WE COULD KNOW THAT.
TO THE SHROUD OF SECRECY SERVES
NO.
ONE WE WORKED VERY HARD ON THIS
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
BALANCED THAT IT PROTECTS ALL OF
THE DUE PROCESS INTERESTS.
AND THAT IT PROTECTS PRIVACY
THAT IT PROTECTS OFFICER SAFETY
THERE'S FLEXIBILITY BUILT INTO
THE DEADLINES FOR DISCLOSURE BUT
AT SOME POINT THIS INFORMATION
MUST BE DISCLOSED TO THE PUBLIC.
WE ARE WORKING WITH SHAREHOLDERS
HOLDERS ON THEIR ADDITIONAL --
CONCERNS AND WE ARE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND WE LIKE
TO THINK SENATOR SCANNER.
FOR CHAMPIONING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE SELECT THE
URGENT AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXT.
HI AFTERNOON.
I'M.
MY NAME IS WHAT THE SETTLERS LA
I'M HERE. TO ASK YOU TO VOTE YES
ON THE S. B..
ONE FOUR TO ONE WHICH WELL OP
PUBLIC ASSETS TOO LONG PORTION
RECORDS.
WHEN THEY ARE ABOUT TO USE OF
FORCE?
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT MEANS OF
CONDUCT ON THE JOB.
WHEN MY SON JAMES WAS BORN USE
I'M VERY CONFIDENT HE PLAYED?
BASED ON PORTS HIGH SCHOOL TEAM
INTO A GRADUATE FROM PUT HER
HIGH --
AFTER.
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL HE HE GOT INTO
THE OIL REFINERIES HE ALSO LOVED
HIS FAMILY TO ME HE WAS A
PEACEMAKER AND OUR AND OUR
FAMILY IN HIS SCHOOL.
HE WAS THE PATRON OF THE NIECES
AND NEPHEWS AND THE LITTLE
COUSIN DESPITE HIS YOUNG AGE HE
WAS.
APPROVED BY THE COUNTY SYSTEM
FOR CHILD FOSTER CHILD CARE. TO
WORK AS A CAREGIVER.
ON THE DAY HE WAS KILLED HE LEFT
THE HOUSE ABOUT EIGHT THIRTY TO
JOIN HIS FRIENDS. TWO MILES FROM
FROM OUR HOME HE WAS PRO HE PUT
INTO A GAS STATION.
AND HE SCREECHED WHEN HE PULLED
IN -- THIS
GAVE THE REASON FOR THE BPD.
ARE FROM BAKER SHOW.
CHU I APPROACH HIM.
AS A POLICE STROM BEHIND HIM HE
PANICKED JUMPED IN HIS CAR DROVE
AWAY.
YOU MAKE THE WHY WOULD HE LEAVE.
BUT YOUNG MEN OF COLOR IN KERN
COUNTY LIVING IN THE COUNTY AND
THE HIGHEST RATE.
OF USE OF FORCE HOMICIDE IN THE
NATION ARE PRAYING OF THE
OFFICERS.
JERRY THE NEVER BROKE THE LAW HE
WAS NEVER ARRESTED --
NEVER BEEN ARRESTED ONCE.
ONCE WHEN HE WAS A LITTLE BOY HE
WOULD SAY.
I'M BE A COP MOM WHEN I GROW UP.
AS A CHILD.
HE HAD CONFIDENCE IN THE POLICE
AND AS HE GOT OLDER HE LOST THAT
CONFIDENCE IN THE POLICE.
THE PICTURE POLICE DEPARTMENT
CHASED HIM FOR TWO MILES AND
OTHER PLEASE JOIN THE CHASE HE
LOST CONTROL OF HIS CAR.
AND HIT A POLE A WITNESS SAYS
THAT JAMES GOT ON WITH HIS HANDS
UP.
I IT HE WAS LIKE YEAH FROM THE
AIR BAG HITTING HIM IN THE FACE.
WHEN HE WHEN HE GOT THE CAR HE
LEFT HIS HAND AND HE?
LET ONE HAND GO DOWN TO PULL HIS
PANTS UP --
OFFICER RULE WHERE RICK WIMBISH.
TRY TO TASTE HIM.
I'M HEARING THAT CASE ARE YOU
HAVE THE POLICE OFFICERS AND
KURT ANGLE AROUND VALERIE ROOM
LISTEN FRANK MCINTYRE.
SAID THEY THOUGHT IT WAS A GUN
FIRE BUT IT WASN'T IT WAS TO
CHANGE OUR THAT WHEN OUR JAYCO
SHOT TWICE IN ITS HIM.
ONCE AND HIS GROWING AND THE
FATAL SHOT WAS TO HIS HEAD.
HE WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL
WHERE HE WAS PRONOUNCED DEAD WE
WE NEVER CONTACT.
AND MAKES A PLEASE NEVER
CONTACTED US.
TO HERE.
EVEN THROUGH.
THEM KNOWING THE HIS ADDRESS FOR
HIS DRIVER'S LICENSE AND THE
PLATES ON THE VEHICLE.
LATER ON THE INVESTIGATORS CAME
BY WHICH NEVER SPOKE TO ME
[inaudible]
I'M.
BE THEY NEVER SPOKE TO ME EN
DURING THE TIME THE CHANGE WAS
IN THE HOSPITAL --
HIS BODY WAS CONSIDER EVIDENCE
BECAUSE HE WAS AND A CRYING --
THEY HAD OFFICER STRINGER AN
OFFICER LACY --
WATCHING HIS BODY --
OFFICER STRINGER POWER THEY PLAY
WITH MY SON'S BODY [inaudible]
WAS OKAY.
HE MOVED MY SON'S HEAD BACK AND
FORTH HUGHES POPPY MIGHT SENSE.
TOES AND HIS FINGERS.
AND HE TELLS OFFICER FEEDING.
I LIKE PLAYING WITH DEAD BODIES.
SO NOT ONLY WAS MY SAID MURDER.
BUT HE WAS A VERY DISRESPECT.
VERY DISRESPECTED BY THESE
OFFICERS --
WHEN WE RUSHED THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE WE WENT TO
THE CRIME SCENE AND?
THE COPS WOULDN'T TELL ME NOT TO
AND I TOLD THEM THIS IS MY SON'S
VEHICLE PLEASE TELL ME WHERE MY
FATNESS.
THEY WOULDN'T HELP ME THEY TELL
ME TO LEAVE AND THEN I ASKED HIM
AGAIN BAKING THEM PLEASE TELL ME
WHERE MIX BUT IT.
THEY TOLD ME TO LEAVE.
SO DOWN THE ROAD FROM WHERE MY
SON WAS MURDERED THERE IS A
COUNTY HOSPITAL AND I KNEW IN MY
HEART THAT THAT'S WHERE HE WOULD
BE.
I GET TO THE HOSPITAL AND TRY TO
GET INFORMATION THEY DON'T GIVE
ME ANY.
THERE'S ONE YET AMENDED BEEN
WORKED OUT LIKE FORTY YEARS
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN TO THIS
HOSPITAL.
AND I SUBMISSIVE PLEASE TELL ME
IF MY SON'S IN THE BACK.
AND I GAVE HER MY SON'S NAME.
HE'S ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
THERE'S A DISPARITY BOY BACK
THERE.
I THOUGHT HE CAN TELL ME.
THE REST OF THAT NIGHT --
THERE WAS NO INFORMATION GIVEN
TO ME. TO REGARD TO ME AYE MY
SON OF WHAT WAS GOING ON LATER
ON THAT EVENING AFTER MY SON WAS
MURDERED AT NINE I LATER ON THAT
EVENING MAYBE ABOUT. ONE IN THE
MORNING I'M GOING TO STAY.
THEY CAME OUT OF THE CORNERS KEY
MOUNT.
AND OFF WE TO DESCRIBE SOMETHING
UNIQUE COMING SAN I SAID HE HAS
A TATTOO OF MY NAME.
ANNA AND I DISCUSSED OUR HE HE
WAS SORRY TO TELL ME THAT MY SON
HAD DIED [inaudible]
AND IT WAS HEARTBREAKING YOU
KNOW IF IT WAS JUST OVERWHELMING
APPETITE IT'S STILL IT.
I GET WOULD JUST EVERYDAY.
WE HAVE THAT.
WE HAVE HEARD THAT ONE OF THE
OPERATIVES A MODERN GNU SHOOTING
HAD BEEN INVOLVED WITH SEVEN
OTHER SHOOTINGS.
ANOTHER OFFICER WAS
INVOLUNTARILY HERE.
AND I IN ANOTHER HOW HOMICIDE IN
THE TURN OFFICER.
THAT SHOT GAINES WAS CAUGHT
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE.
I WAS NEVER HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
HIS ACTIONS ARE BREAKING THE LAW.
DRINKING AND DRIVING A USING
DRUGS WHILE.
HE'S A POLICE OFFICER MAKES A
POLICE DEPARTMENT --
BECAUSE OF THE CALAVERAS SECRECY
AROUND POLICE MISCONDUCT WE HAVE
NO IDEA HOW PRAYER IT.
CURRENTLY REPLIES ON IT IS WERE
HANDLE IT THE OPPOSITE WHERE
EVER DISCIPLINE OR IF THERE WAS
ANYTHING.
DONE TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE
COMPETENT.
I URGE YOU.
I'M MAKING IT A VOTE YES ON THE
S. B. ONE OR TWO ONE BECAUSE IT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE LIVES.
THANK YOU FROM MOTHERS AT THAT
TIME [inaudible]
DO THIS.
OF WHAT WE'RE UP TO EIGHT
MINUTES SO I YEP.
SO IT'S A A HEARING FROM.
SUPPORTERS NAME.
AND ORGANIZATION.
LIZZY BEACON WITH A SILLY ó
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO SPONSORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
PROUD CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
BIG MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHRISTIAN BRANDO CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
ANTHONY ROBLES THAT THE YOU JUST
OF COALITION WITH PROP
COSPONSORED THOSE BILL.
AGAIN ON THE CEMENT SO WHERE YOU
JUSTICE COALITION WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PASS IT.
CAN WE GO FROM THE IS JUSTICE
COALITION HONORED TO BE A
COSPONSOR THIS BILL ALSO HERE
FOR YOU KNOW FOR ITS FAMILY PICK.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
UNTIL TO PROTECT FUTURE HUMANS
FROM THE CRIMINALS IN VALUES
NICKEL CIGARS SO YES COALITION.
YES MY NAME IS REBECCA TELEPHONE
I'M ON THE AT JAMES DEL ROSA.
I SUPPORT THE S. B..
FOURTEEN ONE SUSAN LOVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN SUPPORT.
TURKISH ACCORDINGLY YOU JUSTICE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SHOULD THOSE THE EASY
WHY JC I STRONGLY SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ACTUALLY
MARTINEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION LOCAL ONE THOUSAND AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY PHILLIPS
AND I'M HERE ARE ON BEHALF OF
THE MURDER AND COVER UP OF MY
SON AARON JAMES PHILLIPS AND WE
BOTH SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS SHARON LARKINS I AM
HERE.
ON BEHALF OF MY SON FILL PARKINS
WHO WAS SHOT AND KILLED WHO SHOT
TEN TIMES ON FEBRUARY ELEVENTH.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I'M A
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHERRY STEMMING
ALWAYS SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
ANYWHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S LAURA SERRANO MY
FATHER FRANCISCO SERRANO WAS
MURDERED BY BAKERSFIELD BAKER
BAKER STOP POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
JOANNE FELONY MURDER ELIMINATION
PROJECT AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
KEY EN GINA VILLARROEL FROM
BAKERSFIELD --
HONORING MY HUSBAND HER DAD
FRANCISCO VILLARROEL MURDER BY
FICTIONAL PLEASE DEPARTMENT AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU MA'AM.
WEARING IT ALL OF US SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JAMES PERCH POLICY DIRECTOR ANTI
PLEASE TEAR PROJECT PART BECAUSE
SPONSORING STRONG SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVID JONES
ABOUT THE CITY SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO.
MY SON JACOB DOMINGUEZ WAS
EXECUTED BY SAN JOSE PD AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROSY TRAVIS AND MY
NEPHEW JACOB DOMINGUEZ WAS
EXECUTED BY SJP DE AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
FAMILY WAS ROUGH WHEN HE'S THERE
SELLER SILICON VALLEY DEBUG.
ON THE HAVE VIETNAMESE FAMILY WE
SUPPORT HIS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS KAREN NODS I AM WITH
USE JUSTICE COALITION I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU I'M AND THEY
PART OF ERIC ROBERT AND HIS
FAMILY OKAY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S TONY WHAT WAGES HAS
STRONG SUPPORT AS WELL
[inaudible]
YOU.
THERE'S WILLIAM CHEN --
BE HAVE A BORN BURNS'S TO A
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANA BILLINGSLEY BRINGS INSTITUTE
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
I GRANDSON PD PEREZ WAS KILLED
BY THE RICHMOND POLICE.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN HE WAS
UNARMED WAS NOT A THREAT TO
ANYONE SAFETY BUT HE'S DEAD
THANK THANK YOU I SUPPORT.
CASSIDY CROFTON WITH ANTI POLICE
TEAR PROJECT IV HAVE REALLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
KOBE LENDS A CCW PAEAN SURVIVED
AND PUNISHED ON BEHALF OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS TO
CALL FOR HELP BUT ARE KILLED BY
THE POLICE [inaudible]
I SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS DENNIS FLAN AND EVER
PRESENT CARES FOR YOUTH AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SIR.
MY NAME IS REGINA JACOBS OF
ENHANCES THAT AND HE WAS
MURDERED BY MIKE PING OFFICER
SELLS A PT.
JACOB DOMINGUEZ WAS UNARMED.
MORNING ON MY RECHARGE REFORM ON
VICTOR BEGINS GRANDMOTHER HE WAS
MURDERED I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
MAYBE CITY WEBER PACIFIC
IMPARTED CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR.
WE SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS SANDY SANCHEZ FROM
SAN JOSE OF MY SON EIGHTEEN OLE
ANTHONY WAS MURDERED BY SAN JOSE
PD.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
MA'AM.
MY NAME IS JUSTIN OVER SOME OF
THEM MY SON ANTHONY WAS KILLER
OF THE PTA AND UP SUPPORTERS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE MIKE GIPSON WILL
LIVE NOW BLUE CAMPAIGN AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS A LINK FROM LEBANON
FUND CAMPAIGN HAS PUT HIS BILL.
MY NAME IS --
US SAYS BEATRICE FLOOD NO BLOOD
CAMPAIGN AND ALSO THE ANTI OF
OSCAR GRANT.
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I AM STEVE ROGERS PUTTING IN
POWER NOW IN THE EARLY MISSION
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S YES RODRIGUEZ HA
COUSIN OF MINE JAMES ON A ROSY
PICTURE CALIFORNIA HOW STRONG
SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND NURSES STATEWIDE WERE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PALU -- YOU
HUNKER GUINNESS OWN BE HELPFUL
CHIU LAME WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JIM WEINBERGER ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ANDREW BIGELOW AN
ORGANIZER SILICON VALLEY DEBUG
SUPPORTIVE FAMILIES SUCH AS
MOODY CUTTING ISN'T ANTONIO
GOODMAN PARA SUPPORT OF THIS.
WE GOT ELEVEN A GAS WAYS
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR SORT OF
YOU JUSTICE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JERRY BROWN WOULD YOU JUSTICE
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT.
NO MATTER YOU SAM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND I STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
WAS SEDUCED BY ONE OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEES UNITED FOR
STAR THE JUSTICE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH MEAGER MY SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA WITH PACKED LEADER
AND WE'RE CO SPONSORS A PICKLE
CALIFORNIA DISPELLED STRONGLY
SUPPORT LAWS PASSED.
I TO A DOCTOR IN SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA PART OF PACKED AND CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL VIA PICO
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
YES SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS OF
ASKED ME. TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT STARTING WITH
[inaudible]
ACCOUNTANT.
CONTRACT HOW COSTA COUNTY.
LABOR COUNCIL.
ONE THE INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHOREMEN WAREHOUSEMAN UNION
LOCAL TEN IN SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I M. THE FACILITATOR FOR THE
OSCAR GRANT COMMITTEE AGAINST
POLICE BRUTALITY WE ALL OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING.
A COALITION OF UNIONS HAVE.
DISCUSS THIS AND THEY STRONGLY
SUPPORTED THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU.
I'M ALICE LUNCH WITH PACKED IN
SAN JOSE WHICH IS PART OF PICO
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL WE STRONGLY SUPPORT PASSING
THIS BILL.
HI SUSAN MORE SAN JOSE I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH PAKISTAN WITH THE
FAMILIES I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
NATASHA MINSKER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE.
ANY MEMBERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
COULD YOU.
IT'S JUST YOU GOT NO.
I THINK THE YOU GOT A LITTLE
MORE THAN FIVE MINUTES SO.
BUT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY TO BE
QUICK.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
LITTLE.
ONE EIGHT MILLER LITE HAVE MEANT
PART IN ABOUT EIGHT MINUTES
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
RAINY PARRY WITH THEIR READING
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HARPER
TRONG POOR ACT.
NOT POSITION --
WHERE WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR --
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE THAT I
THINK WE ACTUALLY HAVE A ME IN
AMMAN I JUST.
VERY QUICKLY ON THE BILL.
OUR OPPOSITION HAS NOT BEEN
BASED ON THE RELEASE OF THE
INFORMATION AND KNEES LIMITED
CASES THE BILL OUTLINES.
OUR CONCERN HAS BEEN ON THE
FAIRNESS OF THE PROCESS
STATEWIDE IN A UNIFORM SYSTEM
STATEWIDE.
WE HAVE TWO MAJOR SECTIONS AND
WE HAVE.
EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE OF EXAMPLE
WE'VE BROUGHT IN --
WHERE AN OFFICER MANY TIMES
OFTENTIMES SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU'RE
THE UNION LEADERS THE
ASSOCIATION?
ARM WILL HAVE SOME TYPE OF
SITUATION THAT THEY ARE INVOLVED
IN.
AND THEY HAVE A SYSTEM SET UP A
SYSTEM OR INVESTIGATORY SYSTEM.
WHERE AND FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW
THREE AGENCIES JUST IN THIS
GEOGRAPHIC AREA AROUND RIGHT NOW?
AND SINCE I SIT NEXT TO CHIEF
SOMEONE MENTIONING ABOUT THAT
BUT WHERE WHERE THEY LITERALLY
HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE IT'S YOU THE
CHIEF MAKING A DECISION ON THEIR
DESPITE HER FIRING MEMBER THESE
ARE CASES WHERE.
THESE OFFICERS WILL ABSOLUTELY
LOSE THEIR CAREER IT WILL NOT BE
PEACE OFFICERS ANY LONGER.
AND OR TALK ABOUT THOSE
INVESTIGATORY FILES BEING
RELEASED --
OR THEY HAVE AN ADVISORY
ARBITRATION SYSTEM WHERE THEY GO
TO ARBITRATOR IT SIMPLY ADVISORY
THE CHIEF LOOKS AT OR THE CITY
MANAGER MOST OFTEN.
LOOKS ALLEN SAYS YEAH THAT'S
GREAT --
YOU'RE STILL FIRED SO IN MIL
INTEL THE SYSTEM IS FAIR FOR THE
EMPLOYEES STATEWIDE AND THIS IS
MORE YOU KNOW LIKE I SAID MORE
FOR A LOCAL UNION ISSUE --
UNTIL THE SYSTEM IS MORE FAIR
STATEWIDE BECAUSE THE P. PEOPLE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR CAREERS.
THAT ARE ONLY ARGUMENT IS THAT
THIS BILL SHOULD AT LEAST BE
FAIR THE SYSTEM THAT THIS BILL
SETUP.
SHOULD BE AT LEAST BE FAIR TO
EMPLOYEES STATE WHY THEY SHOULD
BE UNIFORMLY FAIR.
SO WE'VE ASKED FOR A COUPLE OF
AMENDMENTS IN THAT AREA AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
WITH THE WITH THE SENATOR.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK IN
THAT AREA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS.
OF P. -- LA
POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE --
AND THE LA COUNTY PROFESSIONAL.
YEAH XIN IN CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION FIRST WE
WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MISTER PARRY ABOUT THE FAIRNESS
OF THE FAULT FINDING ELEMENT.
OF OF THE BILL AND WE WOULD BILL
REMINDED THIS COMMITTEE THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE APPROVED --
RECOGNIZE THAT ISSUE IMPLICITLY
IN APPROVING A BILL BY MISTER
SANTIAGO LAST YEAR.
THAT WOULD HAVE RAISED THE
STANDARD OF PROOF IN CERTAIN
AREAS TO A CLEAR AND CONVINCING
STANDARD --
BUT THE ELEMENT WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IS THE FIRST PART OF THE
BILL.
THE FIRST PART OF THE BILL.
PROVIDES THAT THE PERSONNEL
RECORDS SHALL BE RELEASED IN ANY
INSTANCE WHERE A FIREARM IS USED
IN ANY INSTANCE WHERE --
BEAR IS A USE OF TASER USE OF
SOME KIND OF AN IMPACT DEVICE OR
WHERE THERE IS AN INJURY CAUSING --
OR WITH WHERE THERE'S A
CIRCUMSTANCE CAUSING SERIOUS
INJURY BODILY HARM OR DEATH
[inaudible]
WHAT IS?
DISTURBING TO US ABOUT THIS
FIRST ELEMENT.
IS IT THERE IS NO PRECONDITION
OF A FINDING OF FAULT.
IN OTHER WORDS.
OUR OFFICER --
SMITH --
MIGHT HAVE USED --
HER TASER.
BUT THE AT THERE.
THE FINDINGS OF THE AGENCY ARE
THAT SHE WAS ENTIRELY WITHIN
POLICY ENTIRELY WITHIN LAW.
WE WOULD SUBMIT THAT RELEASING
THE PERSONNEL RECORDS.
OF OFFICERS WHERE THERE IS NO
FINDING OF FAULT.
HAS THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF ACTUALLY UNDERMINING
CONFIDENCE AND HERE'S WHY.
USE OF FORCE.
IS NEVER PRETTY.
IN POLICY OR OUTSIDE OF POLICY
BUT THE MOMENT YOU RELEASE.
OFFICER SMITH'S PERSONNEL
RECORDS EVEN THOUGH SHE HAS BEEN
FOUND TO BE TOTALLY WITHIN
POLICY TOTALLY WITHIN THE LAW.
THE MOMENT YOU RELEASE HER
PERSONNEL RECORDS YOU CREATE AN
INFERENCE THAT SHE MUST HAVE
DONE SOMETHING WRONG.
AND WE WE HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS.
ABOUT THE RELEASE OF AN
OFFICER'S [inaudible]
PERSONNEL RECORDS WHERE THERE'S
NO FINDING OF FAULT BY THE
AGENCY THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES BRIEFLY DOT CHAIR MEMBERS
JONATHAN FELT OF THE CALIFORNIA
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
I THERE ARE A LOT OF CHIEFS OUT
THERE THAT THAT AGREED WITH THE
INTENT OF THE MEASURE THAT THERE
IS A LEVEL TRANSPARENCY THAT'S
NEEDED THEIR CHIEFS IN CERTAIN
SITUATIONS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO TELL THE
PUBLIC.
YES THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS IS THE
DISCIPLINARY ACTION THAT WE TOOK
WE RESOLVE THE SITUATION --
AND THEIR CHIEF THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT AND THEY'VE
BEEN BLASTED FOR FOR NOT BEING
OUTSPOKEN AND PEOPLE ARE ASKING
FOR THE INFORMATION THEY
LITERALLY CAN'T.
PROVIDED AND I WON'T NAME NAMES --
FOR THE DIFFERENCE IN MY FRIEND
FROM THE UNION.
SHOW TO ME --
BUT I MEAN THERE AGENCIES WITH
IT HAD REALLY BIG FIGHTS IN THE
CHIEF IS PAID THE PRICE.
AND THAT'S NOT OKAY.
SIMILAR TO THE CONCERNS FROM
OTHER COLLEAGUE I REALLY.
ARE ISSUES WITH THE BILL AS IT
STANDS NOW IS FOR THE RELEASE OF
INFORMATION FOR OFFICERS THAT
HAVE BEEN EXONERATED.
OR THAT FIND THE COMPLAINT NOT
SUSTAINED SO IN THOSE CASES
WHERE THE OFFICERS BEEN PROVEN
NOTHING NOTHING WENT WRONG THERE
THERE'S NO NO ABILITY TO SHOW
THAT THE OFFICER ACTED OUT A
POLICY OUT A LAW --
SUPPOSING THAT OFFICERS TO THE
PUBLIC IS A CONCERN FOR US BOTH
THE SAFETY OF THEIR OFFICER AND
AND FOR YOU KNOW THAT EVERYONE
INVOLVED.
I KNOW THIS IS BEEN COMPLICATED
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO WORK OUT
SOME AMENDMENTS WITH THE THE
CHAIR.
OR THE I'M.
USUALLY WRONG WRONG COMMITTEE.
AND THE CHAIR IN THE SENATE --
THE AUTHOR AND AND HER SPONSORS
UNDERSTAFFED AND WE HAD SOME
REALLY GOOD CONVERSATIONS WITH
SOMETHING GOOD SOME IN
[inaudible]
TENSE BUT THERE IS A COURT CASE
THAT IS LIMITING OUR ABILITY TO
JUST OUT RIGHT.
EXIT A REDACT THEIR NAMES LONG
BEACH CASE MORE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WAYS TO PROTECT THIS
ALTHOUGH THEIR DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN WHAT WE'RE RELEASING
HERE THIS IS THEIR PERSONNEL
FILES THIS IS A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND WE'RE NOT CLEAR
EXACTLY WHAT WORD RELEASING IN
ITS ENTIRETY TO JUST AS A RECORD.
RELATED TO THE FINAL WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE RECORD SO.
SOME CLARITY THERE WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL BUT ALSO SOME WAY TO
PROTECT THE INFORMATION FOR THE
EXONERATED OFFICERS OF THE
OFFICERS THAT ARE --
THE COMPLAINTS NOT SUSTAINED IN
THOSE CASES AS THEY TOOK A GREAT
STEP FORWARD BY COMPLETELY
ELIMINATE UNFOUNDED CASES.
SO THAT WAS VERY HELPFUL BUT
THERE'S STILL SOME THINGS I NEED
TO GET TIGHTENED UP BUT AGAIN.
FOR ALL THE SITUATIONS THAT WE
WOULD WISH WE COULD HAVE COME
OUT AND SAID WHAT HAPPENED IN
BEEN CLEAR ABOUT IT --
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS AND SEE IF WE CAN FIND A
SWEET SPOT IN THE END SO THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
LOUIS BROWN A BEHALF THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER TO CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF COURSE ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITE.
LIEUTENANT SHIRLEY SO WILLIAM
SALMON AND IN I'LL SHARE SOME
BEHALF OF SHERIFF MCMAHON AND
OPPOSITION.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS HAVE A COMMENT.
SELECT GO MITCHELL LACKEY YES I
WOULD THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW I I I TRULY APPRECIATE.
THE OF THE AUTHOR AND THIS
LEGISLATURE ONE TO TAKE STEPS
TOWARDS IMPROVING POLICE
COMMUNITY RELATIONS BY PROMOTING
TRANSPARENCY.
AND I'M ENCOURAGED BY YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH.
WITH THOSE WHO HAVE CONCERNS AND
IT KNOW SOME OF THE ISSUES ARE
STILL KIND OF A LITTLE BIT
UNRESOLVED ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THERE ARE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND FAIRNESS
TOWARDS IT.
OFFICERS WHO HAVE SHOWN NO
MISCONDUCT.
BUT WE CERTAINLY NEED TO PUSH
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
IS.
A PROCESS THAT ALLOWS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
CLEARLY COMMUNICATE WHEN THERE
IS MISCONDUCT.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON I'M NOT
QUITE THERE TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I KNOW YOU'RE
CONTINUALLY WORKING AND I HOPE
TO BE ABLE TO GET. TWO YES BUT
TIME AGAINST THE FORKS I KNOW
YOU'RE ACTIVELY WORKING IN THAT
AREA [inaudible]
QUIRK.
YA I THINK THIS IS A CRITICAL
BILL TO RESTORE --
FAITH IN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT --
AND I HOPE YOU'LL ANSWERING YOU
CLOSE THE ACT CONCERNS THAT TELL
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAVE --
ARE WE MUST MELT MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD AND DIE I HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET TO A POINT WHERE
EVERYONE IS --
CAN RESOLVE THEIR OPPOSITION BUT
IN ANY CASE I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL NOW AND ON THE FLOOR.
AND LET ME KNOW ANYWAY I CAN
HELP THANK YOU.
YES WAS KAMLAGER-DOVE AM.
I I FIRST WANT TO THANK MISS
THAT DE LA ROSA FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I KNOW THAT CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO SHARE.
I WANT TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE DIETS --
BY SAYING THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER FOR BRINGING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL --
FLORIDA AND IT'S ASSURING TO
KNOW THAT YOU ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
LOOK AT AMENDMENTS --
I DID NOTE IN A COUPLE OF
INSTANCES AND CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THAT --
THE PERSONAL INFORMATION.
FAMILY AND OUTSIDE OF THE
PERSON'S NAME THE OFFICER'S NAME
BUT THE OTHER PERSONAL
INFORMATION.
IS NOT RELEASED --
I THINK I ALSO READ THAT --
THE RECORD SHOULD ALSO NOT BE
RELEASED WHEN THE COMPLAINT IS
DEEMED UNFOUNDED AND I THINK YOU
ALSO MENTIONED AS AN AMENDMENT
TO ADD THE WORD FRIVOLOUS IN
THERE AS WELL --
AND SO I THOUGHT I WAS BUT IF
I'M WRONG PLEASE CORRECT ME
LASTLY I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD YOU KNOW
PITCHES --
ARE DIFFICULT --
BUT NO PERSON SHOULD BE --
SHOULD HAVE A LEVEL.
OF A PROTECTION IN ON IMPEACH
ABILITY FROM THE LAW AND I THINK
THIS BILL WORKS TOWARDS KEEPING --
CITIZENS AND FELLOW POLICE
OFFICERS OUT OF HARM'S WAY SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
YES AND IT.
COMMENTS [inaudible] TO LIKE
[inaudible] TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND USUALLY DO
VERY BRIEF CLOSED IF YOU DON'T
MIND SINCE THIS IS A A
COMPLICATED MEASURE.
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
THINGS --
BUT FIRST I'LL SAY BROADLY THAT
[inaudible]
THE THAT UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX CALIFORNIA GAVE BROAD ACCESS
TO INFORMATION ABOUT
INVESTIGATIONS INTO POLICE
CONDUCT.
SO IT THIS IS NOT LIKE THIS BILL
IS SOMEHOW CREATING A NEW
STANDARD THAT HAS NEVER BEEN
APPLIED.
AND IN FACT THIS BILL IS
NARROWER SO IT DOES NOT RETURN
CALIFORNIA LAW. TO PRE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX LEVELS OF
TRANSPARENCY.
INSTEAD IT HAS A MORE LIMITED
ACCESS THAT OUR INTENT WAS TO
STRIKE THE BALANCE BETWEEN
PRIVACY AND PUBLIC RIGHT TO KNOW --
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT HOW CALIFORNIA
IS AN OUT LIAR AND I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT THERE ARE TWELVE
STATES.
INCLUDING ALABAMA ARIZONA
GEORGIA FLORIDA OHIO IN UTAH
THAT HAVE DISCLOSURE LAWS FAR
MORE EXTENSIVE THAN WHAT IS
PROPOSED IN THE BILL BEFORE YOU.
AND THAT THERE ARE FIFTEEN
STATES INCLUDING TEXAS OKLAHOMA
ARKANSAS TENNESSEE.
THAT ALLOW FOR LIMITED
DISCLOSURE THAT IS MORE
COMPARABLE TO WHAT IS PROPOSED
HERE.
NOW IN THE SENATE I TOOK A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE THAT THE OPPOSITION
NOTED THAT I'VE BEEN MEETING.
WITH [inaudible]
THE CHIEFS WITH PORAC WITH CHP
WITH SHERIFF'S THE DA'S AND YOU
NOTICE THAT THE DA'S DID NOT
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AND THAT
IS DUE TO THE FACT THAT WE TOOK
DE A TOOK AMENDMENTS.
AND NOW WHEN I DESCRIBE THIS I
WAS NOT BOBBY.
CLEARLY I WANTED TO REMOVE AS
MUCH OPPOSITION AS POSSIBLE.
I WAS HOPING THAT IT WOULD
REMOVE MORE OPPOSITION THEN THE
JUST THE DA'S BUT THIS IS THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
THE SENATE.
THAT DID REMOVE THE DA'S
OPPOSITION IT GAVE AGENCIES THE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE TIMING OF THE
DISCLOSURE IN ORDER TO RESPECT
OFFICERS DUE PROCESS RIGHTS --
FILES TO AMENDED THAT IF THE
COMPLAINT AS WAS NOTED HERE WAS
UNFOUNDED THE RECORDS WOULD NOT
BE RELEASED AND I'M TAKING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENT THAT WOULD
ADD FRIVOLOUS THERE ALSO SO
EITHER UNFOUNDED OR FRIVOLOUS --
ALSO ALREADY AMENDED WAS THAT
RECORDS THAT MIGHT AFFECT
CRIMINAL DISCOVERY WOULD NOT BE
RELEASED SO THOSE OUR AMENDMENTS
THAT I'VE TAKEN SO FAR.
NOW I COMPLETELY APPRECIATE.
POR ACTS EXPRESSION OR CALL IT
ALL OF THIS WAS NOT ONLY THEIR
EXPRESSION BUT RATHER RANK AND
FILE LAW ENFORCEMENT'S.
SUPPRESSION OF FEELING THAT
UNTIL THERE IS A UNIFORM
DISCIPLINARY PROCEDURE.
ACROSS ALL JURISDICTIONS THAT IS
NOT APPROPRIATE TO HAVE THE
RECORDS RELEASED I APPRECIATE
THAT AS A FORMER A MEMBER OF
UNION MYSELF.
THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU MOVE TO A
DIFFERENT WORKPLACE YOU WANT THE
RULES TO APPLY --
UNIFORMLY BUT FOR US TO MANDATE
A UNIFORM PROCESS NUMBER ONE
WOULD OF COURSE --
INCUR GREAT STATE COSTS BECAUSE
ANY MANDATE OF THAT SORT WOULD.
BE BORNE BY THE STATE AND WOULD
CAUSE THE EMPLOYERS OF THOSE
OFFICERS --
TO OF I SHOULD NOT BE HAPPY IS A
MILD.
IT WOULD BE A MILD DESCRIPTION --
SO IT IS DIFFICULT TO IMPOSE
THAT.
IN IN TERMS OF THE ISSUES THAT
THE CHIEFS RACED.
BY SOME OF THEM MAY BE A LITTLE
EASIER TO ADDRESS AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE CONTINUE WELL I'M
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH EVERYONE BECAUSE AND I WILL
NOTE THAT IN A MOMENT BUT I WAS
VERY OPEN. TO HAVING THE
OFFICER'S NAME NOT DISCLOSE
BECAUSE FROM MY POINT OF VIEW NO
I APPRECIATE THAT SOME OF THE
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL WOULD NOT
BE HAPPY WITH SUCH AN AMENDMENT.
BUT MY PURPOSE IS TO CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
TRANSPARENCY TO CREATE THE
PUBLIC TRUST THAT IN AGENCY HAS
THOROUGHLY INVESTIGATED.
AND THAT THEY HAVE.
FOUND THAT IT WAS EITHER WITHIN
THE RULES OR NOT THE RULES
BECAUSE YOU UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE NOW WHERE.
DEPENDING ON THE COMMUNITY THE
PUBLIC FEELS THAT.
THERE IS NO REAL INVESTIGATION
THAT OFFICERS ARE ALWAYS JUST
HELD -- HELD --
THAT THERE.
WHAT SOME PEOPLE CONSIDER ABOVE
THE LAW ARE THAT THEY'RE ALWAYS
EXONERATED?
AND THAT THE NINE RELEASE THE
INABILITY OF A JURISDICTION TO
BE ABLE TO RELEASE RECORDS TO
SHOW THAT THEY FULLY
INVESTIGATED.
IN I MEAN FULLY THEIR WHAT THEIR
WHERE -- IT
WAS VERY DETAILED.
NOW CREATES THAT TRUST AND SO.
FOR ME.
IF THE AGENCY IT'S NOT SO MUCH
KNOWING THE INDIVIDUAL OFFICER
BUT RATHER THE TRUST THAT THE
AGENCY HAS RULES THAT THEY
FOLLOW THOSE RULES.
THAT IN AND ALSO THAT IF FOR
EXAMPLE IF AYE OBTAINED IF THE
BILL WERE --
IF WE HAD THE ABILITY TO GET
RECORDS AND I REQUESTED THE
RECORDS UNDER THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION ACT.
AND IT WAS DEMONSTRATED THAT I
WAS ONLY A SINGLE OFFICER I
DON'T NEED TO KNOW THAT
OFFICER'S NAME TO SAY TO THE
AGENCY WHY IS IT THAT THERE'S
ONLY ONE OFFICER IN YOUR FORCE.
THAT IS REPEATED.
IN YOUR JURISDICTION THAT IS
REPEATED USE OF FORCE OR
REPEATED WHATEVER EGGS AND THAT
THAT ALONE CREATES THE ABILITY
FOR THE PUBLIC TO HOLD THE
AGENCY SOMEWHAT ACCOUNTABLE.
BUT DUE TO THE LONG BEACH CASE
WE ARE NOW CONFRONTING
DIFFICULTYWITH BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE SOMETHING.
AROUND THAT BUT WE ARE STILL IN
CONVERSATIONS. TO TRY TO COME TO
SOME KIND OF SWEET SPOT --
ALMOST FORGOT MY LAST POINT --
MY FAULT MY CLOSING IS THAT THE
REASON I AM SO COMMITTED AND
WILL CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE REASON I'M ALSO CARRYING
THIS BILL IS THAT I THINK I
RESPECT THE PUBLIC'S.
RIGHT TO NO I RESPECT THAT THERE
IS UNFORTUNATELY MISTRUST AND
YET AT THE SAME TIME.
WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
USE OF FORCE IS HAS GONE DOWN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT OUR
OFFICERS ARE BETTER TRAINED THAN
THEY EVER HAVE BEEN.
AND THAT EACH AND EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
EVERY TIME THEY WALK OUT THE
DOOR IN THE ON THEIR UNIFORM
THEY TAKE THEIR OWN LIFE'S.
THEIR LIFE SAID RISK
[inaudible]
AND WE WANT TO RESPECT WHATEVER
WE CONSTRUCT [inaudible]
TO BOTH.
GIVE THAT ABILITY FOR THE PUBLIC
TO TO KNOW AND TO FEEL THAT
THEIR RIGHTS ARE BEING RESPECTED
AND YET RESPECT THE RIGHTS OF
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO HAVE
SUCH AN IMPORTANT JOB.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT IS I
KNOW IT IS A VERY DIFFICULT
BALANCE IT MAY BE A BALANCE THAT.
WE ARE.
UNABLE TO ULTIMATELY ACHIEVE BUT
AT LEAST WE COULD GOOD CLOSER
AND SO THAT IS WHY I AM CURING
IT THAT IS WHY I WILL CONDUCT
WIFE TAKING AMENDMENT SO FAR
WILL TAKE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THIS COMMITTEE HAS RECOMMENDED
AND I WILL CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSIONS.
BEFORE IT GETS TO THE FLOOR AND
WITH THAT I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO CENTERS.
SKINNER AND THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK AND ACHIEVEMENT
DIFFICULT.
EVEN MY IN MY SURE APPEAR TIME I
CAN.
AND HOW DIFFICULT HAS BEEN --
FOR FOR THIS COMMITTEE IN THIS
CHAIR -- TO
TO DEAL WITH THIS HIMSELF
[inaudible]
TRY AYE.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR CONTINUED
TO TALK PICTURE TAKEN
RECOMMENDATIONS BECAUSE I'M A
UNION MEMBER.
TOO AND I WOULD ONE EXPOSE
[inaudible]
ANY INNOCENT.
UNION MEMBERS ONTO ANY
UNNECESSARY SCRUTINY BY THIS BUT
SAME MISSION.
IF SOMEONE IS DOING SOMETHING
WRONG WE NEED TO EXPOSE AT AND
WE NEED TO NOT USE OUR RULES AND
REGULATIONS [inaudible]
PROTECT THEM.
AND AND SO WHAT IF IT'S A
DELICATE BALANCE BETWEEN
PROTECTING YOUR MEMBERS.
AND AND MAKING SURE THAT ARM
EVERYBODY IS ABOUT.
AS HONEST AND JUST OUTLINED.
THE THING I LOVE ABOUT THIS IT'S
SOMETIMES AS THOUGH SOMEONE TO
UNION MEMBERS AND WERE FOR
GOVERNMENT FOR A LONG TIME.
SOMETIMES IT THE POLICY.
OF THE PROCEDURES AND THE
TRAINING IS FLAWED.
NOT THE INDIVIDUAL.
AND YOU KNOW WE WERE GOING TO
GET. TWO THE POLICIES AND THE
TRAINING UNLESS WE EXPOSE.
AND SO I BY.
I'D YOU CAN EVEN APPRECIATE YOU
LOOKING AT SUPPOSING THAT FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF NOT DEMONIZING
EVERYONE THAT'S IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT BUT REALLY LOOKING
AT HOW THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
TRAINED BECAUSE THAT MAY BE THE
ULTIMATE FLAW.
AND AND WE NEED TO EXPOSE THAT
AND SHOW IT IN AND HAVE A FULL
DISCUSSION.
EVEN THE SMALLER BOMB.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE WE
ALL NEED THAT TO TALK ABOUT THAT
THIS IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT.
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN AND THOSE
POLICIES THAT THEY HAD BACK THEN
SHOULD NOT BE.
DONE THROUGHOUT THIS ARE DISH
DISPIRITING TIME.
AND SO I'M I'M GLAD YOU YOU YOU
LOOK AT THE FAIRNESS HONESTY.
AND REALLY WHEN PEOPLE ARE
EXONERATED --
THAT THAT I DID FOR THE PUBLIC.
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
[inaudible]
WHY [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THEY ARE EXONERATED.
AND THEN THE MORE MORE THEY HEAR
ABOUT Y. --
SOMEONE MAY MAKE SENSE IMAGE
SOME OF FOR SOME PEOPLE
SPREADSHEET NAM.
I RISK A STATEMENTS DEL ROSA IT
MAY NEVER MAKE SENSE BUT
HOPEFULLY IT OPENS UP SO THAT
SHE SHE SHE DOES SOME CLOSURE.
THAT OF WHAT HAPPENED --
SO THAT WE CAN WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD SO THAT NEVER HAVE AFTER
HAPPEN TO ANYONE ELSE.
LIKE MOST DEAL WITH DIVERSITY
THAT WE DON'T ANY OTHER PEOPLE
WHO TESTIFIED HERE TODAY.
THAT WE THAT NUMBER GOES DOWN
AND DOWN AND DOWN --
TO WHERE I AM ABOUT WE
UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS COMMUNITY HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS.
AND THEN WE CAN MOVE ON TO TO
THE NEXT LEVEL WITCHES BETTER
PROCEDURES BETTER POLICIES
BETTER TRAINING AND WE WE JUST
NEEDED TO HAVE THAT I'M I'M.
I'M RICH I'M READYNOW TO HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS I'M READY NOW
TO EXPOSE ALL THE THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKING.
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD BEYOND OF US DOING
THINGS AND HOPEFULLY.
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TAKES A GREATER HAND.
AND FERRETING OUT AND I'LL SAY
THIS [inaudible]
I BELIEVE.
JUST LIKE IN OUR PROFESSION AS
WITH ELECTED OFFICIALS WHAT
PERCENT OF US. TO MAKE A MISTAKE
THAT WE ALL GET PREGNANT TO SAME
BRUSH.
BUT ALSO 1% OF HIS CONDITION
REALLY HARM AND DAMAGE AND AND
AND SO IF 99% OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS WORK HARD WORKING HONEST AND
BE DOING THEIR JOB --
I REALIZED THAT 1% BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A WEAPON BECAUSE THEY HAVE
A TASER BECAUSE THEY CAN
PHYSICALLY DO HARM TO SOMEONE --
WE WE NEED TO WE NEED TO TAKE
THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND WORK REAL
HARD. TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
INCIDENTS OF WERE MISBEHAVIOR IS
HAPPENING AND SO --
I LIKED SOME OF THE OTHER
MEMBERS I'M.
DUTY ASK DICK ABOUT MOVING THIS
BILL TO THE NEXT PHASE THEM
DISASTER.
ABOUT YOUR YOUR INVOLVEMENT BUT
MOST MPORTANT THAT YOU WILL
NEED TO CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION
SO THAT WE GET THE BEST BILL
POSSIBLE [inaudible]
BECAUSE ALL THE BILLS THAT HAVE
COME ON LAW ENFORCEMENT I THINK
REALLY IMPORTANT.
BUT AS FAR AS TRANSPARENCY IS
CONCERNED.
THIS DISTRIBUTE GAME CHANGER IF
WE DO IT RIGHT.
SELECT CHAIRS RECOMMEND AND I
VOTE WITH THE CHAIRS PERMISSION
IF I MAY JUST I WANTED TO THANK
YOU FOR MAKING THAT
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT I FORGOT TO
ADD WHICH IS THAT.
THAT TRANSPARENCY WOULD AS YOU
RIGHTFULLY POINTED OUT HOPEFULLY
ENABLE THE PUBLIC AND
JURISDICTIONS TO IF THERE IS A
CONTINUING PROBLEM.
I TRIED AND THEN IDENTIFY HOW.
TO FROM A POLICY OR PROCEDURE OR
PROCEDURAL WAY ADDRESS IT SO
THAT WE HAVE LESS OF IT.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IN IT WAS
A POINT I INTENDED TO MAKE SO
THANK YOU CHAIR.
YOU UP A BIT RECALL LITTLE.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY NO FOR
NOW LACKEY NO CARDIO.
CARDIO I KAMLAGER-DOVE HAVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
QUIRK AYE AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURES OUT
CONGRATULATIONS [inaudible]
JOB GROWTH [inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
MAY WE GO REAL QUICK WHETHER
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SELECT GO.
OKAY THANK YOU --
TO CHAIR MEMBERS S. B. THIRTEEN
OH THREE NUMBER THIRTEEN YOU
GOTTA THIRTEEN THIRTEEN AUG
SELECT SIXTEEN NO THREE MOVE THE
BELL JACKET.
ALRIGHT --
SO THANK YOU --
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO YOU
S. B. THIRTY NO THREE A BILL
THAT REQUIRES THE MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S OFFICE TO ESTABLISH
IN LIEU OF THE SHARE OF CORNER
AND COUNTIES OF POPULATION FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR MORE.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE LAST
THAT'S ONLY THREE STATES
MAINTAIN SHARE CORNER MODEL TO
ASSIST INVESTIGATE SUSPICIOUS
THAT'S THE SHERIFF AND THE SMILE
THE SHARE FOODS ALSO THE CHIEF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IS ALSO
CHARGED WITH CONDUCTING AUTOPSY
INVESTIGATING THE SUSPICIOUS
DEATH.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT MAY INVOLVE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AYE LAST WEEK I
TO MAKE NOTE IN ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I DID AGREE TO TAKE
FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS --
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE TAKEN
APPROPRIATIONS SPENDING YOUR
VOTE TODAY WHICH THEY MANAGE OR
CHOIR DATA COUNTY --
SHALL EITHER INSTITUTE A MEDICAL
EXAM WHEREBY.
THERE'S A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
FOR THE SHARE OF CORNER LET
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
OFFICER RELATED THAT'S FAMILY
RELATIONS INSTEAD OF THE COUNTY
SHOULD REFER THE MATTER TYPE OF
DEATH INVESTIGATION. TO ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA COUNTY THAT
IMPLEMENTS A MEDICAL EXAMINER
MODEL --
BASICALLY.
I WOULD JUST MAKE NOTES THAT --
SHARE FOR THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER.
SHARE CORNER MODEL DOES AND DOES
NOT HAVE A MEDICAL BACKGROUND
BUT CAN OVERRULE A BOARD
CERTIFIED FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS
PERTAINS THE MANNER OF DEATH
DETERMINATION WE HAVE SEEN THIS
HAPPEN IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY --
WHERE AND WHICH IS RESULT IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY DECIDING TO
MOVE TO A MEDICAL EXAMINER
SYSTEM MIGHT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
IT'S NOT ONLY HAPPENED SAN
JOAQUIN SANTA CLARA COUNTY?
THAT.
PURSUE SIMILAR ISSUE BACK INTO
TWENTY SIXTEEN AS WELL --
AS WELL AND THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
CINEMA COUNTY TASK FORCE
RECOMMEND SEPARATING THE OFFICES
CITING --
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST
IS ONE REASONS FOR THAT SPLIT --
EVEN THOUGH THEY RECOMMENDED
THAT.
POLITICAL PRESSURES LED --
TO THAT NOT ACTUALLY OCCURRING
SO THIRTEEN NO THREE IS ABOUT
ENSURING COUNTIES HAVE THE TOOLS.
TO HAVE A SYSTEM WHERE AUTOPSIES
ARE DONE AND ETHICAL EQUITABLE
MANNER IN THE SURE JUSTICE
ACROSS THE STATE EXPECT WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND I WENT TO SUPPORT BY MINUTES.
YEAH MISTER MEMBERS TO TALK
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION OR PROP COSPONSORED
THE BILL WOULD LIKE TO YIELD OUR
TIME TO OUR WITNESS OUT DOCTOR
AMAL LUBA HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
WELL MISTER CHAIR DOUG CHIP UP
EFFORT UNION OF AMERICAN
PHYSICIANS DENTISTS WOULD ASK ME
WHERE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
AND SAME WILL BE HAVING OUR TIME
TO DOCTOR MAILLOT JUST WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ALSO BRIAN NELSON
ANNOUNCEMENTS SUPPORTED A BILL
THANK YOU.
YES COULD OFTEN AND I WAS THE
PHYSICIAN WHO DISCOVERED.
CHRONIC TRAUMATIC ENCEPHALOPATHY
AND I HAD SO MUCH NEWS NOW NAY
FORMER QUARTERBACK WAS JUST
CONFIRMED TO HOP C. T. E. HE
COMMITTED SUICIDE.
ON LAST YEAR I RECEIVED THE THE
HIGHEST AWARD ANY PHYSICIAN CON
RECEIVING THE UNITED STATES FROM
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
TO SERVICE AWARD.
I COME HERE TO DO BEFORE YOU ARE
SO PHYSICIAN AND NASA SCIENTIST.
PEOPLE EARLY SPHERE TO SUPPORT
PUBLIC CONTRAST [inaudible]
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE.
UNDER PUBLIC TRUST.
I LOVE YOUR SLEEP PUBLIC SAFETY.
I WAS RUNNING AWAY FROM
PITTSBURGH PENNSYLVANIA IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE NFL.
WHEN I CAME TO SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY BECAUSE IT HAD NO NFL
TEAM?
I AND I CAME ABOUT WHEN I CAME
MY WIFE IS THAT NOT A SOCK
CHARLIE ADVICE ME GOT.
SHE TAUGHT HOW WOULD HOW
PROBLEMS WALKING IN AND I POLICE
ENVIRONMENT PASS A PHYSICIAN.
I'M NOT ALWAYS AS IT ALWAYS
HAPPENS MY WIFE IS ALWAYS RIGHT
ON SHE WAS RIGHT.
IN THE TEN YEARS I WAS IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY YOU MAY NOT
BELIEVE IT I HAVE.
FALL PUT SUCH APPLICATIONS ON
EIGHT DEGREES AND MATTER ST ON
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT.
SHARIF STEVE MOORE WAS
PREVENTING ME ON OUR DIVING ME
NOT TO ACT AND SINGS TO
INVESTIGATE [inaudible]
DEATH.
HE WOULD CALL ME TO HIS OFFICE
BEHIND CLOSED DOES TOO TAUGHT ME
ARE YOU STRUCK ME ON HOW HE
WANTED ME TO DO AUTOPSIES.
HOW HE WANTED ME TO WALK COURSES
ON MY NOSE UP DEBT?
HE SAID ABOUT TIMES CHANGED THE
MODEL OF THAT ON CASES WITHOUT
EVEN INFORMING ME ARE DOCTOR
DOCTOR PATTERSON.
THAT I WALKED WHICH I REMEMBER
ONE VERY.
SPECIFIC LOCATION I'M ONE OF THE
LEADING PLAYING TRAUMA EXPERTS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
I DID A CASE INVOLVING ON
OFFICER INVOLVED DEATH.
I IT'LL MEAN WHILE HE WAS
ADVANCED THAT HE WAS BEING A
VAST THAT IT WAS A VERY.
VIOLENT TOP MASSIVE BY A LINE
STRUGGLE.
AND HE SUFFERED WHAT WE CALL A
HIGH PASS.
EXTENSION IN JEWELRY OF HIS NECK
WHICH WERE.
HOWEVER US A PHYSICIAN IS NOT MY
DUTY TO JUDGE THE MOTIVE OUR
INTENT MY DUTY IS SIMPLY TO
DETERMINE COSTS OF THAT ON THE
MOUND OUTSIDE JUST DEMAND OUT OF
DEBT.
I EX ARMY TO PLAYING SUBJECT IT
TO VARIOUS SOPHISTICATED TISSUE
ANALYSIS CAME UP WITH PICASSO
DOT.
I REMEDY DAY HE CALLED ME TO HIS
OFFICE AND TOLD ME HE DID NOT
THAT CLEAR WEEKLY.
I'M BECAUSE HE WAS THE ELECT HAD
CARVE ON THE A DOT HE HAD BUILT
POLITY TO CHANGE IT ON ALL OF OF
LOAN ME.
WHAT I SAID TO HIM SO YOU KNOW
NO MATTER WHAT YOU MAY BELIEVE
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DO?
HE SAID TO ME I WALK FOR HIM ON
DOWN TO I'M THEM UNSUITABLE TO
HAVE.
THIS IS NOT UNIQUE TO ME ALONG.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES SPEAK CUTS
OF ONE REASON NOT DE ARTE.
THAT THEY CALLED WE TALK WE HAVE
OUR WEB PAGE WE TALK THEY'LL
EXPERIENCE INTO --
BUT I I'M A CHRISTIAN I'D CHOOSE
Y. SAT.
DOT YOU SHOULD NOT BE AFRAID.
I WAS ENOUGH WEIGHT TO RESIGN.
SIGH HOW TO PLEASE SIGN WE'D BE
OUT A DOCTOR IN THE OFFICE TO
BRING TO LIGHT.
DID THIS PROBLEM.
IT'S BUT FACE UP.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS A
LOT ECONOMY IN THE UNITED STATES
ON THE MOST POPULATED STATE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THE
ONLY STATE IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS UP OF THE POPULATION OF
THREE MILLION ASK YOUR HOUSE THE
SHARIF COORDINATE SYSTEM.
THE ONLY OTHER STATES ON THEM
BADA ON MONTANA.
MONTANA HAS A POPULATION OFF
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
NEVADA ABOUT THE MEDIA.
WHAT A BIG STATES NEW YORK PACK
SO SLAMMIN?
HAVE MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM THE
SHERIFF COHEN A SYSTEM WAS
CREATED IN THE EIGHTEENTH
CENTURY BY THE KING OF ENGLAND.
AND THAT MEDICAL EXAMINER SYSTEM
WAS CREATED IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
I'M BECAUSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST STATE
WITH THE BIGGEST.
WOULD YOU BE GUEST ECONOMY.
WE ARE CONTRIBUTING TO DISCUSS
CITY OUR FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS
IN THE COUNTRY IF NOT IN THE
WALL.
A STATE LIKE NOT COME ALIVE YOU
KNOW WE'D A POPULATION OF JUST
ABOUT LET'S NOT FIVE MILLION.
HOUSE TO TRAINING POSITIONS FOR
FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
ABOUT FIVE TIMES THE POPULATION
OF NOT COME ALIVE YOU KNOW HAS
ONLY TWO TRAINING POSITIONS AND
ONLY TO TRY NEW POSITIONS WE
HOPPED.
I SIGNED DIEGO I MEAN LOS
ANGELES SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
DEPROTECTION OF PUBLIC SAFETY
[inaudible]
PUBLIC TRUST.
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE A PUBLIC.
A TRUST.
WAY COOL MORE FORENSIC SCIENCE
TO THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
ANNOUNCED.
THANK YOU ORDER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT NOT NAMING
ORGANIZATION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRIAN
NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ABOUT MICHAEL RIGHTLY AND ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
AND SPORT.
THANK YOU.
AND WHAT ELSE.
MARGOT GEORGE ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MIKE ADOPT OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
BEEN BUSY TODAY FELLOW PERMANENT
SEAT ON THE OTHER SIDE.
CHECK AND MAKE IT STICK.
MUCH PREFER MEDICAL FOR BUILDING
AND MANY --
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RISK
OURSELVES EARLIER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION --
REGRETTABLY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL -- THAT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE AMENDMENTS
WE FOR SORT OF VAGUE DISCUSSIONS
OF THIS NOTION BUT I I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE BILL DOES OR
DOESN'T DO.
I ONLY KNOW WHAT'S IN PRINT
RIGHT NOW SOME GOING TO SPEAK TO
THAT AYE WE'RE HAPPY TO LOOK AT
ANY AMENDMENTS OF THE AUTHOR OF
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE --
BUT WITHOUT REVIEWING THOSE AND
HAVING.
I WILL BE ABLE TO WIN BUT I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THE SERVE CORNER
SYSTEM --
THAT NOTWITHSTANDING THE
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY CONTAINS A
MAJOR CHECK AND BALANCE --
THAT.
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHO THE CORNER
IS.
A DOCTOR ALWAYS DOES THE AUTOPSY.
PRACTICE AND IT WAS CODIFIED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE DOCTOR
DOES THE AUTOPSY IN DETERMINES
CAUSE OF DEATH.
THE CORNER IS THE EXAMINER IS
THE INVESTIGATOR AND DETERMINES
THE MANNER OF DEATH THESE ARE
TWO SEPARATE.
JOBS THEY'RE DONE BY TWO
SEPARATE PEOPLE.
AND THAT MAKES SENSE BECAUSE IF
THERE ARE DISCUSSIONS TO BE HAD
OR DIFFERENCES OF OPINIONS THIS
SYSTEM CAN WORK THOSE
DIFFERENCES OUT.
THERE WAS A QUESTION ABOUT SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY.
THAT MATTER HAS BEEN REPORTED ON
AUDITED.
THERE'S BEEN AN ACTION BY THE
BOARD AND THEY'VE TAKEN I DON'T
MEAN TO STEP ON MY COLLEAGUES
TESTIMONY BUT EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS COUNTIES.
DECIDE TO ABOLISH THEIR OFFICE
OF THE CORNER AND CREATE OFFICE
OF THE MEDICAL EXAMINER THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
DID MONTHS AGO THAT'S WHAT SANTA
CLARA COUNTY DID A COUPLE OF I
THINK.
WITHIN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
OTHER COUNTIES HAVE CONSIDERED
THIS THIS IS IN THE REALM IT'S
AN EXISTING LAWS GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION.
TWO FOUR ZERO ONE ZERO THIS
AUTHORITY EXISTS.
THE CORNER IS NOT A PHYSICIAN
THE NOTION THAT THE CORNER
DOESN'T HAVE MEDICAL TRAINING IS
A NON SEQUITUR THE CORNERS NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE MEDICAL
TRAINING THE CORNER IS NOT
UNDERTAKING THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE THAT'S THE DOCTOR'S JOB
AND THAT'S THE SYSTEM WE HAVE
TODAY.
AS I MENTIONED NECKS WITNESSES
SPEAK TO LOCAL CONTROL --
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF FORENSIC
PATHOLOGIST THAT WILL BE
EXACERBATED BY REQUIRING THIS IN
THESE COUNTIES.
EVEN THE THE THE RESPONSE WILL
BE THAT FRANCE A PATHOLOGIST ARE
ARE READY REQUIRED BUT IF THEY
ARE MANDATED UNDER THIS BILL. TO
BE HIRED IN CERTAIN COUNTIES.
IT WILL.
RESTRICT THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTRACT WITH OTHER COUNTIES
THIS IS VERY COMMON SET UP THAT
SMALLER COUNTIES WILL CONTRACT.
EITHER WITH THE FORENSIC
PATHOLOGISTS OR WITH ANOTHER
COUNTY WHO HAS A FRIENDS
PATHOLOGIST IN HOUSE THIS WILL
MAKE THAT MORE DIFFICULT --
I THINK THAT I WILL STOP THERE
AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU YET
AFTERNOON JESSICA SAVAGE IN THE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION JUST
ECHO WHAT MR FOR THE LOS THAT
COUNTIES CURRENTLY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CREATE A MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S OFFICE.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CAN
OPT TO ABOLISH THE AFTER THE
CORONER PURSUANT TO THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AND CREATE A
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S OFFICE.
COUNTIES THROUGH OUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE EXERCISED
DISABILITY.
AND CONSIDERED WHAT MODEL SERVE
THEIR PEOPLE BACK TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES MOST RECENTLY WE'VE
HAD VENTURA SANTA CLARA.
AND SAN JOAQUIN AND I THINK SAN
WELL IT'S WORKING.
A MAJOR ISSUE AROSE THE SAN
JOAQUIN BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAD
AN AUDIT CONDUCTED.
THEY RECEIVE THE AUDIT RESULTS.
BASED ON THOSE AUDIT RESULTS
THEY'VE CREATED A MEDICAL
EXAMINER'S OFFICE.
SO I'M OUR POSITION LIKE I SAID
FACE PRIMARILY A LOCAL CONTROL
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
AMENDMENTS AND WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. TO THE RIVER TO GET.
THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS POLIO HER
SHUDDERING THREE ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD SUPRISED SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY IN KERN COUNTY.
LINKED TO LEAD WITNESSES REALLY
NAILED IT A SEVENTEEN IS ALREADY
DOING --
WITH THE BILL WOULD PROPOSE THAT
THEY DO IN THE MEANTIME THE BILL
WOULD MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE
OTHER COUNTIES WOULD BE AFFECTED
BY THE BILL IF I CAN'T I'VE I'VE
MADE THIS REQUEST --
WANNA MAKE IT PUBLICLY IF THE
BILL COULD BE AMENDED DOWN THE
ROAD TO ALLOW MORE TIME IT'S
GONNA GO FORWARD TO ALLOW MORE
TIME FOR THE TRANSITIONING.
ON THAT WOULD HAVE TO OCCUR THE
BILL THAT WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LIEUTENANT SHIRLEY SO WILLIAM
SALMON MEDINA SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT ON BEHALF OF SHARE
THAT MAN IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESOLUTION MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE CORNERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITE.
SO CHAIR MEMBERS JOINT OR
SOMETHING AFTER URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO HER PATH THE
COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
SCARLETT HIS FOR THE SO I
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS PUBLIC
GUARDIAN SOME PUBLIC
CONSERVATIVES WERE OPPOSED.
NICOLE WERE LIMON ON BEHALF OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND UP.
RAYNE XIN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO
OPPOSE THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND WE LOOK
FOR TO A REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU --
BRING HERE ANY [inaudible]
QUESTION FROM [inaudible]
COMMITMENT.
HEARING NONE OF YOU MAY CLOSE
AND HOPEFULLY YOUR YOUR DRESS.
POLICE A COUPLE OF THE CONCERNS
OF FOR ME ESPECIALLY TO DISCUSS
ABOUT BILL.
ELAINE IT GETS WITH ELAINE
DEBILITATION.
OF IF THAT'S FEASIBLE.
WELL OR HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH
THEM ABOUT A CERTAIN CERTAINLY
OPENED IF --
NOW IT'S THAT THE WINDS WOULD
PROVE THEIR OPPOSITION THEM WAS
GOING -- TO
TO TO AND TO NEGOTIATE THE LIKE
THE ONLY ONE TO GIVE STATE
COUNTIES THAT APPROPRIATE TIME.
TO MAKE THE TRANSITION BY THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS IS ABOUT
ASSURING --
EQUAL JUSTICE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
DON'T I KEEP IN MIND YES SAN
JOAQUIN FINALLY MADE THE CHANGE
BUT THAT TOOK THE RESIGNATION AT
THEIR FORENSIC PATHOLOGISTS TO
SPEAK OUT.
NOW WE KNOW THAT OTHER FRIENDLY
POLICIES ARE FACING THE SAME
[inaudible] THREE YEARS.
THEY'RE NOT WILLING TO COME TO A
HEARING AT AT THAT SPEAK TO THE
PRESS ABOUT THIS ALRIGHT SO IF
YOU'RE TRAVELING IN ONE OF THOSE
OTHER COUNTIES AND YOU'RE
INVOLVED IN A LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVOLVED.
AND SOMEONE DOZEN AUTOPSY WHEN
YOU GO TO COURT --
THAT CORNER.
CAN CHANGE THE RESULTS OF THE
CELL YES A FRANTIC PATHOLOGISTS
WILL PERFORM THE AUTOPSY BUT THE
ACTUAL REPORT THAT THEN GOES TO
THE COURT.
THEY MEET THE MANNER OF DEATH
WILL BE THE SAME AS THE CHIEF
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER SO
INFECTED CORNERS OPPOSED IT'S
BECAUSE THEIR SHARE OF COURSE
THEY ARE THE SAME.
SAME PERSON ADMITTED COUNTIES
AND THAT'S COUNTY SO THIS IS AN
INHERENT CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
EVEN YOU KNOW YEAH SURE MOST
CHAIR OF CORNERS ARE TRYING TO
DO THE RIGHT THING BUT I MEAN
IT'S IT'S AN INHERENT CONFLICT
OF INTEREST TO HAVE THE SHERIFF.
CORNER ALSO BE THE PERSON WHO
OVERSEES AND DECIDES ON THE
FINAL REPORT TO ACTUALLY THIS
WHO ACTUALLY CAN THAT.
LIMIT THE INVESTIGATION OF THE
POSITION --
WHOSE ACTUALLYPERFORMING THE
INVESTIGATION THAT'S HAPPENED AS
WELL OUT WE NEED TO BE SURE
PEOPLE HAVE TRUST IN A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND I THOUGHT YOU
SHOULD BE AN OBJECTIVE FINDING
OF FACT IT'S IN THE IT SHOULD
NOT BE SOMETHING THAT IS.
SUBJECT TO CONFLICT AND ARE
PERCEIVED CONFLICT EXPECT THE
ASK FOR AND I THINK YOU WILL
[inaudible]
BUT THE WE'RE GONNA PUT IT
CHAIRED.
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE THAT ONE
BECAUSE WORK SUBJECT HERE ARE
SOME THINGS YOU CAN'T WORK OUT.
TO LIKE WE WE COME FROM OUR AREA
HAS BOTH A SHERIFF.
AND A MEDICAL EXAMINER AND THE
MEDICAL EXAMINER.
ACTUALLY WE HAD ONE IN THE PAST
THAT WAS NOT VERY ON THAT THEY
WERE DOING SOME THINGS THAT WERE
VERY ETHICAL.
SO IT COULD HAPPEN TO BOTH ENDS
STRIKE WHICH CD DID NEED TO KEEP
THEM APART AND I THINK PUT YOUR
YOUR POINT HAS HOW DO WE START A
SEPARATION SO WE HAVE DEALT
ECONOMY.
SO THAT --
MEDICAL EXAMINER SLASH FORENSIC
SCIENTISTS LAST QUINCY JACK
KLUGMAN TYPE OF PERSON ONLY SAY
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE WILL SMITH
HERE SO.
I'M GONNA.
THAT WE THAT WE DO HAVE THAT.
SEPARATION AND I THINK WILL ALSO
HELP.
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT THEY'RE NOT
INVOLVED IN THE ACTUAL SOLUTIONS
IF THEY'RE DOING.
THE THE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ARRESTING THEY SHOULDN'T BE ON
THE OTHER END --
LOOKING AT SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WITH THE THE SHOOTING ESPECIALLY
EVEN IF AN OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTING. ONE OF THEIR OFFICERS
TO I THINK THEY WOULD EVEN ENJOY
NOT BEING TOGETHER SO HOPEFULLY
YOU CAN.
YOU OR DO SOME OF THOSE AND
HOPEFULLY.
THE SHERIFF AND OTHERS
CONSTRUCTING BRACE THAT I THINK
WILL BE BEST FOR EVERYBODY
CONCERNED.
WITH THAT CHURCHES RECOMMEND AYE
VOTE.
S. B. THIRTEEN AT THREE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER TO ANSWER AYE LACKEY
[inaudible]
CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
MEASURE ON BECAUSE WE NEED THANK
YOU.
SOME OF THE MEMBERS TO GET BACK
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU [inaudible]
CHRIS LEYVA.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING WE'VE.
WE'VE HAD A BUSY DAY.
I'LL BE A LITTLE [inaudible]
IF IT [inaudible]
SECOND SINCE WE'RE DAILY.
OKAY THEN I'LL BE REALLY QUICK
FOR YOU HOW'S THAT SOUND THE
CORE OF S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
NINE CHANGES ONE WORD IT CHANGES
THE WORD FROM.
* SHOULD TO SHALL TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL RAPE KITS ARE
TESTED I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ELABORATE MORE IF YOU NEED
MISTER CHAIR BUT IF YOU'RE READY.
TO FOR TO MY WITNESSES I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THAT THAT THEY NOT
A PROBLEM LATER.
HI HOW ARE YOU GOING GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN NUMBERS.
ANY ESPOSITO ASSIST INTERESTED
ATTORNEY ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY SPONSORED S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
BACK WE EMBARKED ON THE TASK OF
IDENTIFYING ALL UNTESTED SEXUAL
SOCKETS.
THIS WAS A CUMBERSOME AND
PROTRACTED PROCESS.
AND IN PART BECAUSE WHEN WE WERE
THERE WAS SOME CONFUSION THERE
WASN'T ANY UNIFORMITY OF
CONSISTENCY IN THE PRACTICE OF
SELF AUDITING OR SELF REPORTING
FROM THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO THE LAB.
AND WHEN WE ASK THE LAB ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS ANY AND
TEST THE KIDS THE LOTS OF THERE
WAS NOT.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WERE NOT
REPORTING TO THEM.
WHEN IN FACT WE DISCOVER THAT
NINETEEN HUNDRED UNTESTED SEXUAL
SOCKETS WERE SITTING IN POLICE
EVIDENCE ROOMS?
TODAY THERE ARE NO UNTIES THE
SEXUAL SOCKETS INCLUDING THE
NINETEEN HUNDRED MANY OF THOSE
SEXUAL SOCKETS PRODUCED A DNA
PROFILE LINKED TO THE
PERPETRATOR WHICH NOW HAS BEEN
UPLOADED INTO THE CALIFORNIA
DATABASE IN CODIS.
WE NOW HAVE A PROCESS TEST ALL
THE SEXUAL SOCKETS.
BUT THE CURRENT LAW NIXON
MISSION OF THE SEXUAL SOCKETS
FOR TESTING BY LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERMISSIVE AND NOT REQUIRED.
DNA IS.
AS ON EVELYN A HOSE IT IS AN
AMAZING FORENSIC TOOL.
ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SOLVE
CRIMES AND CONVICT CRIMINALS
ESPECIALLY SERIAL OFFENDERS.
I'M TEST A SEXUAL SOCKETS MEAN
LOST OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP DNA
PROFILES.
SEARCH FOR MATCHES LINK COLD
CASES AND PROSECUTE OFFENDERS.
BY TESTING SEXUAL SOCKETS WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING
THE RESOLUTION AND JUSTICE FOR
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS SURVIVORS
AND PREVENT SEXUAL ASSAULT
CRIMES BY SERIAL OFFENDERS.
FURTHERMORE TESTING SEXUAL
ASSAULT KIDS CAN ALSO EXONERATE
INDIVIDUALS ROLLING IDENTIFIED
OR CONVICTED.
THE SMALL CHANGING CURRENT LAW
IN THIS BILL FROM SHOULD TO
SHALL WILL ENABLE SEXUAL SOCKETS
TASKS WHAT.
SUBMISSION AN ANALYSIS OF
FORENSIC EVIDENCE.
ENSURING THERE IS NO BACKLOG IN
EVIDENCE ROOMS AND OUT OR
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THEREFORE ON BEHALF OF THE
ALBANY COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES I
AM TODAY I'M REPRESENTING
NATASHA ALEXANDER GO A SURVIVOR
AND CO SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION THAT COULD NOT BE
HERE TODAY.
JUST MARRY A BRIEF STATEMENT
FROM HER I'LL BE BRIEF
[inaudible]
I'M.
I MISS SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVOR
AND SURVIVOR OF THE RAPE KIT
BACKLOG.
SURVIVOR VOICE YEARS ARE
CRITICAL IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND ALL EVERY SURVIVORS
EXPERIENCE IS DIFFERENT I WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK ABOUT MINE.
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE AS A
COLLEGE STUDENT IN NEW YORK CITY
I WAS KIDNAPPED WHILE WALKING
HOME TO MY PARTNER.
THIS STRANGER I MEAN AND I'VE
NEVER MET BEFORE VIOLENTLY RAPED
ME AND ROBS ME AGAIN POINT.
WHEN I SKIPPED AND THANKFULLY
FOUND MYSELF IN MY APARTMENT MY
ROOMIE INSISTED THAT I GO TO THE
HOSPITAL?
THE MEDICAL TEAM AT THE HOSPITAL
WAS AWARE OF THE FACT THAT MY
BODY WAS A CRIME SCENE.
GREAT CARE WAS TAKEN AND
COLLECTING THE EVIDENCE
NECESSARY TO FIND MY PERPETRATOR.
I ASSUMED AS DO MOST OTHER RAPE
SURVIVORS THAT VALUABLE
INFORMATION IN THAT CASE.
THAT WAS PAINSTAKINGLY COLLECTED.
WOULD BE PUT TO GOOD USE AND NOT
WOULD BE DELIVERED TO A FORENSIC
EXPERT AND OTHER CRIMINAL
JUSTICE PROFESSIONALS.
WHO WOULD USE IT TO IDENTIFY MY
ATTACKER AND BRING HIM TO
JUSTICE?
THERE MUST BE A REASON I WAS PUT
THROUGH THE HOURS LONG
EXAMINATION.
HOWEVER UNBEKNOWNST TO ME MY
RAPE KIT WAS NOT IMMEDIATELY
TESTED.
AT STYLE LONG WITH THOUSANDS OF
OTHER VICTIMS KIDS IN A PLEASE
EVIDENCE WAREHOUSE FOR TEN YEARS.
I WAS CONTACTED BY AN
INVESTIGATORS IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE A FULL DECADE AFTER MY
SALT TELLING ME THEY FINALLY HAD
A SUSPECT.
HE HAD BEEN ARRESTED AND NEVADA
ON A MINOR CHARGE AND POLICE
PERFORMED IT DNA CHEEKS BOB AND
ENTERED HIS PROFILE.
INTO THE COMBINED DNA INDEX
SYSTEM OTHER NO AUTHOR.
KNOWN AS CODICE.
HIS PER FROM MATCH THE DNA
SAMPLE COLLECTED AMERIC IT.
I HAD NOT BEEN HIS ONLY VICTIM
HE WAS A SERIAL RAPIST WHO HAD
MADE A CAREER OUT OF ITS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES.
HE WAS EVENTUALLY CONVICTED OF
THIS CRIMES AGAINSTME AND
OTHERS INCLUDING RAPE AND WAS
SENTENCED TO FORTY FOUR TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVEN YEARS IN
PRISON. FOR YEARS NOW I'VE BEEN
DIRECTLY INVOLVED A NATIONWIDE
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF RAPE KITS THAT
ARE BEING FOUND A POLICE
EVIDENCE ROOMS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
THESE KIDS HAVE LINGERED IN THE
QUIET DARKNESS ALONE AND
FORGOTTEN GATHERING DUST AND
MARKING TIME AS A STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS CLOCK.
SLOWLY TAKES FOR SOME THE CASES
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MUCH IT
MEANS TO ME TO SEE CALIFORNIA
TAKING STEPS TO IN.
EMPOWER SURVIVORS LIKE MYSELF
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE LA
COUNTY PROFESSIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ONLY [inaudible]
ONE OKAY TAKEN.
DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITY
SACRAMENTO WE APPLAUD THE AUTHOR
ASK THE AYE VOTE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS CASEY O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION VICE CHAIR FIONA
MONSTROS PORT THINK.
TIFFANY MATHEUS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY TOMAR
TOKAT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU.
BRIAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
.
MARGOT GEORGE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION --
REGRETTABLY WE MUST OPPOSE THIS
BILL I THINK THE FACT THAT
ALAMEDA COUNTY WAS ABLE TO TEST
THEIR BACKLOG.
ON SHOWS WHY THIS BILL ACTUALLY
ISN'T NECESSARY.
AND THE REASON THAT WE'RE
OPPOSING IT ALTHOUGH WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR REACHING
OUT TO US TO HAVE SOME
DISCUSSIONS WHICH WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE.
IS THAT IT PRIORITIZES RAPE
CASES ABOVE EVERY OTHER TIME A
VIOLENT FELONY.
AND FOR ME PERSONALLY I KNOW I
HAD A CLIENT WHO WAS CHARGED
WITH --
ROBBERY ARMED AND IN THE COURSE
OF THE ROBBERY WAS AT A
CONVENIENCE STORE HIS HAT FELL
OFF.
AND HE SAT IN JAIL IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY A FOR ALMOST A YEAR
BEFORE THEY TESTED THE HALF FOR
DNA.
IT WAS AN EYEWITNESS CASE UP
UNTIL THAT POINT AND THE DNA
EXONERATED HIM.
WELL WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD PUT.
THE MANDATORY EVERY SINGLE RATE
CASE FIRST REGARDLESS OF WHETHER.
PERSONS ALREADY PLED GUILTY.
ON THAT HAVE THE PERSON HAVES
OWN BEEN CONVICTED --
THAT SOME THE DNA ISN'T NEEDED
IN THE RAPE CASE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A CONFESSION OR OTHER
EVIDENCE THIS PUTS RAPE CASES
ABOVE MURDER CASES [inaudible]
ARMED ROBBERIES.
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON
KIDNAPPING EVERY OTHER KIND OF
CASE AND LIKE IN MY CASE IT HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO KEEP INNOCENT
PEOPLE IN JAIL. FOR A VERY LONG
TIME SO WE APPLAUD THE EFFORT WE
BASS BEFORE.
IN AN EFFORT TO DEAL WITH RATE
THAT THE KIDS BE TESTED BY THINK
THAT THEY SHOULD.
AND BUT I DON'T THINK BAT ON THE
SHOULD BE MANDATORY.
THAT IN EVERY INSTANCE OF RAPE
KITS TAKE PRIORITY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RT AND QUESTIONS FROM QUIRK
[inaudible]
YEAH -- THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PUBLIC
DEFENDERS KNOWS THAT.
I CONFESSIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
TRUE.
AND SO I I WOULDN'T USE THAT AS
A REASON NOT TO TEST TO REST
BRETT.
A RAPE KIT AND I'LL BE VOTING
FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
BOB ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
JUST QUICKLY SAY APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION'S VIEWPOINT BUT I
WOULD ALSO SAY THAT RAPE IS AN
INCREDIBLY VIOLENT AND LIKE
CHANGE THE CHANGING.
EVENT THAT HAPPENS TO SOMEONE
AND THIS BILL IN NO WAY PUTS
THOSE RAPE KITS IN FRONT OF
ANYTHING ELSE WE SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE LOSSES THAT
THEY SHOULD BE TESTED WE HAVE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE UNTESTED ODD THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO EXONERATE INNOCENT
PEOPLE THAT MIGHT BE IN JAIL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND UP BUT AND I THINK
WE JUST.
RIGHT NOW THE OPS IT'S HAPPENING.
RAPE KITS ARE BEING PUT AT THE
BOTTOM.
STATE OF BEING THERE ARE EVEN
BEING DONE AT ALL AND SO WE'VE
HAD.
I THINK WHAT THE SENATOR IS
SAYING NOT TO PUT THEM UP FRONT
BEGIN MAKE SURE TO GET DONE.
BY ANY MEANS NECESSARY TO GET
THEM DONE AND I DID DOES NOT A
PUSH.
OR IMPETUS TO GET IT DONE SO IF
THERE'S SOME WORDING.
THAT THAT YOU WOULD LIKE THEIR I
THINK THAT THE SENATE TO BE
ABSOLUTE GLAD TO SAY YOU KNOW
DON'T PUT ANY OTHER CASE TO THE
SIDE.
NO GET THEM ALL DONE AT THE SAME
TIME MEANT AND JUST DON'T LEAVE
OUT RATE KATE GREAT KIDS WE'RE
ALWAYS OPEN TO DISCUSSION.
OKAY THANK YOU CHOSE RECOMMEND
AYE VOTE.
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO.
KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
MEASURES ARE CALLED MARK THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MIL ON MISTER QUIRK.
SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR AUTHORS
[inaudible]
SENATORS.
BELLS DARN GLAZIER PORTANTINO.
HOPE PORT PORTANTINO BLASIER
BELL AND STERN.
ANY ORDER [inaudible]
ONE READ
ABOUT HER [inaudible]
HERE'S A ACCURATE
[inaudible]
EARLIER
.
THANK YOU MISTER PORTANTINO.
YOU HAVE TO ITEMS --
S. B. ELEVEN OOPS I'M SORRY
LEVELS I ACCEPT LEVEL SEVEN
SEVEN ALRIGHT WE'LL GO WITH THAT
ONE RIGHT NOW IF THEY GET.
ALRIGHT --
MISTER CHAIR --
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING S. B. ELEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN WHICH PROHIBITS ANY PERSON
FROM MAKING APPLICATION TO
PURCHASE MORE THAN ONE FIREARM.
WITHIN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD.
FARMS WILL NOT BE DELIVERED
WHATEVER NUCLEAR THEY'LL
NOTIFIED I GOT A MOTION THIS
BILL PASSED OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IT'S GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
IT'S GOOD FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU AND WITH ME.
IS AMANDA FROM THE BREAK
CAMPAIGN.
YES AMANDA WILCOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER TO THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
THIS IS BEEN UP PRIORITY POLICY
FOR US FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
WE BELIEVE HANDGUNS ALONG AND
SHOULD BE TREATED THE SAME I
JUST WANT YOU TO BE CLEAR WHAT
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL IS TO
CURB FIREARMS TRAFFICKING.
STANDS TO REASON WHEN SOMEONE'S
BUYING FIFTY GUNS AT ONCE BOB AT
THE TURN AROUND AND SELLING THEM
ON THE BLACK MARKET CITY ANTI
TRAFFICKING BILL AND THEN THE
OTHER KEY POINT IS MOST --
MOST LONG GUN PURCHASERS WOULD
NOT BE IMPACTED BY THIS BILL WE
DID A PUBLIC RECORD REQUESTS AND
FOUND THAT 82% OF LONG GUNS WERE
SOLD.
AS A SINGLE LONG GUN PURCHASE
WITHIN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD SOME
MOST LAW ABIDING GUN PURCHASERS
WOULD NOT BE IMPACTED ON THE
OTHER EXTREME ONE INDIVIDUAL
PURCHASE A HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN
GUNS WITHIN ONE MONTH.
AND THOSE GUNS FOR LOWER
RECEIVERS WHICH ARE BUILT UP
INTO SEMI AUTOMATIC HIGH POWERED
VERY LETHAL WEAPONS SO MAKE
SENSE TO HAVE LONG GUN LAW IN
THIS REGARD.
MATCH HANDGUN LAW AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
CALLING QUICK BAY AREA STERN ACT
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ VOLUNTEER FOR
THE BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT
GUN VIOLENCE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
CHAPTER.
JIM WYNNE BURGER ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND
READ THE NATIONAL RIFLE
ASSOCIATION.
ALSO YOUR FIRST YEAR PLAY I IN
OPPOSITION TODAY AND SEE AND
WALK INTO THE ROOM.
WHERE A STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL OF THIS BILL --
FOCUSES ON LAW ABIDING IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE VERY
STRINGENT GUN LAWS.
AND PRETTY MUCH EVERY SINGLE
TRANSFER ABSENT SOME VERY
LIMITED EXCEPTIONS HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A DEALER.
AND THE DEALERS ARE PERFORMING A
BACKGROUND CHECK THEIR CHECKING
FOR FSE.
EX CENTER SO.
WHO'S GONNA POLICES IT'S GONNA
BE A DEALER WHO'S GOING TO LIMIT
THE NUMBER OF LONG GOING TO CAN
BE PURCHASED IN A MONTH RIGHTS
OF THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT.
ARE GOING TO OUR BACKGROUND
CHECKS WERE BUT COMPLYING WITH
OUR LAWS WHO'S NOT COMPLYING
WITH OUR LAWS CRIMINALS WERE
CRIMINALS GETTING THEIR FIREARMS
NOT FROM DEALERS THEIR OPERATING
OUTSIDE THE SYSTEM SO THIS IS
NOT AN IMPACT THEM --
SOME OF THE PROPONENTS OF THE
BILL MENTIONED TRAFFICKING.
AND TRAFFICKING IS RTO JR --
ADDRESSED IN OUR PENAL CODE IN
LESS THE TRANSFERS ARE
INFREQUENT WITHOUT REGULARITY.
INDIVIDUALS ENGAGING TO TRANSFER
ALL ALONG AND MUST HAVE A
LICENSE.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE SO THAT'S ALREADY
ADDRESSED SO AGAIN WE HAVE
ANOTHER BUILDING GOES RIGHT
AFTER THE LAW ABIDING THAT'S NOT
GOING TO ADDRESS THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT WHO ARE NOT GOING TO THE
LEGAL CHANNELS RIGHT NOW.
THAT WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT DID LO MIXTURE MEMBERS ARE
COMMITTEE CARGOES ABOUT FARMS
POLICY COALITION OF THIS MEASURE
WHICH --
WHICH DEALS WITH A CLASS.
THAT'S WHAT I DID A FEW MONTHS
AGO.
MOM YOU KNOW.
I GUESS MY MY MY CONCERN HERE IS
IS THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S HARD FOR THE
AVERAGE PERSON TO FOLLOW PUBLIC
POLICY WHEN BILLS CAN BE.
A AMENDED TO INCLUDE ALL SORTS
OF DIFFERENT LANGUAGE I KNOW
THAT THERE USED TO BE A RULE IN
THE LEGISLATURE CALLED GERMANUS
RULE.
WHERE IF YOU'RE GOING TO AMEND
THE BILL THEN THAT THE TOPIC THE
NEW WHATEVER'S DEMAND AMENDED
INTO THE BILL NEEDED TO BE
GERMANE TO THE OLD TOPIC?
I I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THAT RULE
WENT AWAY BUT CLEARLY I DON'T
SEE HOW A BILL DEALING WITH
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES --
HAS TO DO ANYTHING TO DO WITH
PURCHASING ONE OF FIREARM AMONG.
THE IF THE AVERAGE CITIZEN
DAMIANA GET YOU WANT TO PASS
LAWS AND YOU WANT THE AVERAGE
YOU WANT CITIZENS TO BE ABLE TO
TO TAKE THE LAWS THAT ARE PASSED
BY THIS BODY SERIOUSLY.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THAT IF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO.
SETS ITS OWN RULES I MEAN THE
MAJORITY PARTY GETS A CHANCE TO
SET THE RULES IF THE MAJORITY
PARTY IS NOT EVEN GOING TO TAKE
ITS OWN RULES SERIOUSLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE PRO THAT THE
PROPOSING OF LEGISLATION.
WELL THEN HOW WITH THE AVERAGE
CITIZEN TO TAKE THE LAWS THAT
ARE PASSED OUT OF THIS
LEGISLATURE SERIOUSLY.
I THOUGHT I I WILL CONTEND THIS
BUT SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE
THE THE POWER.
YOU DO IT DOES NOT NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT IT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO WHEN YOU ESTABLISH RULES
AT THE VERY LEAST THIS BODY
OUGHT TO FOLLOW THE RULES THAT
IT IS SAID.
THE AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL ARE
NOT GERMANE TO THE ORIGINAL
TOPIC I DON'T SEE HOW ANYBODY A
WHO CLAIMS TO BE LITERATE CAN
READ IT AND SAY THAT IS GERMANE
TO THE ORIGINAL TOPIC.
AND THEREFORE I THINK THIS BILL
SHOULD BE REJECTED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IF YOU.
CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS SAMPRAS
REPRESENTING GUN OWNERS
CALIFORNIA.
A IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL HAS BEEN STATED --
BY MY COLLEAGUES HERE BOTH ON ON
ON THE THE SUBJECT MATTER OF THE
OF THE BILL AND ON THE THE
PROCESS WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND WHEN IT IS NOT --
FOLLOWING ITS OWN RULES IT IT IT
IT REALLY CAST A PALL.
OF THAT IS NEGATIVE ON THIS
AUGUST BODY --
I WORK FOR A A MAN WHO SERVED IN
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS [inaudible]
AND STILL HOLDS IT IN RED AND
REFERENCE --
AND AND SO THAT SO WHY HE'S
PASSED THAT ON TO US.
WITH REGARDS TO THE SPECIFICS OF
THIS BILL.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
THERE IS A IN ANY SORT OF A
TRAFFICKING OF LONG GUNS FROM
LEGAL PURCHASES.
THAT WOULD BE THE EASIEST THING
IN THE WORLD FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY.
AND TO TO TO CHARGE PERSONS WITH
THE CRIME WITH THE EASIEST.
SO THIS BILL IN EFFECT ONLY
APPLIES TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW WHICH IS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE SO IN
ORDER TO KAT.
ME BE A SMALL GROUP OF PEOPLE.
YOU ARE IMPOSING OR RESTRICTING
THE RIGHTS.
OF THE VAST MAJORITY OF LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS WE THINK THAT
IT IS -- NOT
ONLY UNWISE WE BELIEVE IT TO BE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND CERTAINLY
UNFAIR --
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE IN A
PILE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I CAN'T BE LUNCH REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL SHOOTING SPORTS
FOUNDATION SPY CLUB
INTERNATIONAL OUTDOOR SPORTS WAS
COALITION CALIFORNIA SPORTSMEN'S
LOBBY ON STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS WHY JOHN AND I'M AN
INTERNET GUN OWNERS OF
CALIFORNIAN ALSO REPRESENTING
YOUNG GUN OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU SIR.
MEMBERS.
THEN YOU MAY CLOSE AND AND IN
YOUR CLOSING AYE I KNOW --
TO PORTANTINO YOU'RE PROBABLY
ONE OF THE SMARTEST PEOPLE IN
BOTH HOUSES YOU KNOW PUBLIC NO
RULES BETTER DAY.
YOU'VE BEEN AROUND FOR AWHILE HE
PROBABLY KNOWS THE RULES BETTER
ANYBODY ELSE IF YOU IF YOU WANT
TO GO AHEAD.
ABSOLUTELY OUT IN A RASH ON MY
HEAD I CAN ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS OF FIRST OF ALL THE
ORIGINAL BILL WAS INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET --
SO THAT'S WHY THE REGIONAL BELL
WAS IN ESSENCE NO LONGER NEEDED
BOTH HOUSES MADE AN AGREEMENT TO
NOT MOVE --
BILLS THAT HAD BEEN IN THE
BUDGET THE STATE FRANKLY HAD
INVESTED IN THAT VEHICLE --
TO GET THIS FAR ON THIS IS NOT A
NEW POLICY --
THIS IS A POLICY THAT THIS
COMMITTEES VERY FAMILIAR WITH SO
WAS TOTALLY APPROPRIATE AND
WITHIN THE RULES TO PUT --
THE CONTENTS INTO THAT BELLOWS
REFERRED.
LEGALLY YOU KNOW THROUGH ALL THE
PROPER CHANNELS SO ARE IT'S
OFTEN SOMETHING PEOPLE.
BRING UP WHEN A BILL CHANGES ITS
CONTENT IN THE PROCESS PEOPLE
WILL CRY FOUL BUT THERE THERE IS
NO FOUL NO FOUL WAS COMMITTED.
WERE HAVING THIS HEARING PUBLIC
ON TELEVISION SO.
THE PROPONENTS AND OPPONENTS
INCOME.
WEIGHED IN AND MAKE THEIR CASE --
SO AGAIN NO VIOLATION OF
CERTAINLY THIS COMMITTEE WOULD
NOT BE PARTY TO ANY VIOLATION OF
ANY ROLE SO --
WITH THAT AS I SAID THIS POLICY
IS PASS THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
BEFORE.
THE REASON WHY WE MOVED IT OUT
OF THE OTHER BILL AS WE WANTED
EACH BILL TO BE CLEAN SO.
GIVING AN OPPORTUNITY FRANKLY TO
HAVE FURTHER COMMENTS THAT
CONVERSATION ABOUT THESE SO AND
NO ONE SHOULD BE.
UNDER THE ILLUSION THAT THIS
PARTICULAR POLICY HAS NOT BEEN
VETTED DISCUSSED --
ADD INFINITUM AND AGAIN TODAY SO
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IN THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE AND IN.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THE
EXPLANATION [inaudible]
AND CLARIFICATION.
OVERALL SB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES ARE AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY
[inaudible]
QUIRK QUIRK ICE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSED.
AND I WILL NOT BE PRESENTING AT
TWELVE SIX THANK YOU MISTER
PORTANTINO CENTER PARK HERE
.
I DO SEE YOU THERE MR GLAZER
SENATOR GLAZER PLEASE GO.
THANK YOU FOR FORGETTING HERE
THAT.
BUT A VERY BUSY DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT THAT THIS
BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE PEOPLE
CONVICTED OF SOLICITING OR
ENGAGING IN PROSTITUTION WITH A
MINOR. TO PROVIDE DNA SAMPLES
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
IDENTIFICATION ANALYSIS.
WHEN THE NEW TIERED REGISTRY
TAKES EFFECT IN?
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE THIS
BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THOSE
WHO ARE CONVICTED TWO REGISTERED
SEX OFFENDERS FOR TEN YEARS.
WHICH IS THE LOWEST HERE.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THOSE WHO ARE
CONVICTED TO AVOID REGISTERING
AS A SEX OFFENDER IF.
THEY HAD REASON TO BELIEVE THE
VICTIM WAS NOT A MINOR.
WHAT ABOUT THE VICTIM'S AGE OR
LESS THAN THREE YEARS OLDER THAN
THE VICTIM AT THE TIME OF THE
SOLICITATION?
IN A STUDY CONDUCTED BY THE
OAKLAND SPECIAL VICTIMS UNIT.
THIS FOUND THAT 85% OF UNSOLVED
MURDERS IN THE CITY INVOLVED A
PROSTITUTE.
MINORS ARE ESPECIALLY AT RISK.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
ALONE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MINORS WERE RESCUED FROM
PROSTITUTION.
HOWEVER THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM
PARTICULAR TO OAKLAND.
OF ALL THE PEOPLE ARRESTED FOR
SOLICITING A PROSTITUTE TWO
THIRDS WERE FROM OUTSIDE OF
OAKLAND.
INCLUDING SEVEN OTHER COUNTIES.
WITH NO MAJOR METRO POLITICIAN
AREA UNTOUCHED BY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING A STATEWIDE
RESPONSES REQUIRED TO MAKE SURE
WE ADDRESS THOSE TO PERPETUATE
THE SYSTEM.
OF SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
IN RECENT YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE'S MADE GREAT
PROGRESS TO PROTECT MINORS WHO
WERE VICTIMS OF SEX TRAFFICKING.
THIS BILL REINFORCES OUR PRIOR
EFFORTS BY ADDRESSING THOSE THAT
CREATED DEMAND FOR THE
TRAFFICKING OF MINORS.
HAVE WORKED TO MAKE THIS A
BIPARTISAN BILL.
THAT NARROWLY TARGETS THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO PERPETUATE THE
SYSTEM THAT PREYS ON MINORS.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL WAS ABLE TO
CLEAR THE SENATE FLORIDA THIRTY
NINE TWO ZERO VOTE.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE I'M JOINED BY SOME
WONDERFUL WITNESSES WHICH I HOPE
WILL PROVIDE [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
[inaudible]
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS ANY
ESPOSITO ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY NANCY
O'MALLEY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE PEOPLE CONVICTED
OF ILLEGALLY PAYING FOR SEX TO
PROVIDE DNA SAMPLES FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IDENTIFICATION
ANALYSIS.
IT WOULD ALSO HELP IDENTIFY
BUYERS OF SEX PLATH SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED SOMEONE IN THE PAST OR
ATTEMPTED TO PURCHASE SEXUALLY.
EXPLOITED MINERS.
BUYERS OF SEX PERPETUATE SEX
TRAFFICKING BY CREATING DEMAND
FOR IT.
ALTHOUGH THERE HAVE BEEN EFFORTS
TO PROTECT MINORS NOT ENOUGH HAS
BEEN DONE TO ADDRESS THOSE THAT
PERPETUATE THE SYSTEM.
AS LONG AS THERE IS A DEMAND.
THERE WILL BE AN EXPLOITER TO
FILL IT.
INDIVIDUALS WHO PURCHASE HUMAN
BEINGS FOR SEX FUELED THE MARKET.
THAT TRAFFICKERS SUPPLY WITH
VICTIMS.
UNTIL WE ELIMINATE THAT DEMAND.
AND ADDRESS THE ISSUE WITH
DEMAND.
SEX EXPLOITATION OF OUR
SOCIETY'S MOST VULNERABLE GIRLS
WOMEN AND MORE MEN AND BOYS WILL
CONTINUE.
AND THIS BILL.
IT TARGETS THAT DEMAND SEEKING
TO ELIMINATE IT.
SO ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPOD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CODE ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION --
THE CALIFORNIA NARCOTICS
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PROFESSIONAL PEACE
OFFICER SAYS I ASSOCIATION.
AND THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
PROTECTIVE LEAGUE BY MAY BE
PERMITTED A BRIEF HISTORICAL A
REFERENCE.
AS A YOUNG PROSECUTOR WITH THE
LA CITY ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE I
PROSECUTED THE FIRST CASES THAT
WERE BROUGHT.
AGAINST CUSTOMERS --
FOR FOR HOW OLD ARE YOU.
WHO DEAL WITH IT?
BOB OUT ANY OTHER WITNESSES
[inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
SHARE MEMBERS COURCELLES ALONG
WE HAVE A CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MARCO GEORGE --
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PUB PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION THEN
OPPOSITION --
I WON'T SAY BAD I DEFENDED THOSE
FIRST CASE THAT A NOT QUITE BUT
I'VE HAD A FEW --
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL BECAUSE
REALLY THE THREE TIERED SEX
OFFENDER SYSTEM.
OF REGISTRATION WAS JUST ENACTED
LAST YEAR --
IT HAS HAS NOT GONE INTO EFFECT
IN THIS TOO EARLY TO START
CHANGING THE RULE.
THE RULES THERE ALREADY ARE
SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES --
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONVICTED OF MISDEMEANORS SEX
OFFENSES WITH MINORS THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER FOR A
MINIMUM PERIOD OF TEN YEARS --
IT'S EXTENDED FOR ANY OTHER
CONVICTIONS OR THEY'D HAVE TO
PETITION THE COURT FOR AN ORDER
TERMINATING THAT REQUIREMENTS.
AND IF THE PROSECUTOR REQUEST A
HEARING ON THE PETITION TO
TERMINATE THE REGISTRATION ORDER --
THE HEARING TAKES PLACE AND THE
COURT DETERMINES THAT THE
HEARING IF THE CONVICTED PERSON.
US STILL POSES A RISK OF RE
OFFENSE.
SO ON SB --
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ALTHOUGH HE
AND I'M SURE WE'RE ALL WOULD
LIKE PAN SEX TRAFFICKING.
AND ESPECIALLY SEX TRAFFICKING
OF MINORS.
BUT THERE'S NO STUDY THAT'S EVER
CONCLUDED THAT INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF SOLICITING A
PROSTITUTE.
RE OFFEND AFTER APPREHENSION AND
CONVICTION AT A HIGHER RATE THAN.
DO THOSE CONVICTED OF OTHER
MISDEMEANOR SEX CRIMES INVOLVING
A MINOR.
ON AND TO THE CONTRARY MEN
ARRESTED AND PROSECUTED FOR
SOLICITING A PROSTITUTE.
THE MAP THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM HAVE LITTLE OR NO CRIMINAL
HISTORIES --
MANY OF THEM ARE OLDER AND MANY
OF THEM ARE FOR MORE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO BE EMPLOYED EDUCATED
AND EITHER MARRIED OR IN
RELATIONSHIPS.
RARELY RE OFFEND IRRESPECTIVE OF
THE TARGETED PROSTITUTES
CHRONOLOGICAL AGE.
SO THIS WOULD BE --
THIS WOULD BE PUBLIC POLICY THAT
IS NOT EVIDENCE BASED IT'S NOT
FACT BASED.
WE ENACTED LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE DID.
LEGISLATION THAT WAS.
AND THE PURPOSE OF THAT
LEGISLATION WAS TO HAVE PEOPLE
REGISTER IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THEIR RISK [inaudible]
AND ABOUT WAS DONE NOT JUST TO
GIVE THE CITIZENS WHO HAD BEEN
CONVICTED OF A SEX OFFENSE A
CHANCE TO REHABILITATE
THEMSELVES.
BUT IT WAS DONE TO MAKE US ALL
SAFER.
BECAUSE WHEN POLICE DEPARTMENTS
EXPEND RESOURCES ON TRACKING
DOWN EVERY SEX OFFENDER
REGARDLESS OF THEIR OWN LEVEL OF
RISK CORD LIKELIHOOD TO REOFFEND.
THAT MEANS THOSE RESOURCES ARE
NOT USE. TO PURSUE PEOPLE WHO
ARE MORE DANGEROUS.
AND TO PROTECT THE CITIZENRY
[inaudible]
SO. ONE MIGHT SAY THAT THIS.
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY --
HURT NOT HELP --
WELL I THINK I'LL LEAVE IT TO
THIS DOCTOR ROUGH TOOK --
FOLLOW UP WITH THAT SORT OF THE
LEGAL RATIONALE AND QUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST LIKE A
DOCTOR OFF ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA RECORD REGRETFULLY
WE REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE SPELL
AS WELL FOR THREE KEY REASONS I
FIRST WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL WILL HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
WE KNOW THAT WHILE PEOPLE OF ALL
RACES ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATIONS PURCHASE
COMMERCIAL SACKS LOW INCOME
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND LGBTQ PEOPLE
ARE THE ONES TYPICALLY ARRESTED
CHARGED AND CONVICTED FOR THESE
OF FUNDS AS SAN FRANCISCO'S
PUBLIC DEFENDER RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT 60% OF PEOPLE
ARRESTED FOR LOITERING WITH.
INTENT TO COMMIT PROSTITUTION IN
THE CITY ARE LATINO.
AND POLICE DEPARTMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO REGULARLY
TARGET AND ARREST GAY MEN ON
CHARGES OF SOLICITATION AND
OTHER OFFENSES.
GIVEN THE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT SOLICITATION LAWS ALREADY
HAVE ON THESE COMMUNITIES
REQUIRING REGISTRATION WILL
RESULT IN FURTHER BURDEN.
SECOND EVEN THOUGH AS THE
AUTHOR'S NOTES AND MY COLLEAGUE
THAT THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY
HAS BEEN REFORMED AND THAT THIS
BILL WILL NO LONGER IMPLICATE
LIFETIME REGISTRATION.
A DECADE ON THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY COULD STILL HAVE
LIFETIME CONSEQUENCES FOR
INDIVIDUALS PARTICULARLY PEOPLE
OF COLOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND LGBTQ
PEOPLE.
INCLUSION ON THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRY CAN MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO GET A JOB FIND
HOUSING PARENT AND REHABILITATE.
INCLUSION ON REGS ON THE
REGISTRATION CAN ALSO BE
DESTABILIZING OTHER WAYS SUCH AS
CAUSING PEOPLE TO FALL INTO
DEPRESSION AND EXACERBATING
OTHER MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
THIS TYPE OF DESTABILIZATION CAN
ALSO LEAD TO RECIDIVISM.
AND LASTLY THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY CURRENT LAW ALREADY
REQUIRES THAT ANY ADULT WHO
ACTUALLY ENGAGES IN A SEX ACT
WITH A MINOR BE CONVICTED OF A
FELONY.
WHICH WOULD AUTOMATICALLY
REQUIRE DNA COLLECTION AND SEX
OFFENDER REGISTRATION.
ADDITIONALLY COURTS ALREADY HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO REQUIRE ANYONE
CONVICTED OF MISS IT MISDEMEANOR
SOLICITATION TO REGISTER AS A
SEX OFFENDER WHEN APPROPRIATE.
SO LONG AS THE COURT FINDS THAT
THE PERSON COMMITTED THE CRIME
FOR SEXUAL GRATIFICATION.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ANYONE WHO IS
REQUIRED TO REGISTER AS A SEX
OFFENDER ALSO HAS TO SUBMIT DNA.
IN THIS WAY CURRENT LAW IS
PREFERABLE IN THAT IT ALLOWS FOR
A CASE BY CASE DETERMINATIONS
AND DOESN'T UNNECESSARILY
CAPTURE PEOPLE WHO DO NOT BELONG
ON THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY OR
IN THE DNA DATABASE.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU ARMENIA AND WHAT ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
MAKE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
FOR YOU MAY CLOSE UP FULLER
[inaudible]
THERE'RE LACKEY.
YEAH I'M A CLEAR GOING TO BE
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT I
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LANGUAGE.
IT SEEMS TO PLACE THE THE BURDEN
OF PROOF ON THE DEFENDANT RATHER
THAN THE PROSECUTION.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE ROUTE OF
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT SHOULD
INCLUDE REQUIRING PROOF OF THE
DEFENDANT KNEW OR REASONABLY
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THE
VICTIM WAS A MINOR.
THE WORD SOLICITATION SHOULD NOT
BE INCLUDED BECAUSE THE
UNDERLYING CRIME COVERS
ADDITIONAL LACKS THE TERM.
THE COURT FINDS SHOULD NOT BE
INCLUDED.
AND THAT'S ALL.
ANYONE ELSE YOU MAY CLOSE LANKY
OTHER MEMBERS FOR HERE IN THE
BILL I HAD TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY I THINK THOSE ARE
SUGGESTIONS LIKE CERTAINLY
INCORPORATE.
AYE IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
LET ME JUST SAY A COUPLE THINGS
FIRST I I VOTED FOR THE REGISTRY
CHANGE LAST YEAR.
AND IN A WAS CAREFULLY CRAFTED --
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE VARIOUS
OFFENSES THAT THAT WOULD PUT
SOMEONE ON THAT LIST AND ARE ALL
ALL THAT'S BEEN SUGGESTED IN
THIS BILL AS THEY GO ON AT THE
LOWEST HERE I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GOING TO INTERFERE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY. TO TO
MONITOR THOSE WHO ARE THE MOST
SERIOUS OFFENDERS ON THAT LIST --
BUT IT DOES HAVE THEIR CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN RAISED ON THAT ISSUE I
WANT TO JUST IDENTIFY THAT.
IF THERE IS A CHOICE IN THIS
BILL THAT WAS MORE IMPORTANT TO
ME WOULD NOT BE THE REGISTRY
ISSUE WOULD BE WOULD BE THE
CAPTION AT THE DNA --
AND THIS BILL WAS BROADER WHEN
IT WAS HEARD IN THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
AND IT WAS THROUGH THE GOOD WORK
OF THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF THAT
IT WAS NARROWED TO THIS PLACE UP.
OF ONLY TAKING DNA FROM AYE
THOSE A CONVICTED OF GAUGING
BRING PROSTITUTION WITH A MINOR.
I THINK THAT WAS A COMPROMISE
THAT WAS DIFFICULT TO ACCEPT AT
THE TIME BUT IT IS WHAT'S BEFORE
YOU TODAY AND I THINK IT IS A
STEP OF MODEST VERY MODEST STEP
FORWARD IN TRYING TO ACTUALLY
CATCH BAD PEOPLE --
WHOEVER THEY ARE WHEREVER THEY
ARE THAT I'VE IF DATA.
THAT BAD SEX WITH A MINOR AS A
PRECURSOR TO SOMEONE WHO COMMITS
MURDER OR RAPE OR OTHER MORE
SERIOUS CRIMES.
WE CERTAINLY --
I THINK THERE'S OF A FINE I
DON'T APPROPRIATE BALANCE OF TO
HAVE.
BEING ABLE TO TAKE THAT SWAB IN
THAT DNA.
UPON THAT PERSONS THAT --
CONVICTION AND ALLOWING US TO A
FIFTH OF THE COURSE OF THINGS
THAT WE FIND THAT THEY KICK A
COMMITTED A MUCH MORE SERIOUS
CRIMES SO.
I KNOW WE ALL WANT TO PROTECT
OUR MINERS THEY KNOW THERE'S NO
DIFFERENCES REPUBLICANS
DEMOCRATS.
ON THIS PANEL.
AND I THINK THIS BILL IS THAT
MODEST STEP FORWARD AND IF THERE
IS CONCERN ABOUT THE REGISTRY.
OR MAKE A CHOICE MISTER CHAIRMAN
REPEATED MAINTAIN THE DNA
COLLECTION WILL WORK CAN EITHER
WORK IN IN FUTURE YEARS ON THE
REGISTRY ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND AT IT AND I KNOW
YOU VERY SINCERE ABOUT THIS AND
OTHERS. TO IN ALPHA NO YOU
WITNESSES VERY WELL THAT --
THEY WOULDN'T BE HERE UNLESS
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT MATTER --
VALLEY JUST YOU BUT WHAT DID --
SO I'M NOT TOTALLY A HYPOCRITE.
WILL I ALWAYS SIDE WITH OF
DIESEL EXISTING LAW WE CAN DO IT.
WITH THAT LAW THAT WE SHOULD ADD
ON TOP OF THAT.
I KNOW WE WOULD JUST COMMITTEE
HAS ADDED ON FOR A MINUTE.
TOTALLY HYPOCRITICAL BUT MOST IS
TIED THAT IS BECAUSE YOU MAY BE
LOOPHOLES IN THE LAW OR IS NOT
REALLY CLEAR OR SOMEONE OR ITS
NOT BEING --
IMPLEMENTED.
AT ALL AND THAT'S WHY SOMETIMES
WE DO.
WE DO ALL THE LAW THAT KINDA
CLARIFIES PUTS IN STATUTE WHICH
IS ALREADY WHAT ARE A SHOULD BE
DONE AND SO ON IN THIS COMMITTEE
HAS DONE THAT BEFORE.
OF IN THIS INSTANCE --
AYE AYE DICTATE THE OPPONENTS
HAVE A VALID REASON THAT.
THIS IS ALREADY BEING DONE AT
THAT COURTS HAVE THE DISCRETION
THAT ANYONE DOES THIS PARTICULAR
CRIME.
THAT OF BE ABLE TO LIVE THE
COURTS HAVE THE DISCRETION OF TO
GO AHEAD AND NOT ONLY FOR THE
REGISTRY BUT ALSO [inaudible]
AND TAKE DNA SAMPLES AND SO FOR
THAT ONE READ THE SECOND
[inaudible]
IS DION.
I'M WANTED WHEN I GOT HERE
TWENTY TWELVE I GOT BEATEN UP ON
THEIR OTHER REGISTRY IN A SEXUAL
OFFENDER REGISTRY COULD THAT THE
LA DA WANTED US TO MAKE SOME
CHANGES.
AND IT TOOK.
UNTIL LAST YEAR --
I CARRIED THE FIRST BILL ON THAT
AND WAS.
VICIOUS RATED ON THE FLOOR
BECAUSE I WANTED TO HELP SEX
OFFENDERS THAT'S NOT WHAT I
WANTED TO DO.
AND I'M GLAD WE GOT TO A POINT
NOW WHERE WE ACTUALLY REFORMING.
THE THE SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY SO
MY SECOND ISSUE IS ALWAYS
IMPLEMENTATION.
THAT WE GIVE THINGS TIME TO TO
BE UP ABOUT IT SO WE CAN SEE IF
IT WORKS OR NOT.
AND SO OF LOS TO REASON
FORTUNATELY --
I WOULD RECOMMEND A NO VOTE --
AND IF THINGS AREN'T WORKING OUT
AFTER IS IMPLEMENTED AND ANY
SOME CHANGES.
OR YOU NEED SOME CLERICAL WE
NEED SOME CLARIFICATION AND IF.
YOU WANNA WILL WORK TOGETHER ON
A BILL THAT KIND OF GET SO THAT%
I BE HAPPY TO DO THAT BUT AS
TODAY UNFORTUNATELY THE
RECOMMENDED OVER [inaudible]
SECOND.
MEDICARE CALL THE ROLL.
S. B. SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN THE
MOTION AS DO PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE GARCIA.
COUNTY NOT VOTING KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE NOW KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK NO SANTIAGO.
TRY THAT MEASURE FAILED.
I GAVE HER CHAIR [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
RECONSIDERATION [inaudible]
YEAH.
IT'S A GOOD BILL.
BALANCE STERN SENATORS BELL AND
STERN I SAW SENATOR STERN POP IN
AND LOOK [inaudible]
REALLY.
CAN WE DO SOME --
YEAH.
LET'S.
LET'S GO AND FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS LET'S GET THAT OUT OF
THE WAY SO THAT [inaudible]
RIGHT. TO LIFT A CALL.
ON ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS MEASURE WAS
ON CALL [inaudible]
CARILLO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BRADFORD THIS MEASURE WAS ON
CALL CUT LEO.
CARILLO AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK I THAT MEASURE PASSES.
BRADFORD S. B..
NINE SEVEN EIGHT I'M SB THIRTEEN
NO THREE BY SENATOR PANNED THIS
MEASURE WAS ON CALL.
LACKEY NO LACKEY KNOW EVERY YEAR.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN NO PRE BY SENATOR PAN
WO.
CAVIAR AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING QUIRK
[inaudible]
QUIRK I PAN S. B. THIRTY NO --
THREE PASSES.
ON SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN BY SENATOR LARA
THIS MEASURE WITHOUT CALL.
KILEY YOUR EVERY YEAR I KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE.
ITEM S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
LARA THAT MEASURE PASSES.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR LEE ABOUT
THIS MEASURE WAS ON CALL.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE CARILLO.
EARLIER I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES S. B. --
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE LEYVA.
THAT GO TO OTHER ITEMS WHILE
WE'RE WAITING ALRIGHT HOW ABOUT
DEBT CALLING THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD ON BUT IT
WAS A ON ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE CARILLO.
EVERY YEAR I QUIRK [inaudible]
QUIRK I STILL WAITING ON ITEM
[inaudible] ONE OH SURE
[inaudible]
YEAH DIRECTLY.
ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NOW.
ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB.
ELEVEN NINETY CARILLO.
CAVIAR AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY AYE
.
ON ITEM NUMBER TEN SP TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT LARA JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
ON ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR
SKINNER KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN LACKEY.
NO LACKEY NO.
IT WAS COOL
[inaudible]
OR MAYBE
BOTH [inaudible]
REPORTER [inaudible]
ALREADY [inaudible]
WORLD.
ACTUALLY I HAVE ON
ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T EVER TO S. B. WHEN
EIGHTY THREE THIS MOTION WAS TO
PASS TO THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
S. B. SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER THREE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NOT VOTING.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BRADFORD SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM FIVE IS ON CONSENT.
ITEM SIX WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB ELEVEN
SEVENTY SEVEN SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB ELEVEN
NINETY BY SENATOR SKINNER
SANTIAGO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T KNOW NINE WAS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR LATA.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
I DON'T OR TWELVE HAVE NOT BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B.
THIRTY NO THREE PAN SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM FOURTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR HEALTH
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM FIFTEEN S. B. THIRTY NINETY
ONE BY SENATOR LARA'S SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEMS SIXTEEN SP FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE BY SENATOR SKINNER LAR
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM SEVENTEEN SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
SANTIAGO SAN DIEGO I ITEM
EIGHTEEN SB FOURTEEN FORTY NINE
BY SENATOR LEYVA SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NINETEEN S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR HILL
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE OR
PROP BY THE AUTHOR
.
WE ONLY HAVE TEN MORE MINUTES
AND THEN THE COMMITTEE WILL BE.
CLOSE BECAUSE THE OTHER
COMMITTEE NEEDS TO COME EN SO
HOPEFULLY WE GET AUTHOR SOON
[inaudible]
OTHERWISE.
SENATORS AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PRESENT
.
SENATOR BILL.
MOVE NOW SECOND [inaudible]
JUST JUST SIT DOWN IN.
OKAY.
SO WE HAVE SUPPORT SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION WHAT SHOWS
[inaudible]
I YEAH S. B..
ONE FOUR TWO CRIMINAL OFFENDERS
MENTAL HEALTH [inaudible]
NO.
THIRD OR MY WITNESS.
AND FOR THE SAKE OF TIMELINE OF
BLAKE ON BEHALF OF THE A AND THE
PLACE IF YOU LEGAL DEFENSE FUND
HAVE TO ANSWER A QUESTION
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY.
THANK ANY MATTHEWS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JUST A COULD HAVE ENTERED THE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL DOT DROP ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS PART
THANK YOU.
MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY TOMAR
TOKAT ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
TERRORISTS ON BEHALF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE HAVE NO
OFFICIAL POSITION AT ON THE BILL
AT THIS TIME BUT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AND ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CONCEPT.
THANK YOU ARE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
CNN YOU MAY CLOSE [inaudible]
A JEFF LET ME I S. B.
[inaudible]
ONE WELL I DO NEED A FIRST AND
SEC VERY DID WHO DID IT.
WE ARE ALL.
OF COURSE WE WALKED IN I'M SORRY.
WHAT WE'RE GETTING TIRED?
S. B. ONE PARTY TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO CANOE YA I
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE KILEY KILEY
AYE QUIRK.
I QUIRK I SENT PACO [inaudible]
SANTIAGO AYE.
THE MEASURE PASSES IT IT TOOK
YOU LONGER TO COME DOWN HERE.
TO THINK SOME OF THE OTHER.
I NEED ONE MORE MISTER STERN
JUST
[inaudible]
YES STERN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
YOU MAY BEGIN LOOKING LOOPHOLE
IN OUR OUR GUN SAFETY LAWS --
SP TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE AND
I DO APOLOGIZE FOR KEEPING THE
COMMITTEE WAITING I APOLOGIZE
PROFUSELY HERE BUT ALL JUVENILES
DESERVE A SECOND CHANCE AT LIFE
EVEN IF THEY COMMIT A CRIME.
ZERO CHANCE TO GET A CREDIT CARD
LOAN -- ZERO
CHANCE TO GO.
RENT AN APARTMENT GET A JOB
WITHOUT FEAR RETRIBUTION OR SOME
PALL HANGING OVER THEIR HEADS
BUT THAT THE PREMISES BILLS THAT
YOU FORFEIT YOUR RIGHT TO
PURCHASE FIREARM IF YOU MAKE.
THOSE BAD DECISIONS THE YOUNG
PERSON AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF THANK YOU
HIGH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
TOMATO FOUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S.
OFFICE AYE WERE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL --
OUR JOB AS PROSECUTORSIS TO
ENFORCE OUR CRIME LAWS AND ONE
OF THOSE LAWS --
IS A FIREARM LAW THAT BASICALLY
SAYS THAT A PERSON --
MAY NOT OWN OR POSSESS A GUN
UNTIL THE AGE OF THIRTY IF THEY
ARE AS JUVENILES COMMITTED
CERTAIN TYPES OF OFFENSES SUCH
AS ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON
CRIMINAL THREATS ETCETERA.
BUT CURRENTLY THERE'S A CONFLICT
BETWEEN --
OUR FIREARMS LAW AND ARE
JUVENILES --
BECAUSE IN THE JUVENILE COURTS
RECORDS ARE BEING ORDERED SEALED
AND THEN THEY'RE BEING ORDERED
DESTROYED --
AFTER A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME.
AND IN FACT OF MANY OF THESE
RECORDS ARE BEING DESTROYED OF
FIVE YEARS AFTER SEALING.
AND THE CURRENT JUVENILE SEALING
LAWS DO NOT MAKE AN EXCEPTION TO
ALLOW PROSECUTORS TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THE SEALED RECORDS AND THEY
WILL REMAIN SEALED.
UNDER THIS BILL ARM BUT THERE'S
NO EXCEPTION MADE FOR
PROSECUTORS TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE SEALED RECORDS IN AN EFFORT
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION OF
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S BEEN A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN SOMEBODY TURNS. TWENTY
EIGHT OR TWENTY NINE YEARS OLD
AND THEY'RE FOUND IN POSSESSION
OF A GUN IF THE RECORDS ARE
DESTROYED WE HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING THAT THERE WAS A
RESTRICTION ON THE THEIR WELL
OWNING OR POSSESSING A GUN --
UNTIL THE AGE OF THIRTY SO FOR
THAT REASON ALL WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST --
AN AYE VOTE SO THAT'S WE CAN
RESOLVE THE CONFLICT AND THAT WE
CAN --
BETTER --
AND EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCE OUR FIREARMS LAWS THANK
YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES.
I AMANDA WILCOX ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER TO THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE
WE ARE IN SUPPORT KNOW OUR
SIGNATURE ISSUE IS.
BACKGROUND CHECKS --
I'M EVERY GUN SALES SO THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROHIBITED CANNOT
PURCHASE A FIREARM IN THAT'S
BASED ON THE BELIEF THAT THERE
ARE THOSE.
WHO BASED ON THEIR CONDITIONER
PAST BEHAVIOR A GREATER RISK OF --
COMMITTING ACTS OF VIOLENCE AND
PAST VIOLENT BEHAVIOR IS A
PREDICTOR OF FUTURE ACTS OF
VIOLENCE ON TOP OF THAT YOUNGER
PEOPLE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY --
IMPACTED AND WITH CRIME AND OF
VICTIMS OF OF GUN VIOLENCE IF IF
ONE VIEWS A CHART OF HOMICIDE
FIREARM HOMICIDES.
ARE IT DRAMATICALLY.
DROPS AFTER ABOUT AGE THIRTY TWO
SO YOUNGER PEOPLE ARE SO SHADED
WITH --
FIREARM HOMICIDES THAT'S CLEAR.
BEHAVE IT MAKES SENSE THAT THE
PROHIBITION IS ENFORCEABLE TO
AGE THIRTY THREE IN THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS RIGHT NOW.
DEPARTMENT JUST JUSTICE CANNOT
DO CONSISTENT ART BACKGROUND
CHECK BECAUSE OF THE SEALED
RECORDS ISSUE THEREFORE WE'RE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OF OUR ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CALLING QUICK BAY AREA STERN
ACTIVISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
TIFFANY MATHIS SOME BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION
--
MARCO GEORGE WHEN YOU PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION A
REGRETFULLY REGRETFULLY WE MUST
OPPOSE THIS BILL --
AND THEIR TWO REASONS --
ONE OVERALL IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
CHIPPING AWAY AT THE JUVENILE
RECORD CEILING.
AND THEN TO THE SECOND REASON IS
THIS IS ACTUALLY --
THE LEGISLATION IS REDUNDANT AND
UNNECESSARY.
AND CREATES AN ARBITRARY DATE TO
DESTROY THE SEALED JUVENILE
RECORDS BEYOND THE STATUTORY
TIME PERIOD A PERSON CAN BE
RESTRICTED FROM POSSESSING A
FIREARM UNDER EXISTING LAW.
SO -- THE
CASE THAT THE THE ADVOCATES HAVE
SIDED AND ENRAGE OFF TO WORK THE
COURT OF APPEAL CASE.
IT SAID IT HAS ALREADY RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE.
IT'S STATED AND THIS IS IN
REGARD TO TO STATUTES ONE IS IN
THE WELFARE AN INSTITUTIONAL CHO.
ON SEVEN EIGHTY SIX THE OTHER
ONE IS THE PENAL CODE STATUTE
THAT BARS GUN OWNERSHIP --
FOR JUVENILES WHO BEEN CONVICTED
OF MISDEMEANORS BUT HAVE HAD
THEIR RECORD SEALED UNDER THE
WELFARE AN INSTITUTION CODE
SECTION AND IT IT HAD THIS ISSUE.
AND IT SAID WE FIND THE STATUTES
CAN BE RECONCILED AS ALWAYS OUR
ROLE IN STATUTORY INTERPRETATION
IS TO A AFFECT THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
THEREFORE ALTHOUGH WELFARE
INSTITUTION CODE SECTION SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES SEALING THE
RECORD THE FORM DESCRIBED IN
PENAL CODE SECTION. TWENTY NINE
EIGHT TWENTY SUBDIVISION DE IS
EXEMPT FROM THE REQUIREMENT OF
DESTRUCTION FOR THE LIMITED
PURPOSE.
OF DETERMINING ELIGIBILITY TO
ACQUIRE A FIREARM THIS WHILE THE
REST OF THE RECORD MUST BE
SEALED AND DESTROYED BY THE DATE
THE DOOR COURT SPECIFIES.
IN THE ORDER IT WILL ISSUE AFTER
REMAND THE FIRE ARM FORM NEED
NOT BE DOES ORDERED DESTROYED
UNTIL.
THE INDIVIDUALS THIRTIETH
BIRTHDAY SO WE AND THEY WENT ON
TO SAY WE BELIEVE THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE LOWER REQUIRES THIS
OUTCOME AND FURTHER SUPPLY MARY
PURPOSE.
OF BOTH STATUTES.
THE GOAL BEHIND WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE SECTION SEVEN
EIGHTY SIX AS WE READ THE
STATUTE IS TO ALLOW CERTAIN
JUVENILE OFFENDERS WHO HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THEIR
PROBATION. TO LEAD PRODUCTIVE
LIVES WITHOUT THE BLACK MARK
OVER RECORD HANGING OVER THEIR
HEADS FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES.
THE ONLY PURPOSE OF SECTION. TWO
NINE EIGHT TWO OH IS TO PREVENT
THOSE WHO HAVE COMMITTED CERTAIN
OFFENSES AS JUVENILES FROM
OWNING FIREARMS BEFORE THEY TURN.
THIRTY BOARDING ORDERING THE
RECORD SEALED AS REQUIRED BY THE
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION. SEVEN EIGHTY SIX WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
MAINTAIN THE FIRE ARM FORM UNTIL
JOSH WHAT.
TURNS THIRTY THAT WAS BUT GAME
NAME OF THE YOUNG MAN AND THE
CASE WILL SERVE BOTH PURPOSES.
AND FOR THAT PURPOSE.
ON THE FIFTH.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS
PROMULGATED --
A FORM.
AND THIS IS THE FORM THAT THEY
USE ACTUALLY A TWO US SEAL THE
RECORD UNDER.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX AND ON THE BACK
OF THE FORM IT SAYS --
UNDER NUMBER EIGHT ALL RECORDS
PERTAINING TO THE DISMISSED
PETITION ARE TO BE DESTROYED ON
THE DATE STATED IN THE SIDE THEM
IN THEIR ARREST IS DEEMED EVER
TO UP KURT.
EXCEPT THAT THE PROSECUTING
ATTORNEY PROBATION OFFICER CHILD
WELFARE AGENCY AND COURT MAY
ACCESS THESE RECORDS FOR THE
SPECIFIC PURPOSES STATED IN
WELFARE INSTITUTIONS CODE
SECTION.
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX SO IT GIVES
THEM THE RIGHT TO ASK TO GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THE RECORDS.
AND THEN THERE'S AN A IN THE BE
AND IT HAS THE COURT OFFICER
RIGHTS IN THE DATE THE COURT
RECORDS MUST BE DESTROYED.
SO IF THE INDIVIDUAL WAS TO BE
SUBJECT TO THIS THIRTY YEAR ON
PROHIBITION OF NO GUNS.
THE COURT OFFICER RIGHTS IN THE
INDIVIDUALS THIRTIETH BIRTHDAY
THE DA IS PRESENT WHEN THESE
RECORDS ARE SEALED ALL THEY HAVE
TO DO IS SAY.
JUDGE THIS PERSON IS GONNA
MANDATORY GUN PROHIBITION CAN
YOU PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT THESE
RECORDS ARE DESTROYED UNTIL HIS
OR HER THIRTIETH BIRTHDAY.
AND THEN IT SAYS ON BE DATE ALL
OTHER RECORDS MUST BE TO DESTROY
COULD YOU WRAP UP SURE.
SO MANY JUST RIGHT IN THE SAME
THING SO THERE IS THIS IS A
SOLUTION WE FEEL.
WITHOUT A PROBLEM BECAUSE IT'S
ALREADY BEEN SOLVED AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE THE BILL
AND ASK REARED UP.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
I KNOW IN THE PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE A TIMING ISSUE SO I'M WANNA
SAY THAT I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THOSE BILL BUT I
DIDN'T READ AND I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS --
ESSENTIALLY ABOUT --
ALLOWING THE D. A.'S OFFICE TO
GO IN AND POKE AROUND --
UNTIL OF THE PERSON IS --
YOU KNOW THIRTY THIRTY THREE
YEARS OLD AND SO I'M I'M HOPING
YOU KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW FOR SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT OR
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE WE DO KNOW
THAT FOLKS LIKE.
TO HAVE AS WIDE A SCOPE AS
POSSIBLE WHEN THEY WANT TO GO
BACK AND LOOK AT RECORDS AND
WHILE I DO SEE THAT IT STATES
IT'S SPECIFIC FOR THE PURPOSES
RATE RELATED TO A FIREARM
ENFORCEMENT.
YOU KNOW WE SORT OF OPEN ADORN
ALLOW FOR A SLIPPERY SLOPE SO I
HOPE SOMEWHERE IN THERE THERE'S
SOME LANGUAGE THAT ALSO TALKS
ABOUT CONSEQUENCES TO USING THAT
AS AN OPPORTUNITY --
TO NOT JUST FOCUS ON FIREARMS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY CLOSE --
IN RE JOSHUA THE CASE THAT THIS
THIS BILL EMANATES FROM ALSO
STATED THAT.
THE THE VIOLATIONS --
THAT OCCURRED MAY MAKE
ENFORCEMENT OF THAT PENAL CODE
PROVISION MORE DIFFICULT TO
PROSECUTE AND THAT THE STATUTORY.
CONFUSION --
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE IT RESOLVED
BY LEGISLATIVE FIX --
AYE AYE AYE GRANT THAT THERE'S
ALSO A REVISION OF THE FIREARM
FORM -- I
DON'T THINK WE CAN BE TO SAY FOR
THIS POINT TO TO RELY JUST ON A
FORM I THINK THIS THE
LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO STEP IN AND
I DO -- WANT
TO RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE
MISCONDUCT OR DOVES POINT THIS
IS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE --
A SORT OF ENTRY POINT FOR A
BUNCH OF DIGGING IN POKING
AROUND THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
VERY SURGICAL CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE.
IT'S STRICTLY ABOUT THE FIREARM
BUT I WILL TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT
THAT AND I WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORT
SO.
THANK YOU MAKE A FAST RIDE VOTE.
CHAIRS RECOMMENDING I CALLED
ROLE AS HE TOLD RADIO ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER.
DANCER I LACKEY LACKEY I CAN.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
FILL UP.
SO I WANT IT APOLOGIZED TO
PRIVACY IT'S COME IN AFTER WHO
RAN A LITTLE WRONG A LITTLE LONG.
SO I PAUSE AS TO EVERYBODY BUT
BILL DIVIDE FROM A TNT THIS
COMMITTEE STANDS ADJOURNED